Доброго ранечку.
Доброго.
Так, супер. А нас 6 чоловік.
Це так у вас зараз в кінці модуля
или просто спят ще в воскресенье?
Не слуху обратну связь.
Не, не, не, не. Наверно спят ще. Вчора були бодрі, всі полні сил і...
Ну а всі, хто спосле вчора не вижив, то їх проблеми.
Значить, все мистецтво слухати буде наше.
Ми активні слухачі.
Ну, добре, але у нас є запись, це хороші новини.
А у вас вчора була якась-то серйозна тема, да?
Ну, я не можу сказати, що транзактний аналіз – це якась не серйозна тема.
Добре, добре. В любом случае, ми будемо починать.
Я вас приветствую на завершающий четвертый урок со мной.
І в целом у вас обучення MCMM подходит к логическому завершению.
Вы прошли здоров'яний, большущий путь.
Вы больші молодці.
І при этом давайте соберемся.
У нас сегодня с вами 4 часа такой включенной работы.
Важні теми я з вами хотів би сьогодні обсудити.
Прежде всього, кроме тех пунктів, які написані на слайде, я хочу сьогодні затронуть таку тему,
яка на обычних класичних ораторських тренінгах не проходит.
Вот ми з вами изучаємо структуру публичних выступлень, ми з вами изучаємо тони голоса, практикуємо,
Получаємо обратну зв'язку.
Звучимо зв'язку.
Це все наш профіль, адвокат Маріношка.
Ізучимо зв'язку зв'язку.
І при цьому я сьогодні хочу ще глупже поговорити на тему того,
що ми вообще транслируємо, і найголовніше, з якого мотивація.
Тому сьогодні ми розберемо, разогреємся.
Перші 15-20 минут обсудимо головні ошибки оратора,
як на сцені, так і в будь-яких інших форматах.
Ми з вами будемо багато практикувати.
К сожалению, я, це моя ошибка, я перепутав дату нашої лекції,
хотів передупредити вас поранше,
але надіюсь, ви підготовили трьохминутне какое-то выступлення.
Якщо ви не підготовили, окей, чай GPT в допомогу, хоч як-то згенерируйте по структуре аіда, або ескалація, або живой круг 3-5 минут і прочитайте сейчас це з тексту.
Ви должны получати як можна більше практичного опыта такого стресу.
Далі я буду викликать между тематическими блоками 2-3 чоловіка на 3-5 минут, щоб кожен выступив з какой-то своєю інтересною темою.
Після цього ми изучимо тему «Уровні слушання», поговоримо о ненасильственній коммунікації
і осознаємо разницю проявленностей із травм і між проявленностю через здоров'ю позицію, здоров'ю самоценностю,
в більшій мере ісцеленнюю психіку.
І далі підведемо итоги, обговоримо плани на вашу дальнішю проявленностю.
Подніміть руху, будь ласка, хто успею подготовити якусь тему, презенту, щоб я був в курсі просто на якій ми стадії.
Є ли хтось із присутніших, хто подготовив якусь річ для фінального виступлення на 3-5 минут?
Рук нету? Окей, хорошо.
Тоді у нас буде перерівчик в 11.30.
У вас буде 15 минут згенерувати щось в GPT.
Але до перерівчика теж два чоловіка я б хотіла вызвати.
Тому ви можете зараз щось згенерувати.
Ну да, в общем чаті куратори просили, там домашнє задання таке було.
Але не суть, розберемося, все буде нормально, ми же свої люди.
Итак, главні ошибки оратора.
Давайте вспомним, по сути, все, що ми проходили,
але зараз більше в такому концентрированному форматі.
Коли людина говорить, що він боїться публічних виступлень,
він відпочиває страх, правильно я вигляжу, а то ли на мене одето,
а все ли хорошо я підготовився.
Чаще всего це фокус внимання і мотивання,
що спікер, оратор, він тут, зараз для себе і про себе, а не про людей.
Це головний закон маркетингу.
Ми для людей, ми фокусуємося на їхніх болях, на їхніх цінностях, на їхніх потребностях,
даємо їм быстрі решення їхніх, потребностей, біль.
І коли спікер думає про себе, як я вигляжу, що сказати, як не облажатися,
У нього це – следствие цього егоцентричного умовостроення,
з-за якого і відбувається страх, зажим,
нет контакта з аудиторією, тяжело її включити, і так далі, і так далі.
Тобто, лайфхак какой – це перевести фокус з себе,
в хорошому смыслі цього слова, на інших.
Що у них болить, хто вони, з чим вони прийшли,
що вони хочуть, як я можу їм лучшим образом це дати.
Ми фокусуємося на них
Простій пример
Є чоловік, який сподіває жажду в пустыні
І коли ми їм даємо чисту воду
Ми не думаємо в цей момент, як ми виглядемо
С лівої руки нам дати бутылку
С правої руки нам дати бутылку
Присість, нагнуться
Ми їм даємо то, що йому потрібно
Тому в чому нуждається
А якщо в момент того, як я в пустыні буду думати о себе
правильно ли я зробив, що він подумає, то це, я думаю, о себе зациклено.
Тобто головний принцип – це сострадання і навык видити мир із глаз нашій аудиторії.
Це ми розуміли першу житку оратора, коли він про себе, а не про людей.
Далі. Це такий легкий розогребчик, щоб ви немножечко включилися перед нашою практикою.
Друга ошибка оратора – це желання понравитися всім.
На самому першому уроку, я вам напомню, ми обсуждали таку тему, що є три вида аудиторії – ваше, не ваше.
Эта тема дуже срезонувала в нашому обществі.
Ми говорили о тому, що немає ніякого смисла. Нравиться всім, є смысл знайти своїх і успокоїться.
І при цьому всім бессознательно ми все одно можемо хотіти понравитися всім.
В абстрактной толпе. І це проявляється в тому, що спікер, він як би зглаживає угли, становиться удобним для всіх. Лиш би не затронуть нічі границі і одновременно угодити всім. А це по факту нев
озможно.
І тому виходить, що немає енергії, немає харизми, а харизма – це коли я розумію свої цінності, і з них проистекають определені ціли, і я прям ярко горю і йду к ним.
І там завжди є, що я люблю, що я не люблю, що мені подобається, що мені не подобається. За що я і проти чого я.
Мотивация «за що я» і проти чого я, вона може бути із его, вона може бути травматична, вона може бути чиста.
Це більша віддільна тема, але факт остається фактом.
Коли ми становимося удобними для всіх, ми перестаємо бути личністю.
Личністю в якому-то смыслі.
Своїм определенним мінемо о себе, о цьому мірі, о продукці, як правильно, як неправильно.
За цим к нам люди приходять, за чіткими границами.
Далі. Третья ошибка оратора – це коли немає внутреннього розрішення говорити.
Знамений синдром самозванца. Кто я вообще такой? Что я можу дати?
Коли ми не присвоили свій прошлій опит, обучення, реалізацію, успішних кейсів, личну трансформацію, ми це не присвоили. Возникає отсутствие розрішення говорити, і в зв'язі з цим на сцені проявляється
тихий голос, ніяка сжатая енергія, нету влияния на аудиторію.
Я напомню, що головний смысл публичних выступленьів на сцені, для мене, який перед собою ставлю, – це трансформація.
Це коли людина після вашого виступлення, він мається, у нього мається убеждення, соответственно, мається його вибори, дійства і те результаты, які він получає.
Я зараз говорю не о образовательних выступлениях, як ми с вами взаємодіюватися,
хоча образовательні продукти теж можна робити трансформаційні.
Я говорю именно о трансформаційному выступліні,
коли є хоч якась така яркость до і після фільма, до і після книги, до і після выступлення, до і після контакта з вами.
Не просто вы вышли і розказали якісь тезиси, прочитали конференцію, як ми зараз занимаємся, а именно щоб злочився інформаційний чи емоційний інсайт.
Інформаційний чи емоційний інсайд?
По сути, це все, що ми і викликаємо у клієнтів, у аудиторії,
як на сцені, так і в личному форматі того ж коучинга
чи інших психотерапевтичих направлень.
Ми викликаємо інформаційний інсайд у клієнта,
або емоційний інсайд, який його менеється в зависість від його запросу.
Це, якщо так концентрично сказати.
Далі. Четвертая ошибка оратора – це коли немає структур.
Коли ми йдемо на сцену, у нас є 5-10 минути, 30 минути чи час.
Ми можемо бути в потокі неподготовлені, якщо це наша аудиторія, якщо все вже глубоко в контексті.
І формат мероприятия це розполагає.
Але якщо нас мало, хтось знає, чи ми ведемо конкретний урок,
то в нас повинна бути структура.
Тому що коли спікер говорить із потоку, що відбувається?
У адіторії теряється увагу,
Звичайно, немає конкретного смыслу цього концентрованого трансформаціонного обучення
чи виступлення, і, соответственно, немає никаких результатів.
Ми просто послухали, запомнили какую-то ментальну картинку
і пошли в кафе їсть вареники з вишнію чи пиццу з сыром.
Ну, і все. Трансформація не случилась.
Щоб довести чоловіка до змінений, до трансформації, ми повинні його прогріти, довести до кульминації, о чому ми говорили з вами на 3-м предыдущому занятті. А щоб довести до кульминації, у нас должен
бути чіткий алгоритм, структура, що в начальні, що в середні, як ми переходимо к цій кульминації, яку розв'язку в тому даємо. Довжна бути ніяка структура.
І для того, щоб она була, на прошлом занятий ми з вами изучали порядка десяти структур,
які ми можемо заблаговременно вибирати, виходя на сцену.
Це саме знаменитое Аида, ескалація, живой круг, арка героя, пять фактов і так далі.
Все те, які ми изучали.
Желательно, це навіть не желательно.
Якщо ми говоримо о трансформаційних виступленьях,
то обязательно по цій структури готовитися заблаговременно.
Іначе, якщо ви обесцениваєте цей пункт,
то получается, що ви виходите на сцену,
це як ярмарка тщеслава для себе.
Тобто немає ціли довести чоловіка до кульминації,
я не розумію, як працює його ум,
щоб у нього реально залишилися змінення.
Мені все ровно на це.
Я просто вихожу, я є, я яркий, я харизматичний, мені хлопають.
Все, як виступив? Прекрасно.
Як у клієнта змінення? А не знаю, не знаю, мені хлопали.
Поэтому, щоб довести до результата, дозна бути структура.
Ми учитываем ум, природу, аудиторію.
Ісходясь, звісно, з вашої теми, з вашої ниши і так далі.
Але об цьому в третьому предыдущому заняті ми подробно говорили.
Пятая ошибка оратора.
Ну, це необязательний, це зараз в наш век СДВГ, клипового мышління.
Це так називаємий хук.
Нет крючка в начале.
Этот пункт, він такий спорний, але є осознанна аудиторія, в якій не потрібні хуки.
Вони знают вас, вони приходять, вони включаються, вони готові слушатися, вони впитують, їм интересно.
Почему так происходит, чуть позже расскажу, коли дійдемо до теми уровня слушання.
Але це в нашій зоні відповідальності в початку зробити дофаминний інтерес,
як в маленькому рілзі, так і в величому відступленні,
чи в продаючому вебинарі, щоб чоловіку було легче, інтересніє і корисніє
дослухати до конца і, відповідно, пройти по той структури,
яку ми йому пропонували, щоб у нього відбувала внутрішня трансформація,
яка збавить його від деструктивних розумінів себе цього світу
і дасть йому більш конструктивне розуміння себе цього світу
і приведе його до більшого рівняння щастя.
Василь, віжу твою руку. Говори, будь ласка.
Так, вітаю. У мене питання щодо фуку.
Я зараз їду на конференцію і буду спікером.
Я — другий спікер. І я їду в футболці, де є моя фотка, і знизу пише «Я є Василь Бугель і це є моя суперсила».
Тобто я — другий спікер. Це не буде вав-ефектом, коли вийду на сцену.
Але в мене питання, якщо я вийду на сцену і повторюю цю фразу «Я є Василь Бугель і це моя суперсила»,
це буде рахуватись хуком, чи вже, проходити, що футболка не є вав-ефектом, що вже мене в годину побачили, не буде?
Я дякуюсь, як відповідати на цей питання. Я думаю, може бути да, може бути нет, але чітно признаюсь, я в контексті хуків прямо не експерт.
Прямо не експерт. Хуки — це все следствие нашого періоду, эпохи СДВГ і кліпового мішління.
І це більша тема манипуляцій. Я завжди це обесценивал, ігноривав, мені це не важливо.
Я сам не сильно реагирую на хуки, і якщо я вибрав себе учителя-наставника, то я прям можу 3-5 часів слушати його неманипулятивні лекції.
Але на конференціях, так, це умісно робити.
Якщо ви не знаєте, з чого почати,
ну, блин, GPT три минути згенерирує вам 10 хуків,
і ви виберете інтуїтивно, учитывая ваш контекст.
Так що, Василий, чувствуй не логикою,
а чувствуй прямо очіщеннями телом.
Це буде чи не буде?
Вот як-то так.
Все, що я можу. Прости, якщо не совершенно...
Ні-ні-ні, мені б просто була ідея початися фрази про недолюблених, або ось ось ця, тобто якби цю футболку ніхто не бачив до цього, це точно можна було б почати, був би хук.
І собі думав, ну, типу, саму структуру знаю, а ось над хуком таким, щоб він був відносно екологічним, ну, тільки в роздумах, тому якось так.
Дякую, почуваю.
Благодарю. Але якщо говорити о хуках, то основний принцип – хук – це те, що вдохнує людина, здає у нього інтерес дослухати. А інтерес у людина – це коли говорять о нім, о його болях, о його конфлікті
, чи дають какую-то провокацию, що-то, що цепляє його, тригерит, що-то, що о нім.
Якщо ми говоримо «я, Василь Бугель, це моя суперсила», це більше про Василия все-таки.
Якщо там у тебе вже є своє ком'юнити, своя, условно, мини-секта, ну, в хорошем смыслі цього слова, це може бути прикольно.
Якщо це холодна аудиторія, то краще, конечно, сфокусуватися, задати себе питання,
Вот що чоловік должен услышать перші 5-10 секунд, а це чоловік егоїстично сконцентрирован на себе,
що він должен услышати, щоб захотеться і давати мне своє время, внимание і енергию?
Що він должен про себе услышати?
Тобто принцип завжди один і той же.
Ми не поступаємо перед людьми, ми общаємося з ними.
А коли ми общаємося з людьми, ми розпринимаємо їх як Личності,
маємо дивитися на мир через їх гляда і розуміємо їх.
Тому головний принцип такий, що людина має слухати, щоб йому було вигідно і интересно влажити саме ценне, що у нього є.
В своє час побыть з нами в цьому рівсі чи в цьому конференції.
Вот такий принцип. І коли ми принцип розуміємо, ми можемо применити його в будь-якій унікальній ситуації.
Тобто немає смысл обучати вас тисячу разным хукам, щоб ви їх заучили.
Є смысл дати принцип.
І коли ми цей принцип розуміємо, ми його в свою любу унікальну ситуацію
в будь-якому місті, в будь-якій країні, на будь-якій сцені можемо применити.
А принцип – це що? Человек має услышати, щоб захотеть включити дофаминомо в мене зараз.
Дальше. Шеста ошибка оратору – це нет призыва к якому-то действию. Я буквально вчера проводил урок, заміняв одного педагога у нас в Одесі офлайн, і там дівчина одна выступала, прекрасно выступила, в
ступление, три факта о себе, очень класна тема у нее була, вдохновляюча.
Дала все по пунктам, як робити. Кульминація така ярка була, а потім просто не закінчила призивом к дійсню.
Ну, і все. Типа, спасибо, я закінчила. Ну, то есть не було, після цієї кульминації слилась без призива к дійсню.
І виходить, що виступлення було, було яке, але воно було таке развлечення, а щоб були трансформації, якісь результати, продажи, треба прям проговарувати вслух той призов, куди ви ввели человека на
протяжі всього вашого виступлення.
Переходіть по ссылці, покупайте, просыпайтеся рано по утрам, скидайте донат, ну, конкретний призов.
Це важливо. Ми можемо понимати, що це для чоловіка і так понятне, само собою розуміющееся, але ніфига не понятне буває іноді.
Тобто ми, коли виступаємо, ми, можна так сказати, емоціональний інтелект у нас вищає средністатистичній маси, і в нас є склонасть судити людей по себе.
Тобто, якщо для мене це понятно, само собою розуміющееся щось, то і для всіх це буде понятно.
Але по опыту моєму непонятно.
Вот, хто це говорив вам, маркетолог?
То ли Дэн Кеннеди, то ли хто?
Ну, треба з вашей аудиторією в хорошем смыслі,
як з дітьми маленькими.
Це модна фраза.
Щоб було понятно пятикласнику, який в очках.
Вот якщо пятикласникам, ви розказали, йому непонятно,
значить половина зала теж не услышит контекст.
При цьому це искусство, і не так, щоб я був в цьому великим примером,
але в своїх тренингах, семинарах, у мене в основному це офлайн, все йдет,
Я розумію цей принцип і максимально розжовуваю, як можу, як получается, учитываю свою обусловленність.
Знаєте, коли приглашаю тренера по актерським чи ораторським практикам провести щось,
в даному випадку даже здесь, на ММСММ, то може возникати таке ожидання у вас,
а як же буде його речі, як він все филигранно говорить, скільки буде приемів, хуков і так далі.
Але ні, я ж такий же самый обикновений парень, і вот ці навыки, у них немає предела совершенства.
Це знаєте, як в спорте є перший розряд, кандидат мастера спорта, мастер спорта, мастер спорта міждународного класа, заслуженний, чемпіон Олимпийських игр.
І щоб виступати публічно, в принципі нам можна освоїть там рівень «Первий розряд КМС».
Це вже нам виступати для того, щоб виступати публічно.
А там филигранне мастерство, як лучший в мире оратор – це вже сочетання і внутреннього гения, і внутрення мотивація і сострадання, і маркетингового мишління,
і врожденних способностей талантов.
Але до уровня КМС довести можна кожного.
І цього вистачає, щоб проявлятися в блогі,
виступати публічно, вести конференції,
якісь вебинари, ефіри і т.д.
Тому безперфекціонизм, будь ласка.
Хорошо.
Як ви? Включені?
Поставте сердечко лайк, слушайте.
Це таке легке вступлення к нашій сьогоднішній части.
Отлично. Благодарю.
Далі, седьмая ошибка – це монотонність.
На прошлом занятии ми з вами изучали тони голосом.
І якщо ми не меніемся, ми одинакові, як в начальні, в середіні, в кульминації, в кінці.
Якщо ми не робимо паузи, якщо ми не повищаємо голос, не даємо енергию,
як так монотонно, все время, вас буде слухати тільки ваші фанати і розуміти.
Ваші фанати, коих там 1-10%.
Але щоб позаботитися аудиторії, ми включаємо тонну голосу,
Ми включаємо енергию, включаємо паузи, включаємо тон мудреца, тон воїна, друга, волшебника, учитывая місто, время, обстоятельства.
І таким образом більше количество людей може з нами соединиться.
На прошлом занятий ми прямо училися з вами, говорили одну і ту ж фразу разними тонами голоса.
І щас вилетелось з голови, що я хотів сказати.
Ну, значить, не щас, секундочку.
Вот, вспомнил.
При цьому нам не треба робити це искусственно і механістично.
Ми, коли настраємось на людей,
либо в зале живому смотримо на конкретні лиця,
у нас все наше внутренне естество, нейрологічний уровень,
всі ці внутрішні кодіровки, вони самі собою настраюваються на чистоту цього чоловіка,
якщо ми з ним з'єднаємся.
Коли ми говоримо на камеру, записуємо відео на ютуб, я вам рекомендував що?
Кто помнит, що я вам рекомендував?
Кто помнит, що я вам рекомендував, Лера?
Що?
Персоналізувати.
Персоналізувати. Умничка, Лера. А що значить персоналізувати? Молодець.
То, що ми говоримо, говорити комусь конкретному.
Либо какому-то конкретному чоловіку,
либо какой-то конкретній групі людей,
щоб це було персоналізовано.
Да, ми представляємо, молодец, благодарю,
ми представляємо конкретну личність.
Вот у вас є два-три ваших ідеальних кліента,
с которими, коли ви общаєтесь на личних ссіях
или ведете им тренинги, вас прям несет, у вас поток,
Ви чувствуєте себя хорошо, і чувствуєте, що ви вконтакте.
І ви можете прямо в фотографії перед камерою їх приклеити і для них, конкретно в них обращаться.
І тогда у вас 90% ошибок, які ми обсуждаємо, вони уйдуть.
Не буде монотонності, тому що ви будете для личності, а не для лінзи какой-то абстрактной.
Персоналізувати. Плюс 5 очков Гриффиндор. Лера Резник.
Хорошо. Ну, давайте, це важна тема.
Тільки Лера вспомнила, ви можете зараз представити
человека, с которим у вас були якісь кармічні відношення.
Це може бути ваші родини, бувші партнеры,
хто-то, хто вас критикував, обесценивав і так далі.
І, допустим, можливо, зараз ви вже протерапевтировали, проработали ці відношення,
у вас там вже немає емоційних проявлень, коли через триггер ці люди на вас дивляться,
чи вам щось роблять, чи, можливо, ви вже з ними не взаємодієте.
Але, якщо ви вспомните свою проявлення для цих людей,
Наприклад, я выступав на відкритті свого пространства і в зале сидів мій отчим.
І в мене відбувається стід, куди-то голос починає дрожати, ком в горі, просто тому, що це чоловік в зале.
Зараз вже такого, звісно ж, немає.
Але якщо я буду вести блог, ютуб, інстаграм в надіжні, що посмотрє цей чоловік,
то що у мене буде? Два варіанта розвиття событий.
Либо я буду максимально перфекционистично, суперразжовано, максимально филигранно своим контентом доказывать этому человеку,
Ну, пойми же, ну вот я какой.
Либо у вас буде отсутствие проявленности из-за страха, стыда,
що вот этот человек увидит і як-то осудит, закритикує, оценив, не поймет, захейтит,
не знаю, там, изгонит из стаи і так далі.
Поэтому, коли ми фокусуємося на совмістиму,
о чому ми говорили на першому занятиї, можете в записи пересмотреть,
На конкретних личностях, с которими у нас є совместимость,
которые нам благодарны, у нас все ошибки решаются.
Вот по сути це все, що нам потрібно.
Поняти, хто свої, а хто не свої.
І для них своїми суперсилами служити, як може, без перфекціонизму.
Ідемо далі.
Восьмая ошибка – це перегруз логикой, коли немає емоцій.
Тобто ми зараз говоримо про виступлення на сцені 30 минут,
чи ефір якийсь, де є одна цель, одна тема.
Не як ми сьогодні, коли в нас 4 часа, і ми затрагуємо три більші теми.
У нас іде обучаючий формат, образовательний.
А коли ви виходите в інстаграм, в прямой ефір,
коли ви виходите на сцену, коли ви снимаєте один ріюс,
ви хочете донести какую-то одну ключевую ідею,
але перегружаєте це логикою без емоцій.
Тобто багато знань, багато чувств.
Запомнят вас тільки те, у кого природа така інтелектуально-задротская.
Це не хоро, але включає нас емоція.
Ми запомінаємо состояние.
В більшій степені, ми, коли виходимо після фільма, після книги, після выступлення якогось,
ми забуваємо половину, що говорив спікер,
але запомінаємо то состояние і головний меседж, який був упакований в це состояние.
Боже, Анна на этой ключевой фразі аж зимула.
Я чому-то заметил, именно її.
Ана ми приходить.
Ой, смеється.
Хорошо.
Да, ідемо далі.
Ага, переключилась, отлично.
Та ж ошибка, о которой ми тільки що проговорили, це не контакт с аудиторією, коли ми говоримо в стену, в камеру, а не в личності. Об цьому я вже тільки що сказав, ми представляємо конкретних личност
ей, якщо ми онлайн, або ми соединяємося з конкретними личностями, якщо ми оффлайн.
І тоді у нас відбувається вовлеченість, тоді це вже діалог, тоді общення, а не монолог і не виступлення.
Тобто ми можемо задавати питання в зал, ми можемо просити реакції якісь у людей, ми можемо їх як-то включати.
Ну, наприклад, якщо ми не спешили, а ми зараз не спешимо, давайте я вас включу.
Тон і голос, чим вони відличаються.
Прямо зараз, кому удобно, хто не за рулём,
давайте плечи скукожим, голову опустимо вниз,
і таке умонастроення жертвы.
І в цьому стані, прямо з виключеним мікрофоном, скажіть любу фразу.
Типа, главна ошибка оратора – це нет контакта з аудиторією.
Прямо утрируєте, утрируєте, як будто ви плохой актєр і максимально на 100-градусну емоцію ви зараз утрируєте жертву.
В общем, да, лекція була, ну, да.
Вот, і це ваш вайб. А тепер наоборот, ми можемо плечи розправити, руки вверх. І головна ошибка оратора – це нет контакта з аудиторією. Ну, я щось футрирую. То есть у нас м'якається, да?
І таким образом, в чому суть цього маленького упражнення?
Якщо ми хочемо бути настоячими, а головна ціль психологічного театру,
який я преподаю оффлайн, це дати людину можливість бути собою
і на сцені бути простим, настоячим, естественним,
то щоб достичь простоти, нам потрібно зрозуміти, що таке фальш.
Наприклад, фізичне теле.
Щоб воно розслабилось, до цього воно працюється, в тренажерному залі, наприклад, і потім буде розслаблення.
Точно так же і тут, щоб достичь настоящесть,
мені потрібно де-то, наприклад, дому, коли ніхто не вийде, зрозуміти, що таке фальш.
Коє я, коли я жертва? Коє я, коли я мотиваційний спікер?
Коє я, коли я комусь щось доказую? Коє я, коли я оправдуюсь?
А «какой я», коли я – це я. Обичний, настоящее, аутентичне.
Короче, контакт, включайте аудиторию.
Так, давайте перед тем, как мы… У нас ще тут 4 или 5 пунктов є.
Я би хотів одного чоловіка включити, і прямо, щоб він виступив на 3-5 минути,
Якщо хто є, такий готовий.
Це, звісно, з відсутнім подготовленних скриптів, така складність.
Але давайте справимося. Анастасія включила митрофончик.
Я кажу, що це ви придумали.
Це все, що я хотіла в своєму виступліні сказати.
Мов'ярко розказати о пяти стадіях принятия.
Коли я не слухала,
почему я опять пропустила момент,
що потрібно виступати.
Настя, ну якщо хочете,
можеш розказати про це буде актуально.
Давай три минути виступлення.
Якщо немає, то перерывчик буде в 11.30,
і кожен підготовить за 15 минут
какую-то речі на 3-5 минут.
Що думаєш, зараз чи після перерыва?
Не, навіть після перерыва.
Мне треба потрібно випити чашечку кофі.
Ну все, хорошо, тогда после перерыва.
Тогда после перерыва, тогда идем дальше по нашим слайдикам.
Подскажите, пожалуйста, какая хоть тема, на какую тему выступить надо?
Я що-то прослушав, наверное.
Да, смотрите, вы прослушали, потому что я перепутал чуть-чуть даты
и поздно предупредил кураторов, но они написали в чатик
такое домашнее задание, чтобы каждый приготовил короткое финальное выступление
на наш сьогоднішній урок на 3 минуты, максимум 5, на любую тему,
которая вам интересна, актуальна, значима, не знаю, пользу учить английський,
пользу бегати по утрам, пользу коучингу, пользу пити воду по утрам вместо кофе,
любое, що-то чисто, щоб попрактиковатися, на 3-5 минут по той схеме,
которую я давав в прошлый раз, а я давав около 10 схем, аида, ескалація, живой круг,
і так далі, і так далі.
Зараз ми виявилися в той ситуацією,
коли немає підготовленних віступлений ні у кого.
Тому я пропоную в перерыві, в 11.30,
у нас буде перерыв,
ви быстренько виберете тему
і згенерируєте в GPT,
прям по такому промту.
Напиши мені тему на 3-5 минут
для публичного віступлення,
на таку-то тему по схеме АИДА,
или ескалація.
І ви просто прочитаєте тут вслух при всіх, для того, щоб отримати практичний опит проявленності,
тому що хтось із вас проявляється багато, а хтось проявляється мало.
І чим більше ви проявляєтесь в тренувачному форматі, тим легше вам буде це робити вживую.
Вот так вот. Елена, відповіла?
Да, да, зрозуміла, дякую.
Пожалуйста. Василий, слушаю.
Якщо потрібно виступити, в мене є своя схема в голові, я можу зупинитися 3-5 хвилин, спокійно виступити, поїхати далі, якщо це потрібно для системи.
У тебе зараз буде це виступлення ще й на сцені, так?
Частинка, невеличка частинка, так.
Давай, Василь, давай.
Окей, зараз я скажу своїм пасажирам.
Дівчата, я на три хвилинки зупинюся, скажу по цьому, і тоді це good.
Все, зараз я паркуюся, бо я можу й по дорозі поїхати, але тоді не буде контакту з сценою.
Давай, ти поки паркуєшся, я розкажу следуючу ошибку.
Я вже є.
А, давай, все, тоді...
Окей.
Тоді...
Мене добре чути?
Да, добре чути.
Вітаю! Мене звати Василь Бугель, і це моя суперсила.
Ті ми в житті недолюблені, недокохані, і так ми будуємо свій особистий бренд.
І зараз я хочу трішки з тобою поділитись тим, яким чином цей бренд формувався і на що він впливає.
Всі ми знаємо красномовного трикутника Карпмана. По натисність сердечка, хто з вас чув про агресора, рятівника і також жертву? Є сердечко? Є, Лєра, дякую тобі, кайф.
Давайте уявимо, що трикутник Карпана – це школа, і він своєрідно є токсичний. Всі ми знаємо, що потрібно бути спостерігачем і виходити із цього трикутника.
А якщо цей трикутник перенести в школу? Тобто, життя – це є хронічна школа, так? Які головні герої є в школі? Скажіть, будь ласка, можете включати мікрофончик, можете писати, мікрофончиком буде мені
навіть комфортніше.
Які, на вашу думку, для кого створена школа? Хто головний герой?
Ученики, учні.
Учні, так, вірно. І якщо ми розглядаємо, що головний герой – учень, та, щодо трикутника Картмана, хто тоді щодо учнів виступає агресором?
Хто в школі є агресор?
Для учнів.
Учителя, так, тобто ми формуємо зверху учні, справа – вчителі, так, і залишається зліва, знизу рятівник, стандартному трикутнику Картмана.
А хто може виступати рятівником для учня в процесі навчання?
Родітелі.
Другий вчителі чи родітель?
Родітель, так?
Ось, і...
Фізрук, хотіла сказати фізрук.
Фізрук, фізрук, красавчик, фізрук, дякую тобі.
Самий головний предмет в школі – це фізкультура, все остальні не важливо.
Ось так говорив фізрук.
Так, твій коментар прямо сердечко, я теж люблю фізкультуру, і це прям кайф.
А тепер давайте перейдемо, якщо в школу. Цей самий трикутник, учень, викладач і батьки, він може бути і токсичним, і не токсичним.
Як думаєте, від чого залежить, чи це стане токсичним, чи ні, якщо брати в розрізі відповідальності учня? За яких умов той трикутник буде токсичним, а за яких умов він буде благосприятливий для цього
самого учня? По відповідальності. Які у вас є варіанти?
Якщо ученик буде хорошим, приємним, відпитаним,
добре вчитися, приносити хороші оцінки,
то він не буде токсичним для вчителей,
буде хорошим для родителів.
Спасати родителям не треба.
Так, окей. Але тоді наскільки він буде хорошим для себе
в цій кожурі, яку ти сказала?
Ну, таке себе.
Таке себе, так?
А що дуже часто батьки можуть робити для учня, для своїх дітей, коли вони навчаються?
Понімати.
Понімати, от. От якщо понімати, то це буде оцей здоровий, так?
А якщо ми говоримо токсичний, то що батьки роблять?
Ругають.
Ругають або роблять за учня домашнє завдання, правда?
Багато тут є мамів, можливо, таків немає, Юра, немає дітей, хто робить домашньо за дітей або з навіть дітьми, поставте реакцію, хто це робить, хто допомагає, так?
А ну, чи є сердечко? Поки що нема. Вау, тут всі прямо усвідомлені, клас.
Дизлайки можна ставити?
Дизлайки, так.
І тепер дивіться, якщо батьки, тобто в учні є 100% відповідальність, так?
І якщо батьки цю відповідальність перетягують, та сама формула 80 на 20.
Якщо в учнях відповідальність 20%, в батьків 80, це токсичний, вони перетворюються в рятівників.
Якщо учень бере на себе 80%, а батьки до 20%, це оцей здоровий трикутник Карпана. І до чого я взагалі це все веду? Якщо життя – це школа, і агресорів, і рятівників уникнути неможливо.
Можливо тільки зрозуміти свою зону відповідальності, свою зону творіння, своє ось це і я є, що у мене написане на футболці, і переходити в цей здоровий трикутник, брати добрих 80% відповідальності за
своє життя, борити, наповнюватись.
І саме про це я буду ділитися вже наступного вівторка і четверга на своєму проєкті. Гроші X20 – це можливо. Про те, як я взяв відповідальність, створив твій масштаб, створив дохід в 20 разів більше,
ніж 2 роки тому, і тебе я запрошую.
І сьогодні спеціально для тебе є спеціальна ціна 500 гривень.
Це найнижча ціна.
І вже всі, хто там є, 50 людей, мають...
Аплодисменты.
Аплодисменты Василію, пожалуйста.
Аплодисменты Василію.
Красавчик, красавчик.
Прекрасне виступлення.
Это просто уровень, человек на обочині.
Зразу же зі своїми виступають серед людей на обочині, в машині, гдє угодно.
Ціхо, ціхо, я не дозалучив людей.
І всі, хто вже оплатили і є разом зі мною, а менше 50, вже від вчора мають медитацію і любові до себе, а сьогодні будуть мати медитацію внутрішнього розширення.
Якщо тобі відгукується твоє серце, запрошую тебе і дякую, що в цей момент ти була зі мною.
Карта посилання у мене в шапці профіля. Запрошую.
Так, у тебе QR-код повинен бути на спині.
QR-код є на спині, але я не обернуся вже.
Ось це хук буде, якщо QR-код на спині, а не на екрані. Це прямо хук.
Він є, він є на футболці, єдине, що він не щитується гарно, він буде і там, і там.
Кайф, кайф.
Василий, прекрасно, мені взагалі все подобається, у нас немає бутерброду, у нас сплошні булочки комплиментів тобі.
Тобто ти прекрасно почав, мені дуже льстить, що ти взяв мій хук про недолюбленість, безціненність, закритикованість.
Пользуйся на здоров'ю, будь ласка.
Вот це прекрасний хук, з якого можна почати, це те, що включає.
Це прям супер.
Тебе відкликнулося, це почував, і тому взяв.
Мене дуже подобається, як ти включаєш аудиторію, задаєш випроси.
Виступлення Василия на процентах 60 і даже 80 состояло із випросів.
І це дійсно відповідь. Це постійна включенність.
Зритель постійно... Мозг вибрирує на частоті обучення.
Почему видно Василий?
Алло, алло, алло, алло, да.
То есть мозг постоянно включен, зритель максимально вовлечен в контент, который Василий дает.
То есть как можно більше вопросов.
У него все выступление построено на вопросах.
Берите себе, пользуйтесь на здоров'ю.
Василий, благодарю тебя за такой пример.
Единственный момент, когда мы включаем аудиторию в вопросы постоянно,
У Василия сейчас не було такої ошибки, но я наблюдаю. У других, знаєте, разумних душнил, они с помощью цих вопросів ставлять себе выше аудиторії і так логически придираються к несовершенствам ауди
тории на ответ. Таке делать категорически запрещаю.
Тобто ви задаєте ці питання не для того, щоб поднятися на аудиторію, а для того, щоб їх включити і так логически ввести до цієї кульминації.
Це суперсила ввести лекцію через питання.
А вже непосередньо кульминація в Василия була просто огонь.
Призов, вивод, що треба зробити, видно, що підготовлено, прекрасно, все отлично.
Над аутентичністю подачи кожен вже інтуїтивно чувствує, працює.
Тобто, якщо у вас є цінності простоти аутентичності,
ви без моїх рекомендацій з кожним разом будете становитися більш настоячими.
Але це цінності не у всіх.
Василий, браво, молодец, благодарю, супер-пупер, прекрасного тебе відступлення.
Ідею з QR-кодом на футболці беру себе.
Хорошо, так, презентацию поделитися, і йдемо далі.
Десятая ошибка оратора – це сильно быстро і сильно много.
Якщо ви обратили увагу на Василия, у нього не було сильно быстро, у нього були паузи, у нього не було сильно много.
Він включив, ввел в контекст, і свій головний вивод упаковал буквально в 3-5 минут.
Все, мені прям хочеться заплатити ему 500 гривень.
Так.
Щас.
Да.
Дякую за перегляд, що ми сподіваємося дуже умно імеється ввідомо.
Смотрите, багато з вас, наверное, обучалися в якій-то уникальних общинах.
Не знаю, хто-то в коучингі, хто-то в кармотусовці, хто-то в якій-то религії.
І в каждій організації є своя термінологія.
Свої слова якоря, які вводять в контекст той чи інші теми.
І якщо ми знаємо ці слова, це не значить, що аудиторія їх знає.
Ну не знаю, пограничне растрійство личності, невротик, чи що-то таке.
Те, хто не изучав КПТ, не відповідають взагалі, в чому різниця.
І коли ми умнічаємо такими словами, аудиторії нічого не зрозуміло.
Поэтому, вместо того, щоб транслировати сложні формулировки, я предлагаю внутренній транслейт-переводчик на язик шкільника пяти лет.
Щоб ви не теряли аудиторію, таким образом говорить максимально просто.
Давайте вже закінчимо сьогодні з ошибками і підемо далі вглубі наші теми.
Не у всіх, але у большинства, не у большинства, не знаю, 10-20-30% у мене немає чіткої статистики,
але є такий опит, що багато говорять не із свого опыта, т.е. пересказывають знання.
І ладно, якщо це ще знання від інших учителей, які їм достались,
Але багато людей пересклюють просто знання, які вони дозволили в АИшки, в GPT чи інших неросетях.
По моєму опыту це не дає пользу.
Якщо ми говоримо про трансформаційних выступлених, це не має серця.
Серця має емоція, наповнена внутрішній силі.
На санскріпці це називається енергія шахти.
Я зараз умничаю терміном, а якщо перевести на наш простой язык, то це енергія від реалізованого опыта.
Коли ми не просто що-то знали, я прочитав в книгі, яка клубника на вкусь, і я вам даю цю клубнику, теж текстом.
Второй рівень – це коли я сам спробував клубніку, але вам даю книгу «Какая клубніка на вкус». А задача – дати людину на вкус клубніку, щоб він прожив цей опыт.
То есть, яким-то особи через своє виступлення погрузити його в це стане,
чи щоб після вашого виступлення він зробив практичне дійсно,
проснувся рано утром, побежав робити зарядку і получив цей вкус.
Але щоб вдохновити чоловіка почати, ми повинні мати цей бутійний опит.
Я не знаю, імеє ли смысл об цьому как-то говорити.
Дальше, це інтересна тема, поизучати,
чому багато експерти хочуть делитися тим, що вони проживали самі.
Але саме трансформаційне, як ми можемо ісцелити і улучшити цей мир,
і нам буде абсолютно проще і легше це робити,
— це, звісно, там, де ми маємо собствену реалізацію.
Василий має якийсь питання, чи случайно рука піднята?
Так, я маю питання.
Що? Що?
У мене… Дарай, метайся в камеру, вігру.
Я задумуюся зараз в останню часу над еканем, так?
Чи є якісь рекомендації як оце Екані можна викинути?
О, знову бачите, є воно це Е.
Або десь я над цим не замислился і думав, що все прекрасно.
Коли послухав себе в записі, його є багато.
І коли, в принципі, зараз виступав, то я б концентрувався на тому,
як виходити в собі це анти-Е.
Ну, я не можу тебе відповідати на цей питання,
тому що я сам екаю, я не считаю це важним.
Коли я екаю, це що мається ввідомо?
Це значить, моя психіка тормозить, я не успеваю за потоком сознання,
я як-то цю паузу бессознательно заполняю.
Вот, навіть зараз, да?
Якщо задатися такою целью, то відповідь придет, і ти зможеш це зробити.
Я лично цей целью взагалі не задаюся. Моя аудиторія, їй все ровно на те, що я екаю.
Мне все ровно на те, що я екаю. Я считаю, що, да, є какая-то там супер такая, знаєте, смокинг-аудиторія,
Оскар, високі круги такі, де аристократична община, і там це важливо.
Я не роботу з такими людьми, а навіть якщо роботу з такими людьми в личному форматі, то їм це не важливо.
Я сфокусуван не на то, в якій я кепки, екую я или не екую. Я сфокусуван на тому, що я несу, а на тому, що нужно людям.
Вот якщо ми вземемо якого-то спікера, який говорить на російському чи українському языку,
імеється ввіду на нашому языку, але він не носитель нашого языка, а він, наприклад, англичанин или грузин,
і він говорить на російському чи українському языку з акцентом, заїкається чуть-чуть, картавить.
Та, блин, мені абсолютно все ровно.
Це навіть харизму якого-то придає.
Якщо у тебе є така ціль, то просто потрібно їй задатися.
У мене такої цели немає, я екою сам.
Я не віжу в цьому якусь проблему.
Опять же, це моє суб'єктивне мнення, я взагалі не авторитет.
Любі оратори, спікери, можливо, закидали б менше з яйцями і помідорами.
Але головний меседж, який я несу в своїх обученнях,
це не те, як я кажу, а те, що і зачем я кажу.
У мене це питання виникло, бо фактично я зараз минулого тижня матиму п'яти хвилин спіч у півфіналі, там є змагання спікерів.
І саме там звернули на це увагу, я розумію, що там це буде цінитися, коли ми в півфіналі будемо ходити в фінал.
І тому для мене було цікаво десь почути якусь думку, пораду.
Там, в принципі, є додаток, який можна говорити, і коли людина говорить «е», то вона потім габкає після того.
як ти через це. Я думав, можливо, є ще щось таке, що десь, ну просто ціль поставити і чути себе, в принципі, так, це найважливіше. Дякую.
Хорошо, я зрозуміло, Василий, якщо ти поставиш таку ціль, пару раз з таким приложенням поработаєш, то ти від цього збавишся.
Якщо п'ятиминутне виступлення, то щоб не їхати, треба просто бути добре підготовленим до виступлення.
Тому що коли я общаюсь з вами, як я не йду по заготовленій структури 30-минутного виступлення, де у мене все четко прописано, я можу екать.
Але якщо я зарані подготовлюсь, я знаю, що у мене буде в начальні, в середні, в кінці, я це отрепетую несколько раз, то мій мозг не буде тормозити, біжати за текстом, текст мене не буде держати, і я
вже можу дати максимальну енергию.
і бессознательне еканье буде менше.
А якщо ти задаєшся целью, то що тобі треба зробити?
Два пункта.
Це підготовитися чітко і репетувати це, наприклад, 5-10 раз,
якщо для тебе це важливо.
І поставити фокус, гру по заданню.
Я концентрируюся тільки на тому, щоб не екать.
І все. Тобто це діло техніки.
Діло техніки.
Ну, опять же, своє мнение я сказал.
Аліна, пожалуйста.
Я хотіла поділитися таким моментом.
В плані, навіть коли я говорю, також задавалась питанням Еканем.
Що стосується Василя, Василь, якщо ти хочеш прям,
якщо ти змагаєшся в конкурсі ораторів, так, це має значення.
Але коли ти проявляєш власний бренд, ну, зараз, я говорю, це моя сутосуб'єктивна думка,
Коли говориться про твій власний бренд, то якісь твої паузи, якісь твої акценти, якісь твої особливості, це особливості, це не мінуси, вони працюють саме як магніт до тебе.
Я зараз поясню чому. Я останнім часом почала за собою помічати, ну зараз мені важко буде відтворити це, тому що це якось так в моменті, це, ну от воно прям як йде зсередини і відображається, це част
ину слова, я можу, причому тільки частину слова, можу повторяти, це схоже трішки як там по типу заїкання, але це не заїкання.
Це повторення цієї частини слова для того, щоб таки зібрати думку до кучки і її проговорити.
Я згадала, що так говорить моя перша психотерапевтка, з якою я працювала, і це для мене було настільки якось так, ну, це енергія.
Це от її така жива енергія, яка прям захоплює, яка прям збуджує усі твої центри, щоб бути в максимальній увазі, щоб вже в кінці почути, що ж вона хоче сказати.
І насправді, так, важливим є сенс, важливим є, як ми це говоримо, важливим є, як ми подаємо структуру, але не менш важливо оці особливості, якими ми точно відрізняємося, де ми точно не будемо як мас
ла, де буде Василь Бугіль, де буде Аліна Велігіна, де буде Настя Вінградова. Тому цей момент, по-моєму, трошечки спірний. Дякую.
Благодарю, браво, прекрасне виступлення, Алина. Просто умночка, молодец. Молодец. Анастасія хоче щось дополнить, і підемо далі.
А я хотіла сказати Василью, це він смотрит себе в записі і видит, що екане і мій слух режет.
Я, як слушатель, я дуже активно слушала, тобі навіть участвовала, я не слуху це «е», і оно настільки, є слова, звуки, паразиты, які дуже режуть слух,
а є такі красиві, мелодичні, так у тебе це «е» просто дуже мелодичне, і в большому контексті даже твоєго выступлення
вообще не слышится. Лично
мне. Поэтому...
Ты сказала, я такая, где ты говорила?
Я так. Благодарю.
Благодарю. И Василий
благодарю за вопрос. Короткое
отступление, буквально две минуточки, и пойдем
дальше. Да, Анна, вижу руку.
Да, я хотела добавить.
Тоже у меня було такое сомнение
в себе, коли я розговариваю. У меня
больші паузи.
Я не могла из-за этого выходить в сторис,
снимать какие-то видео, і потім мій слушателі, мій підписчикі сказали, коли ти робеш паузу,
а це хочеться договорити за тебе, а це така пауза, де ти включаєш своє внимание, і ти так
красиво умеєш говорити, і я така, боже, мені казалось, що я не умею взагалі разговаривати,
що мені потрібно учиться ораторському мастерству, там, ще походить на театральне
іскування, чи ще куди, ні, у тебе все в порядку, і тут приходить внутренне согласие,
коли ти вже слухаєш у своєго зрителя ці коментарі.
Тому іноді те, що нам кажуть таким деструктивним,
чи нашим недостатком, є великим преимуществом, за якою люди цепляться,
і якраз роблять цю ідентичність твоєю.
Тому все добре, все окей.
Я дуже согласен з кожним із вас, і це важна тема. Абсолютно не жалко ефірного времени на цей вопрос, тому що це і є життя, живість, настоящесть.
Я теж помню свого першого учителя, і у нього там були якісь такі слова «да» или «вот», ну в общем, він так говорив, я прямо оргазм получав емоційний от цих лекций.
А потом, коли людина становиться таким чистим, причесаним,
як будто теряється какая-то життя, настоящесть.
Як диктор, да, на радіо?
Ну, давайте на іншій темі просто, да,
візьмемо преподавателя по етикету.
І, допустимо, це жінка чи мужчина.
Це не всіх касається, має суб'єктивне мнення.
І вона вчити там мизинець, осанка, скільки-то градусів має бути чай, скільки-то градусів має бути вино. Вино взагалі не рекомендую, конечно. І вона вся життя як будто б така по правилам, по ровної ос
анки. Все должно бать только так. Нету как будто бы места живости, расслабленности, простоте і естественности.
Да, можливо, кому-то це треба вміти в силі професії,
якщо ви вступаєте на мероприятиях «Оскар» і так далі.
Але в цілому я більше про здоров'ю психіку, розслабленість, аутентичність.
Якщо треба, я можу там на 5 минут собратися і зіграти роль декабрио з ровною осанкою
во всіх смыслах цього слова.
Моя ли це аутентичність? Да нет.
Ну, так що так, добре, але важливий питання. Василь такий, щас, мабуть, і думаю, що ж не робити, не екати чи не екати?
Тут питання просто поки не було в нас цієї вправи з цим додатком, то я навіть на цим не звертав уваги, що я екаю.
Коли я вже дав фокус своєму розумі на це екання, воно почало мені різати вуху і чути в інше.
Тобто, значить було, що можна або це прийняти, або прийняти і змінити в собі, і дати можливість іншим бути іншими.
Ну, якось так. Тому десь про це. Я буду точно усвідомлено старатися сьогодні не екати, і це цікаво, бо це виклик.
З еканем для мене це є норма, це є спокійно, а без еканя це прям виклик і це заводить.
Бути усвідомим, воно заставляє більше бути в моменті, тому я буду спробувати на екат.
Супер, супер. Відти, що ти для себе сам рішили. Я ж тебе кажу, більше почувствуй себе, своє тело.
І так, йдемо далі. Я напомню, що якщо ми говоримо про рівень високого мастерства, як у спортсменів,
олимпійського рівня чемпіон, оратор висшого мастерства, то, звісно, там є таке.
Ну, де ми? Перший розряд в рівень КМС.
Якщо б у нас був курс, посвящённий, як виграюти олимпийське золото,
конечно, ми б там точно не екали.
Але для того, щоб почати проявляться, говорити, выступати,
нам достатньо сейчас того, що ми проходимо. Я в цьому абсолютно уверен.
Итак, що ми маємо? У нас є що говорити, зерно, з якого це все расте.
У нас є як говорити, тони голоса, структура публичних выступлень.
У нас є, з чим ми це говоримо. У кожного з вас є своя мотивація. У нас даже є з кем говорити. У вас є своя аудиторія, інстаграм, свої ученики, підписчики і т.д.
Щоб оттачивати навагом мастерства, важна практика. Наскільки ми робимо це регулярно і методично. Я в своїй жизни професіональний спортсмен і зараз теж во многому як спортивний психолог з чемпіонами і
разного рівня мастерства работаю.
Так вот, ці люди тренируються кожний день, а ми, наше поле деятельності, як спікерів, у нас немає таких кожноднімних тренировок.
Василий тренирується перед выступлением.
Якщо ми хочемо повисити рівень своєму мастерстві, ми повинні просто чаще тренироватися.
Де ми можемо тренироватися?
Ми можемо тренироватися в блогі, снимати рілс, ми можемо проводити ефір, ми можемо участвувати в всевозможних конференціях,
Іспользувати любу можливість, щоб проявитися, ми можемо тренироватися на різних актірських, ораторських кружках.
І ось зараз і тут, якщо ви пам'єте, вторе задання, то ми там багато тренировалися.
Кожен із вас вступав, більшість, отримав обратну зв'язку.
І після цього, отримав цей практичний опит, хоч якого-то виступлення,
ваш уровень мастерства, уверість в себе і решість дійсною повісилися.
У кого-то в більшій степені, у кого-то в меншій степені, у кожного своє точка.
Поэтому я б хотів, щоб ми сьогодні теж попрактиковали.
Поэтому давайте прямо зараз выделимо 30 секундочек,
і кожен із вас виберет одну тему, с которой він сьогодні хоче проявитися.
Що-то, що на його личному опыту реалізовано.
Наприклад, хто-то практикує медитання, хто-то практикує дисципліну, хто-то практикує навык ненасильственного общення, хто-то практикує рані під'ємки, хто-то із професіональної своєї діяльності може щ
ось взяти.
В общем, що-то, чим ви в хорошому смыслі горите.
Виберіть щось одне і на цю тему...
Давайте я вам дам 30 секунд.
Прямо в такому формате.
Виберіть щось.
Настя, Алина, Юля, Анна. Прекрасно.
Молодцы. Остальные, пожалуйста, тоже включайтесь, выбирайте, без перфекционизма.
І далі що нам потрібно зробити?
Либо ви без чата GPT в своєм формате вот цю тему за 3 минути зараз освятите.
Вот такий экспромт-выступлення.
Либо быстренько зашли в телефон, сгенерировали і читаємо текст.
Давайте получим этот микрострес, микро выступление.
Вот у нас є сейчас 20 минут до перерыва,
потім у нас буде перерыв і після перерыва теж послушаємо.
Кто перший? Ну, давайте.
Ну, давай, Юля.
Давайте.
Я вже швиденько згенерувала насправді, тому я десь там буду подсматривати.
ти можеш підсматрувати, це абсолютно нормально. Похлопаємо аплодисментами і сцена виходить, отлично.
Благодарю. Отже, я хочу звернутися до когось з вас. Ми вчора виснули те, що в нас дуже багато трудоголіків насправді.
І я хочу запитати, чи бувало у вас таке те, що ви прокидаєтесь і у вас просто немає сил нічого абсолютно робити.
Хочеться відразу називати ліжку. Якщо є таке, то поставте, будь ласка, якісь серденька, смайлики або якісь плюски у чатик.
Клас, так, бачу, перша, є, є таке.
Я вас дуже насправді розумію, бо особисто я також починала з того стану.
Стане, коли життя летить, а ти десь біжиш за ним і просто не встигаєш.
Мене звати Юлія і сьогодні я познайомлю вас з темою стану, з темою, як психологічний стан впливає на те, а як ми взагалі функціонуємо, як нам дійти до цієї точки Б.
Я коуч-ментор, я людина, яка працює зі станом, я людина, яка працює з проявленістю.
І саме головне те, що я веду у своїй практиці 400 плюс жінок на платформі МЧП,
трансформаційній платформі, де створюється, також створила власну психологічну та коучному групу Level Up,
де ми працюємо якраз таки так само зі станом.
І загалом, чому ця тема дійсно важлива?
Найгірше, що коли стан погіршиться, коли ми знаходимося в стані апації,
то саме найгірше те, що ми почнемо думати, а що я роблю не так?
Можливо, я десь недозаробив, можливо, я десь недо, можливо, десь робота вас виснажує,
можливо, прості речі здаються, що вже все, мені їх складно робити.
Але правда в іншому, правда в тому, що якість нашого життя напряму залежить від нашого стану.
Бо коли людина всередині в апрації, коли людина всередині в якомусь стресовому стані, їй складно заробляти, їй складно будувати стосунки, їй складно комунікувати, їй складно проявлятися, їй складно
приймати рішення.
І саме головне – складно дійти до точки Б, до котрої ви хочете дійти.
Саме стан впливає загалом на те, як ми говоримо, як ми реагуємо,
які рішення ми приймаємо.
І саме головне – те, що людина щитує наш стан.
Подумайте зараз про те, в якому стані ви знаходитесь прямо зараз.
Як би ви його описали одним словом?
Можете написати в чаток, бо я розповідаю далі, я буду дуже вам вдячна за це.
Коли людина в ресурсі, то вона набагато легше вступає в комунікацію, вона бачить більше можливостей, вона притягує людей і, само головне, вона має енергію діяти.
Виснажений стан, хто ще? Виснаження, так.
Саме цей стан дуже сильний, коли ми не розуміємо, що далі робити, він впливає на нашу результативність,
на те, що з нами зараз відбувається. Саме тому дуже важливо на нього звертати увагу.
І неможливо будувати великий результат із внутрішнього виснаження.
Бо коли ми виснажені, саме на цьому знаходиться наш фокус уваги.
Він не може бути на позитивному мисленні, якомусь він знаходиться саме тут, саме зараз.
Саме про те, що обожуємо, що втомилося, вже не можете навчання проходити.
Уявіть зараз інший стан.
Уявіть зараз стан, коли ви прикидаєтесь із внутрішнім відчуттям сили.
із внутрішнім відчуттям енергії,
із внутрішнім відчуттям те, що все вийде, абсолютно все.
Прямо сьогодні все вийде.
Коли у вас є ясність, коли ви не виживаєте, а коли ви створюєте,
бо ви є творець вашого життя.
Зараз подумайте про те, якою тоді стає ваша комунікація,
якими тоді стають люди навколо вас,
якими тоді стають ваші стосунки,
як тоді до вас приходять гроші.
Якщо ви уявили, то подумайте про те,
наскільки змінюється те, що відбувається у вашому житті,
з тим станом виснаження і з тим, а як може бути.
Зі станом, коли ви творець власного життя.
Люди не купують просто продукт, люди не купують просто ваші послуги.
Вони відчувають вашу енергію, ваш стан, вашу ізюміночку.
Я дуже люблю казати це слово «ізюміночка».
Бо кожен з вас є особливий.
І кожен з вас має оцю дуже сильну внутрішню енергію та силу,
яку кожного дня віддає людям.
Тому дуже важливо приділяти цю енергію так само і собі.
Потурбуйтесь про себе.
Сьогодні після цього нашого заняття потурбуйтесь про себе.
Можна мати знання, можна мати досвід, можна мати талант,
але якщо всередині постійне в тому, якщо всередині постійне виснаження,
людина не може проявити свій потенціал наповну.
А я знаю, що в кожному з вас він точно є.
Тому сьогодні я хочу запропонувати одну дуже просту думку.
Працюйте не лише над цілями, бо вже я афієзні коучи, а працюйте над своїм станом.
І пам'ятайте, що до точки Б нас проводять не лише дії.
Нас проводить стан, з якого ми робимо ці дії.
Дякую вам сьогодні за вашу увагу, бо ваша увага – це найцінніше, що є для мене зараз.
Все, дякую вам.
Юлічка, аплодисменты больші і громко тебе зараз хлопають.
Юлічка, молодец, я дам тебе зараз обратну зв'язку, але перед тим, як тебе зараз чувствуєш?
Я не ожидала, що я буду першу. Знаєте, я підготувалася, не ожидала, я так чуть-чуть переживала.
Но потім вже як... Пошло-пошло, і мені було в цьому комфортно.
Мені було в цьому комфортно.
Хорошо. Як себе зараз почуваєш?
Знаєте, як адреналину. Чуваюся адреналину.
Це створення, як виступив і віддіхнув.
Я щось почуваю, у тебе пішла енергія, ти смієшся, напрямок спала, пішло розслаблення.
А як ти себе чувствувала вовремя виступлення?
Сначала тревожна, а потім я можу описати це створення
С інтересом і азартом зацепити увагу?
У тебе вийшло зацепити увагу,
дуже вийшло вийшло.
Почував ли хтось, Юліна, тривожність і напрямі?
Вопрос риторичний, я не почував,
цього не було видно взагу.
Ти дуже гармонично дивишся в кадрі,
у тебе прекрасна внешність, голос восхитительний, волшебний.
А ти на якому язві я щас говорила? На українському. Ага, а то я даже не вийшла на якому язві. Мене було абсолютно ясно, понятно. Я даже вот, ну, что я зафиксировал? Прекрасно ти почала. Но со структ
урою вообще нету вопросов.
gpd помог, і це дуже класна структура.
Це якась ескалація була?
Я використовала аиду.
Так, ну плюс-минус, плюс-минус.
Ти класно почалася з трудоголизма, чітко попала в боль, і все, все твої, все твої.
Единственный вопрос. Кому ти говорила? Кому ти щас говорила? Кто твоя аудиторія?
Я поняла, що я не вибрала якого-то чоловіка про те, що ми говорили. Персоналізація. У мене не було прям конкретного.
Це важливо, але зараз це не важливо.
Я говорила про аудиторію. Я просто знаю, ми вчора проходили транзактний аналіз.
І ми спілкувалися по поводу трогадагалізму і такіх віщей, і тому я знала, що ця тема була актуальна.
Хочу просто таймінг держати.
Ти говорила коучам, ти говорила обычним людям, які собрались.
Коучам, коучам.
Там в тексте це було, але до того, як це визникло в тексте, в принципі, воно підходить ко всім.
Тобто твоя аудиторія – це непосередньо отлично.
Була супер, улыбка, твоя голос. Несмотря, що ти читала текст, сгенерирований нечеловеком, ти дуже чоловічно його читала. Улыбка – твоя суперсила. Пожалуйста, знай. Тебе не треба. Улыбка, мягкость, т
екучість, пауза – це твоя суперсила.
Геніальна структура, т.е. боль, ця боль усиливалась, к чому приводит то, що ми виснажені.
Вот це прям я слушаю, слушаю, слушаю і хочу вже рішення. Ну дай же мені рішення, що вже робити.
Да, я знаю, що я устал, да, я знаю, як це впливає на мою життя, да, я знаю, як це впливає на гроші.
Що мені робити? І ось цього мені не хватило. Що робити?
З одного боку, таке виступлення може бути дуже вмістним і гармонічним.
Задати цей питання, все. Главна цель цього виступлення –
«Блин, ну зроби щось зі своєю створюю».
Можна так виступить.
Можна добавити решення.
Наприклад, учитывая контекст пяти минут, я бы оставил так.
Учитывая контекст, якщо я хочу дати тебе домашні задання,
В цю тему, вийти в прямий ефір з цим.
Тільки вже не для коучей, а для своєї аудиторії.
І я б добавив туди рішення.
Вот А, Б і С, що допомагає вийти з точки А, це вибирання, в точку Б, ресурс.
Сделаєш такий ефір?
Да.
Когда?
Та як зараз загружений графік, то, наверное, через недельки-дві.
Абстрактно ніколи. Давай назначай дату прямо зараз.
У тебе є...
Зараз дата. Хорошо.
Зараз вам скажу.
Зараз я вам скажу.
Так.
Тридцать пярмого числа.
31 числа має на все прекрасно прекрасно молодец это действительно очень актуальна тема мне кажется
на очень ресурсно и что еще вот тот момент когда ты говорила когда ты погружала человека в
состояние а представьте когда вы в ресурсе да вот этот голос волшебника как у вас деньги
приходить, як у вас там окруження, я б в ефирі більше паузи делал, щоб прям чоловік по пунктам себе
ответил, увидел ці картинки. Зараз якби на це не було часу, але там є три пункта у тебе,
як тоді у вас деньги приходять, як тоді у вас там окруження, щоб человеку допомогти йому
це прям пройти ментальний путь вот умничка молодец мне очень нравится твоя аутентичність
прямо хоч а еще сильна сторона была ты очень классно представилась у тебя прям доверия к
тебе сразу проистекает мчп 400 чего-то умничка умничка все прям юля 30 31 числа эфир и и продай
що-то на цьому ефірі. Діагностику, консультатию, що-то. Хрошо?
Хорошо. Благодарю вас.
А потім напишеш мені, як я там все пройшло.
Хорошо.
У нас через 4 минути перерыв. Давайте дадим Юле обратну связь,
і після перерыва буде следуючий чоловік.
Як вам, як со сторони, що вам подобається, що вам запомнилось?
Добавьте їй зеленої пасти,
Добавте їй какой-то похвалы,
выделите те моменты,
которые она со стороны не замечає.
Юлечка, шикарно!
Все було шикарно, що я даже хотіла
руку опустити, тому що я поняла,
що я не знаю, чому говорити після тебе.
Вообще, красотка!
Спасибо, Юлечка.
А я б Юлю...
О, Алиночка, сори.
А я б Юлю слышала,
мені все ровно, щоб она розказувала.
Мені кажуть, якщо б вона мені сказки читала, я б слушала.
Мені кажуть, якщо б вона що-то взагалі не важливе розказувала,
взагалі не мою тему, я б її слушала.
Я б слушала і слушала, тому що вона для моїй нервні системи просто успокоїтельна.
Я з нею просто розслабляюся, я з нею о чому серьёзно не думаю.
Мені нічого не волнує в цій жизни.
Мені з нею становиться абсолютно понятен, мир і спокоїн.
Ей голос мені просто приважає.
Колоскова. Дякую, Юль.
Дякую, Настя. Юля, видиш, як її видить мир? Пользуйся цей, може записуй якісь медліпитання.
Ну, це твоя суперсила.
Це здоров'я луна, окситоцин, нежність, женственность, безпецість, доверість.
Безпецість. Мені з неї безпеціно.
Мені з неї, як жінчіні, просто безпеціно.
Фідбак? Юля знає, як я відношуся до її глибини, такої мудрості. Я нещодавно тільки дізналася, скільки Юлі насправді років і у мене був справді шок, тому що це твоє вроджене.
І сьогодні про твоєму виступі насправді відчулося, наскільки ти розширяєш, пускаєш нас в ту свою глибину, в ту свою мудрість, те, що в тебе є всередині.
Класна структура, чітко, зрозуміло, голос, паузи, вони заворожували, вони, знаєш як, хотілося, хотілося далі, що ж ти далі скажеш.
І, взагалі, супер, що ти була перша, бо я розумію, що моя тема, з якою я перша підняла руку, вона буде продовженням. Дякую, Юлічка.
Дякую, дякую.
Дякую. Юля, я навіть попрошу тебе цей промок, ти можеш поділитися з участьюю, по-моєму, він прекрасний, по ньому прямо дуже здорово.
Я просто скажу по секрету, я большинство ваших словів, я там, як структура так посматривала, але я там придумала щось голову,
поэтому його потрібно чуть-чуть моїми словами дополнить, там він більше також депетичний, я його, з точки зрення чоловіка, більше представляю.
Добре, дорогі друзі, на цій прекрасній ноті ми йдемо в перерів, зараз 11.30 і через 15 минут ми зустрічаємося. За це час я прошу вас віддіхнути, попити чайок і згенерувати свої виступлени. Давайте сь
огодні проявимося. До зустрічі через 15 минут.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Давайте зараз ми по взаємодійстві ще з одним чоловіком, підніміть руху, хто желає зараз проявитися. Дальше перейдемо к някій теорії і потім опять послушаємо чьи-то виступления.
Получилось у вас вибрати тему і сгенерувати? Подніміть руху, у кого вибрати тему і сгенерувати. Я помню, там Аня піднімала руху.
У мене вийшло, але мені сон позвонив. І для дитинка мама доступна 24 на 7, тому приоритет. Тим більше, він в больниці лежит, тому...
Ти хочеш зараз начати? Или попросим Алину? У нього там був контекст.
Да, давайте, потому что я хочу посмотреть, как формат выступлений.
Вообще, да, у меня є тема, є вже згенерирована презентация,
поэтому, да, я пропущу, хто там.
Формат выступлений, он похожий на то, що було у нас два модуля назад.
Ну, ми просто практикуємо.
Ты була на тому занятиях, да, я помню?
Да.
Хорошо, Алина, давай тогда сейчас ти,
Потім ми ще немножечко поговоримо і потім Ані і всі остальні жилаючі.
Отож, насправді тему я підготувала, згенеровану, на прощання, підсумки і все таке, але я не буду цього робити,
Тому що я точно та людина, яку більше збиває йти за якимось чужим сценарієм, чужим шаблоном.
І мене зачепили ваші слова, чим ви зараз говорите, що ви зараз проживаєте.
І в темі моїй є продозвіл, тому я дозволю собі поділитися тут з вами тим, що я зараз проживаю, розвиваю, де я зараз практично дотикаюся, до якої теми.
Ну і в найближчому майбутньому я розумію, що це буде саме той напрямок, у якому я буду працювати.
Я Аліна Валігіна, я психолог, зараз хвилиночку, я психолог-консультант в інтегративному підході, коуч, менторка, власниця маленького жіночого бізнесу.
І я точно знаю, як жінці вийти з мінуса в усіх моментах, в усіх питаннях, фінансовому, фізичному, емоційному, в стосунках і особливо в стосунках з собою.
до стану наповнення жіночою енергією, справжньою, істинною, до стану, коли ти реалізуєш це наповно, коли гроші – це не ціль, це бонус.
І я буду дуже вдячна, якщо ви достаєте мені знак, що вам актуальне це питання, якщо ви хоча б колись задумувались над тим, і класно буде, якщо за можливості, звісно, включитися, включити камеру, щоб
я побачила усі ваші очі.
Я дуже хочу, щоб ви відчули той стан. Дякую. Це безцінно.
Той стан, з якого мені вдається зараз жити,
продовжувати досліджувати себе і передавати свої знання далі.
Отож, як я казала, я продовжуватиму тему Юлії.
Юлічка дуже класно підмітила, що зі стану вагоряння, зі стану апатії
Неможливо створювати щось нове, щось грандіозне, вивільнити те, що є всередині.
Тому першим етапом я точно пропоную вам попрацювати з Юлією.
А далі дати собі запитання, для чого більшого?
Що мені дасть отой стан, коли я стабільна, коли я наповнена, коли мені не потрібно нічого доказувати і коли я знаю, чого хочу я? Не мої батьки, не мої близькі, діти, чоловік, тварини, я.
де отой контакт з собою істинною, яким чином його знайти, яким чином відчувати, що твоє, а що нав'язано.
І я, як психолог з самого початку, я дуже довго опиралася.
Я дуже довго опиралася навіть самому слову енергії, навіть самому слову духовності, езотерики.
А зараз я дозволяю собі досліджувати абсолютно в усіх сферах.
І також допомагаю кожній зі своїх клієнток дотикатися до себе різної,
дивитися на себе через різні грані, де саме ваше, де саме ви найбільш проявлена,
ви найбільш жива, тому що лише зі стану «я жива, я творю».
І для початку, звісно, потрібно усвідомити, який саме бекграунд ви вже маєте, яку ціль ви ставите перед собою і тоді налаштувати ось цей контакт.
Особисто мені дуже класно допомагають в медитації.
Признаюсь чесно, мені не завжди вдавалося спочатку війти в стан тотального контакту з собою, але з часом, з кожною наступною спробою я все ж таки дійшла.
І я усвідомила, наскільки це кайфово, от саме чути оцю внутрішню тишу, якої я раніше взагалі не чула.
З цієї тиші народжується істина, з цієї тиші народжується суть, сенс.
І я хочу запропонувати вам прямо зараз закрити очі, буквально на кілька секундочок.
Зробити глибокий вдих і повільний видих.
відчути свою тишу, що вона хоче зараз вам сказати, де вона зараз, де вона в тілі, а якщо її немає, то де б ви хотіли, щоб вона з'явилась,
Де б ви хотіли, щоб звільнилося місце для неї?
Поставте свою руку на це місце і відчуйте, як тепло в вашої долоні зараз розтікається з тієї точки.
І розповсюджується по всьому тілу, по кожній клітиночці вашого тіла, по кожному сантиметру.
Ось це і є ваша особиста енергія.
Побудьте в цьому стані стільки, скільки вам потрібно.
І коли будете готові повертатись, відкривайте очі.
Я дякую вам за вашу тотальну довіру.
Я дуже надіюсь, що вам вдалося відчути.
Якщо ви хоча б на 10% це відчули, тоді ви точно готові йти далі.
Тоді ви точно маєте усі сценарії на те, щоб продовжити розкривати своє істинне «Я».
А я готова запропонувати вам роботу зі мною в наставництві.
Для початку можу запропонувати роботу в 5 сесій з інтервалом раз в тиждень зустрічі,
де ми з вами навчимося чути спочатку свою тишу, а потім свої сенси.
Я дякую вам, що ви були зі мною залучені. Це для мене безцінно.
Алина, молодець. Вдох-видох. Як себе чуствуєш?
Какі мисли, які відчування?
Зараз таке легке головокруження від тієї енергії, яка піднімається, яка запалює.
Я розумію, що вона зараз розганяється і якби виступ був довший, то більший, то там було б значно більше енергії.
Але при цьому я розумію, що я могла б втратити сенс. Був страх, що люди можуть втратити хід моїх думок.
Збивало.
– Як себе чуствуєш зараз?
– Хвилююся, хвилююся.
– Угу.
– Во время выступления як себе чуствувало?
– Упавнено.
– Хорошо.
Давай, блиц, запрос.
У тебя структура була така?
По какой структурі це шло?
– Ні по якій.
Це було інтуїтивно, Денис.
– А ти читала текст?
– Да.
Ти зараз читала текст?
Це все було з голови, це просто була відповідь на ваше запитання.
Ага, супер, умничка, молодець, хорошо.
Хорошо, тогда главна цель цього виступлення в одному словосочетанні.
Передати сенс.
Який?
Емоцію.
Яку?
дотику до себе справжнього, справжньої.
Супер, молодець, да, да, хорошо.
І от коли ми беремо, смотри, твоє вступлення для мене началось за минуту,
як ти почала представлятися, коли ти вводила нас в контекст.
І от коли ти вводила нас в контекст, я почувствую прям настоящую,
от таку аутентичну очень Алину.
Мене дуже подобається, це хороше начало вступлення, я ввожу вас контекст, це було реально круто.
І коли ти, я тобі зараз кажу таку більш жорстку обратну зв'язку, учитывая то, що ти взрослая дівчина, і мені здається, що це буде тебе щось дуже важливо услышати.
І коли ти почала говорити о себе, у тебе сразу включилась другя роль, другой персонаж, другой тон голоса.
Була аутентична жива Алина, а потім включилася роль.
І знаєш, чому?
Тому що, коли ти вводила нас в контекст, ти говорила нам, ти говорила мене і цим людям.
Була чітка персоналізація, реалізованна на практиці.
А коли ти вже почала говорити роль, типу, виступати,
то, скоріше всього, вот ця персоналізація, вона смылась.
Обалдеться.
Говорила в абстрактність куди-то.
І це ніхорошо, ніплохо, але я повернуваю вас к тем інструментам, і Лера сьогодні його підчеркивала, Резник, да, персоналізація.
Це не що-то абстрактне, це що-то конкретне, чим ми пользуємся.
Поэтому в будущем, вот у тебе сейчас живой реализованный опыт.
Ты в одному выступлении имела опыт и персонализации,
когда ты обращалась к нам, вводя нас в контекст.
І для мене це вже було начало выступлення.
І все остальное выступление, которое було в абстрактную камеру.
І нічого тебе не потрібно думати, робити, мати, кроме цього одного факту.
Пусть буде це один вивод.
Що, окей, я зараз виступила так і получила цей опит для того, щоб в следующий раз персоналізувати людей.
Тому що, коли я персоналізую, я, Алина, у мене все прекрасно, аутентично, естественно.
Мене хочеться тебе касатися. Ушами, глазами, да?
Вот. Там є живість, я чувствую, що є контакт.
Добре. Що в апаратах?
Я зараз не кажу, що все було погано. Я зараз кажу, що це було дуже добре.
Я все абсолютно розумію прекрасно. Я не сприймаю це на емоціях.
Я реально сприймаю це розумом і я розумію, що тут є момент докрутити.
І докрутити – це іменно персоналізація, тобто личності.
Тобто причина і слідство. Причина першої частини виступлення – настоячий, живий.
Це те, що ти обращалась до нас, а потім почала обращатися в камеру, в абстракцію какую-то.
Дальше, мені дуже подобається ця сила, повернути людей до сенсів. Я записав себе, а для чого більшого?
Це класний питання. І все це виступлення можна не обесценивати цей питання, а прямо к нему підводити.
І в рішення на цей питання — у тебе медитання.
І медитання — це така тонка річ, що в п'ятиминутних практиках ми спешимо.
У нас зараз такий контекст. Я розумію, якщо б ти виступала сама,
то у тебе виступлення було б дільше.
Тому я не рекомендую давати медитання в п'ятиминутному виступлению.
Я рекомендую тогда виступлення увеличити,
щоб людина могла погрузитися в це стане, прожити.
прожить. І це дуже класний формат для живого тренінга, для твоєї аудиторії, для прямого ефіра.
Либо, якщо це умісно, десь для більшої сцени.
Вон так. Продавати наставничество після медитання, ну, така себе історія.
Я би вибрав більш простое целеве действо. Боле... Ну, то есть, смотри, продажа наставничества – це як секс.
А до цього йдет там, не знаю, ужин в ресторане, перший поцелуй, ще щось.
Более маленьке цільове дійсто я б предложив.
Я розумію.
І на такому контрасті, коли тут сенс, настоящесть.
Для мене це дуже резкий скачок.
Тому цільове дійсто має бути, але має бути більше.
Більше прелюдія, щоб соблюдається в твоїх відношеннях з клиентом.
Але ці сенси для чого більшого – це те, що достойно внимання.
Хто хоче дати какую-то обратну связь, що понравилось, що запомнилось со сторони?
Можливо, мене поправте, якщо я сильний строк був.
Тож я можу сказати, Алин, ти ж розпринимаєш нормально критику.
Скажем так, ти розрекламувала Юлю більше, ніж себя.
Ти так це вкусно преподнесла, і я б тебе не пішла, я б пішла к Юле.
Тому що ти вокруг неї создала інтригу класну.
А тут ти вся сама відкривась, я пішла вот такий путь, давайте помедитируем, і все, представьте себе.
Я з собою забрала цю медитацию, дома села і почала її практиковати. Зачем не ти?
Ну, то есть, це моє мнение.
Лена, супер, спасибо. Хорошого щось було?
Хороший, да, тембр, конечно, подача була хорошая, то есть неправильно, не подача, а правильная речь, вот так скажем, вот эти «э», «э», «э» я не услышала, то есть нет, ну Алина вообще она хорошо
говорит, но вот я как бы захотела почему-то в этот раз дать, это тоже хороший отзыв.
Отлично, Лена, ви були на второму занятии?
Нет, я зараз на першому занятиї з вами, тому я не була.
Смотрите, у нас на цьому курсі 4 занятия со мною, і вторе занятие со мною вам треба послушати, пересмотреть.
Там є техника «Бутерброд, як давати обратну зв'язку».
Як ми коуч-психологи-терапевти, ми об'язані знати цю техніку «Бутерброд», як ми упаковуємо конструктивну критику.
В записи на платформі є, вторе занятие, рекомендує вам його посмотреть.
Благодарю. Благодарю. Кристина.
Я хочу сказати Алине і Юле, що, во-первых, дівчини дуже круто розполагають,
викликають доверію. У вас і голос, і тембр, і паузи.
Прямо дуже-дуже-дуже круто, здорово.
Алин, единственное, що не хотіло, щоб ти потім залучила до себе.
Вот, все. А так, ну, умничка.
Да, дівочка дійсно располагає. Кристина, благодарю за обратну связь.
Настя хоче щось допомити, і йдемо далі.
Да, що я хочу сказати. Ну, Алина, да. Я б її слушала і слушала тож.
Ну, і провалилась. Провалилась і не уловила для себе сенс.
Що я ощущала? Я ощущала, блин, она така ж жива, она така ж переживаюча, она така ж обычная, а не какой-то там на сцене выступающий, который, вау, из олимпа спустилась. Такого нет. То есть, она своя,
своя. То есть, вот это, опять же, безопасность.
Що не хотів? Продажника. Прокачувати треба. Продажника, качаємо. Будем качать.
Тому що продати себе, це ще той квест, я прекрасно це розумію.
Ну, нічого, це підкачається.
А медитання, ну, ти ж знаєш, я не включаюся в медитання, тому с открытыми глазами слухала.
І на фону шло что-то, шло, шло, шло фоном. О чому, зачем, ну, непонятно.
ну типо классно вот и вот это вот включить действительно на себя чуть-чуть прокачаем
продажника уверенность ценности того что пять сессий с тобой это переворот кверх ногами настат
назад поставить назад твердо на основание вот это вся ценность 50 секундочек поверну
Я хочу подякувати кожному з вас, тому що максимально цінні ваші фідбеки, і тут немає хороших, поганих, вони є цінні для мене, тому що я зрозуміла, де докрутити, і я знову вертаюся в свою улюблену т
ему самоцінність і довіра до себе, і віра в себе.
Йду далі її допрокачувати, я дуже дякую, правда, я точно не хотіла, щоб ви сказали катекласника, тобто я прийшла вчитися і безможно вам вдячна, що ви цьому всі сприяєте. Моя любов вся з вами.
Не повериш, но у мене тут ця фраза була записана, я забыла тебе її сказати.
Це не бояться бути собою, як у тебе вступити на речі сьогодні.
І з практичного це домашнє задання тебе таке.
«Почему я, имея супер-харизму і настоящесть, прячусь за абстракциєю?
І як мені мої виступлени персоналізувати?»
Вот. Вот це, ну, головне.
Хорошо, йдемо далі. Прекрасно.
Ну, в цілому, я же придираюсь, на самом деле, большинство це взагалі не заметить.
І так, що у нас далі?
Да, іду к вам.
Давайте зараз чуть-чуть поговоримо, а потім опять перейдемо к следующому виступлению.
У нас на черзі Анна.
І так, на мій взгляд, як написано на цьому слайді, основна способність і навык ораторам — це не говорити, як би странно це не звучало, а це слушати.
Коли ми маємо слухати і слухати, це автоматично здає нам пространство, можливості для того, щоб ми говорили лучшим образом.
І слушання — це прежде всього про способність бути в контакті з собою, з цим миром, з реальністю, з тим чоловіком, з яким ми взаємодіємо, з егрегором аудиторії в цілому, і тим, що в цьому від цього
контакта може родитися.
От контакта може родитися.
Качество в цілому нашої жизни напрямую зависит от того,
як ми уміємо слухати.
Тому що якщо ми уміємо слухати,
значить ми уміємо входити в контакт.
Якщо ми не уміємо входити в контакт,
це філософія мировоззрення і створення одиночества.
А счастье у нас проистекає
Отношення. Отношення – це завжди контакт. Отношення ученик-учитель, відношення друг-друг, відношення родитель-ребінок, відношення ребенок-родитель в другу сторону, відношення любимий-любимий.
Все це требує способності слухати і слухати. Як в старому фільмі «Счастье» – це коли тебе розуміють.
Але то, як ми слушаємо, вона вимагає вимагає і глубину наших відношень, і вкус наших взаємоотношень,
і уровень доверія між нами, спосібність договаруватися, спосібність щось вистраївати і зробити щось нове.
Є чотири класичних рівень слухання, я, котрим обучався, в різних системах є три, є чотири.
Я вам хочу представити чотири, на мій взгляд, вони відпочиваються.
І перший рівень слушання – це закритое слушання,
коли людина физически, телом своєм присутує, тут і зараз,
але психологически він закриєт, він где-то в прошлом, в будучі,
в своїх запросах, в своїх проблемах, в своїх переживаннях,
либо в броні для своєго эго, щоб не почувствувати біль від контакта.
Фокус внимання у чоловіка, який знаходиться в закритому віде слушання, то є у нього проистекає внутрінний діалог, он внутри постоянно себе як-то оцениває, свої мисли, своє присутствие, як він вигляд
ит, як він не виглядит, у нього які-то страхи.
і він бессознательно чи даже сознательно захищає свою позицію,
тому що якщо його позиція окажеться неавторитетною, то це болі для ложного его.
І як в бойцовському клубі, як ви помните,
розказчик з Марлою, і вони говорили таку фразу,
«Мене таке чувство, що люди мене не слушають, а ждуть своєї очері, щоб заговорити, щоб відповідати».
Помніте там із фільма «Бойцовський клуб Брэд Питт» Чак Паланик?
То есть, чоловік не слушає нас, а вместо этого прокручує у себе мысль в голове,
що відповідає, і ждет в своїй очері, щоб заговорити.
Там нету емпатії, там нету понимання, там є просто я і время, в яке мне потрібно вклиниться.
Когда же ти вже заткнешся, замолчиш, щоб я наконец-то сказав.
На цьому рівні нету контакта, не може нічого родитися, є ніяке напрямання, насторожність, желання захиститися, і це транслирується з собеседника, а якщо з собеседника высокий рівень емпатії, він може
почувствувати, що чоловік зараз не в контакті, чоловік зараз со мене, я для чоловіка небезопасен, чоловік не готов мене слухати.
І саме інтересне, це, коли два чоловіка на першому уріювані зустрічаються з другом, і виходить така історія.
Тобто, якщо подитовжити, першому уріювані зустрічаються, це коли чоловік зациклен на себе.
Низкий емоційний інтелект, низка імпатія.
Дальше є двай рівень слушання, він називається інформаційне слушання.
Ну, наприклад, ви йдете по вулиці і встретили одноклассника чи одноклассницю, і там що-то, привет, як дела, поверхностно друг друга слушаєте.
І потім ваш одноклассник говорить, о, а я таку паріхмахерську нашел, такий барбершоп, класний, і там ціни такі круті, а я як раз іщу себе нового барбершопера.
І в цей момент я включаюсь, я такий вже о, настроював свої локатори, у цього чоловіка є щось ценно і важне для мене, мені все ровно на його личності, мені все ровно, як він там ці 10 років жил,
коли ми не виделись.
Я особо к нему не чуток, не емпатичен.
Я знаю, що ми зараз розтанемся,
але він заговорив за щось ценне,
що для мене користне, інтересне, насушне зараз.
Я настроен, а де, а какой адрес, а кто работает, а скільки стоїть.
І вот я вже готов впитувати від нього інформацію,
тому що вона мені нужна.
Понимаєте пример?
Тобто на чому я фокусуюся, коли я во второму рівні слушання?
Я фокусуюся на логі, на аргументах, на структурі речі,
щоб отримати для себе какую-то чітку, конкретну направленність, інформацію.
Я в цей момент собран, я в цей момент раціонален,
при цьому у мене є ніяка дистанція,
тобто близько своє серце я не відкриваю.
Я слушаю только конкретну інформацію, яка сделає мою життя лучше. Я готов слушати, я готов не перебивати, не ждати свою очередь, пока заговорю. Или там, не знаю, барбершоп, какой еще пример можно
привести. Девочка рассказывает про лазерную апелляцию или про какой-то новый косметологічний салон.
А ви якраз іщете щось таке.
Ви переехали жити в Португалию, і тут нікого не знаєте,
встретились і вот вона вам на вулиці случайно ця тему говорить.
І ви зразу настроені на неї, готові внимати інформацію.
Какі у цього уровня ограничення?
Тобто тут нету близости, какой-то такой сердечний, тут особо нет зв'язи.
Есть как бы диалог, але нет особо отношений.
Вот эта тема закончиться, исчерпається, відношення закінчиться, ми розійдемося. Така історія. Дальше у нас є третий рівень слушання.
То, що я не договорив про другий, це то, що багато люди, вони общаються на другому рівні слухання і відпочивають там нікую безпеку, тому що це безпеку, тому що там немає каких-то більш глибоких вход
ів в личності друг друга, це не требує якого-то емоційного ризка,
Це безпесно, це поверхностно, достаточне для того, щоб получати логічну інформацію, але не достаточне для живих відношеньків.
Третий рівень слушання, він вже слаще.
Це називається емпатичний рівень слушання, коли ми слухаємо не тільки слова, а коли ми чуємо ситуація, переживання, внутрішній вибрації другого чоловіка, той, хто з нами.
Ми зчитуємо не те, що він говорить, а що він зараз чувствує, коли він це говорить.
Як йому зараз? Харшо, тревожно, спокійно, радостно, счастливо.
Він відкритий, чи він щось утаєває?
Ми чутки к його внутрішньому міру, а не к той логике,
которую він через слова, через вербалізацію нам передає.
І в нас естественним образом глаза і все наші фокуси внимання через уши, через вибрацію, емпатія,
ми чутки к мимике, к дыханню, к паузам, ко всему, що відбувається в цьому пространстві, коли ми общаємся.
Тут є відкритість, відчувальність, тут є спережування, тут є теплота.
І таким образом ми можемо даже ісцелять друг друга,
тому що емпатичне слухання, виравнює нас.
Человек відчуває, мене відчуває, мене відчуває, я не один, мене розуміє.
І я розумію, що мене розуміє, і той, хто мене розуміє, розуміє, що я розуміє, що мене розуміє.
Тобто ми в зв'язі, ми в контакті, ми в місті, ми сприкоснулись, ментальними телами.
Юра так смешно смеється, я не знаю, він смеяє ли?
Не, я не з вас, я просто... Я не знаю, коли там буде моя очередь поступати,
если она сьогодні буде, но, если она сьогодні буде,
мне не придеться вас удивити, мне кажется, я уже удивляюсь от того,
как я смогу вас удивить. Вот.
Ты выбрал, мне кажется, эту тему для выступления?
Я нічого не выбирал, я просто утром пошел в душ,
Мені прийшла ідея, я подумав, а що так можна, і оказывається,
даже не так, а ще.
Я зараз просто…
Ваше заректиговало, це був прекрасний хук, і ми ждемо твоєго виступлення, Юра.
Класс, це у тебе там ззади доска з целями, я вижу такі всякі слайдики.
Це мій детективний офіс, я себе зробив персональний.
Мені шопер детективів коучинний.
Красавчик.
Дякую.
В чому тут є проблема на третій урові слушання?
Якщо ми...
Знаєте, на примері жизненому.
У мене був такий пример.
У мене була SMM-девочка год до два назад.
І ми, коли з нею встречались, ми прямо хохотали.
Нам було так класно общаться.
Ну, ми там шутили з якого-то контента, і два часа прошло, а польза никакой.
Ну, типо, ми не зробили ніяких цілевих действий, ми улетіли в цю емпатию, улетіли в цей дружеский вайп,
але не зробили ніяких цілевих действий.
І опасності тут в цьому емпатичному общі, що якщо немає структури, якщо ми нікуди не йдемо,
а наш формат взаємоотношений предполагає, що ми куди-то йдемо,
то тут можна просто розплытися в цьому дружескому вайбі «здесь і зараз» і все, і все.
Поэтому тут класно, коли є какая-то структура.
Але, якщо ви, друзі, п'їхали в путешествію, то, можливо, вам не потрібна якась структура.
Ми переходимо к четвертому уровню слушання.
Ой, тут стільки слайдів я пропустив, але не суть.
Ми переходимо к четвертому уровню слушання, і це нещо більше інтересне.
Щас, а де? Секундочку. Ага, все.
І це нещо більше інтересне, це називається інтеграційне чи генеративне.
Т.е. генерируємо щось вимість. От цього уровня слушання може родитися щось третє.
Наприклад, два чоловіка, коли з другом встречається, один щось сказав,
другий щось сказав, і у кожного відникають якісь нові ідеї, інсайта і осознання,
що в свою життя він може добавити, допривнести.
І у них місце може родитися проєкт, коллаборація.
Що-то родитися від цього контакту може.
Наприклад, ми там, не знаю, з Юрием встретились, поговорили,
І в тому, що от нашого взаємодії стільки інсайдів у кожного, що ми просто не можемо, давай зробимо колабу, вот наш проєкт, вот буде, ну, словно говоря, наш рєбенок, наш проєкт, наш какой-то, не знаю,
прямой ефір, совмєстний курс, совмєстний ретрит, генеративне слушання, после контакта которого возникає нове щось.
Или коли клієнт з коучем общається, в принципі це одна з целей у коуча, щоб клієнт вийшов з новими осознаннями, а що зараз, які нові действия він буде в свою житті делать, создавати.
Коуч помог йому згенерувати нові опції минулого і поведення.
Тобто це — це стане, в якому і емпатія, і логика, і чому визникає щось нове.
Це, знаєте, як мужчина з жінчиною, коли вони вступають в контакт, може родитися рідок.
Якщо я сам з собою вступлю в контакт, це аналістичне дійсно. Ребенок не родиться. А я же можу бути сам з собою в діалогі, зациклен на себе. Не родиться нічого. Понимаєте?
Коли ми друг в другі, тоді можна.
не на комнатки давайте сейчас прямо тут сделаем на каком-то примере чтобы все были включены
я думаю мы сделаем так вот прямо все вместе тут спасибо
вот давайте сейчас два человека три минутки пообщаются прямо при нас например там не знаю
Підніміть руху, хто хочеться поучаствувати.
Один чоловік розкажет комусь.
Я всегда можу, якщо.
Второй чоловік розкажет комусь історію.
І ми будемо за вами просто наблюдати, а ви осознаєте,
во-первых, про себе, коли ви слухаєте, коли ви говорите,
що ви відчуваєте, де це в телі відбувається, що з вами відбувається,
які реакції піднімаються.
Потім ви фокусуєтеся, наскільки воно воно на другому чоловікі.
Ви слухаєте і слова, і чуваєте емоції, і мотив вашого розказчика, його состояния.
Тобто в глубину чого чоловік пытається вам передати.
І у вас здається якесь пространство між вами.
І ви можете замечати, в процесі цього общення рождається щось воно в цьому діалогі.
Які-то нові смыслі, нові інсайди, куди веде цей разговор.
Или не рождається.
Подніміть руки, хто хоче.
Хто хоче попробувати.
Я зараз... Де-то у мене був слайд.
Прості, у мене тут с русським і українським языком просто.
І так, я не вижу рух. Юрий, включай мікрофон. Кто з Юрием хоче пообщаться?
Я включен.
Включи мікрофон.
Давайте, девушки.
Ірина.
Так, я.
І так, ще раз повторю задання.
У нас сейчас є, давайте, 4,5 минуты.
Сначала хтось один просто розказує, не знаю, о своїх насущних переживаниях, трудностях,
чи що відбувається в житті, чи о своєм вчерашній дні, позавчерашній.
Второй розказує какую-то свою історію, чи слушає.
Ну вот в чому, у вас спонтанний діалог відбувається.
І ви просто осознаєте, я зараз в себе, чи я в партнере, що у мене рождається, що не рождається.
К чому этот розговор вообще спонтанний може привести?
Давайте попробуємо без перфекціонізму
Привіт Юра Привіт Іра Ти так зацікавив своєю темою ранішнього ефіру і я з ранішньої думки
промови я подумала тебе попитатися що ж ти там таке нам приготував цікаве
Я б приготував і думаю, може нам всім зібратися компашкою, порухати Віталію.
А там ти в нас експертна, і нам покаєш найкращі місця і зробити такий випускний.
Як ідея, це взагалі мега бомбезна, так що, я думаю, треба тут одразу Насті написати.
Вона ж мала з SMM-щиком десь там по якихось місцях бути.
І відповідно, може би, як точку зупинки, також і сюди, і SMM, і контент, і святкування. Тому, як ідея, бачиш, генератор ідей.
Ти, пану, підтушуємо, якраз буй, думаєш, що в морі вже літо, в морі жила.
Омиваюсь потним італійським вайбом випускного.
Так, такий класний буде. Класне очищення після таких 11 місяців навчання активних.
Є бой. Короче, все було не про то. Давай про щось цікаве. Розкажи мені про Італію. Серйозно, з розумієт приїздом і мені треба визнатися з країною.
От Італія – один з моїх цих варіантів. Чудовий момент, щоб обговорити. Я вважаю.
А, так. Італія – жарка країна, має залежності, для чого ти хочеш, як ти тут себе хочеш реалізовувати, бачити для відпочинку, для роботи.
Якщо для життя, роботи, то треба, коротше, перед тим добре знати податкову систему і добре все обдумати.
Ось так, як на мене, щоб жити тут класно не на мінімалках, а так все класно, все, як мене каже один знайомий італійць, всі круті американці приїжджають жити, купляють житло в Італії, тому що тут
реально на дикому.
Мені подобається оцей от вайб, взяти собі кабрик, поїхати на кому.
Мені ще продали ще одне місце, класно в Італії, розкажу, як він називається.
Добре, я вас встановлю, ми вам похлопаємо, ви молодці.
І зараз кожному з вас питання.
Давайте так, як ви думаєте, на якому із рівнів ви були плюс-мінус?
Тобто більший фокус внимання у вас був на партнері або на себе?
Ірина.
Коли Юра сказав, мені було цікаво на нього, тому що якраз цікавила тема,
і там вже пишуть, що не з душу, тобто мені цікаво було, що він там придумав.
знаючи креативного Юрія це завжди стікаво тобто потім як запитався про Італію тобто тут
зразу трішечки в нашому що би було для нього та тому я зацепила типу різні якраз теми такі
щоб потім дати якийсь момент де би він що і ну куди би він рухався щоб його було якби
пріоритетом по вибору країни це що він назвав я десь це там бачила спокусувалася на ньому як
я можу бути корисна в даному випадку.
Даних три хвилини.
Супер.
Хорошо, Юра,
що ти почував?
Ти більше був сфокусуваний на себе
або на партнері, на Іріні?
Мені було інтересно реально пообщатися
про Італію. Я такий, зачем упускати
момент? Я ще виступлю.
Мені було інтересно переключити
фокус внимання, тому що це ж навик
управління аудиторії. Було якби
що-то на поверхності, що можна було
роздувати, але було де-то, де можна було смесити фокус внимання.
Я такий, чому не смесити фокус внимання? Давайте сделаємо інтересний.
Тому я був в фокусі і на себе, і на Ірине, і на історії якій-то інтересній для всіх.
В різних фокусах внимання. Я їх не отслеживав, якщо честно.
Хорошо, хорошо. Про Італію це більше похоже на друге, коли є щось, що дуже важливе для мене.
Чувство... Две-три мінутки.
Так, у мене связь прервалась? Или у Деніса?
У мене теж. Якщо думаєш, у Деніса.
У мене? Що-то не так.
Деніса, повторіть, будь ласка.
щоб у вас трохи прорвався інтернет.
Прошу прощення.
Юра, на твій взгляд,
як почувала себе Ірина?
Две-три минути,
які ви з нею спілкувалися,
що вона спілкувала?
Що в ній було внутри?
Ну, мені кажучи,
тоді трохи розрив шаблона.
Називається так, FinalP.
І вона спілкується про Італию.
Ну, давайте спілкуємося про Італию.
Що вона чувствовала? Що вона чувствовала, які у нього емоції були внутрішні?
По емоціях?
Перше – це вот цей шок, перше.
Вторе – у нього було желание допомогти, включиться.
Типа емпатию це називається, але це не емпатию, це якось по-другому.
Треба відкрити картинку чуств моєго психолога.
не суть хорошо Ірина на твой взгляд що Юра чувствував во время этих двух-трех минут
які емоції он воспитывав в каком он состоянии был наскільки он був в тебе или в себе
цікавість я відчувала від нього цікавість тобто що це буде типу готов на все типу що буде будемо
експериментувати тобто він на етапі типу я не відчула від нього серйозного очікування від мене ну
тобто що людина да з якоюсь там темою пройшла і щось від мене чекає а тут така типу цікавість і
відкриття до всього тому типу хочеш будемо говорити про то ну про то я потім а давай про то типу
і використаємо ну да учитывая контекст нашого діалогу то що ми онлайн то що ми вот так спонтанно
Неподготовлено, понимаю.
Мене чуть-чуть тяжеловато, я вам признаюсь, проводити цю практику сейчас онлайн.
Все-таки це більш живой формат і требує більше времени.
Но давайте все равно сделаем вид, що ми зробили цю практику класно.
І для самоанализа я рекомендую вам відповідати себе, порефлексувати на следующі питання.
Третій і четвертій рівень требують розвитку.
І незалежно від того, на якому рівні емоціонального інтелекту ви зараз знаходитеся,
я рекомендую все рівно помедитувати на питання,
що мені складно слухати інших людей, що в мене закриває, що блокує мою емпатію.
Вот чуть-чуть помедитувати на це.
Як я вже сказав, от того, як ми слухаємо, зависит вкус наших отношений.
Ми зараз не беремо в пример Іру і Юру, учитывая контекст нашого мероприятия.
Але в цілому, для всіх, хто слушав, всіх участників, я рекомендую на ці вопросы помедитувати.
Що блокує нашу емпатию? Що може блокувати нашу емпатию? Що може нас закрывати?
Некоторі фільтри слушання – це страх услышати правду о себе.
Це може бути немножечко болю.
І ми можемо прятатися за цим страхом в неоткритості.
Емпатию може блокувати желання бути правим, одобреним, понятим, таке ярко.
Емпатию може блокувати якісь ожидання від цієї встречи, від цього розговору, від цього діалогу.
Емпатию може блокувати неосознані проєкції,
коли я в себе не замечаю, що це було п'яти приємного,
а в інших транслирую свої якісь несовершенства на інших.
Емпатию може блокувати внутренній діалог.
Це коли я сфокусуваний на себе, я внутрі думаю, а що ж відповідати, а як ж?
І як-то критикувати собеседника у себе в умі.
М'якою чи грубою, емпатію може блокувати просто опыти прошлого отношення, а не були.
Це хороша тема для рефлексії. Я недавно досмотрел фільм, який мене дуже сильно включив.
Давайте я щас три минути з вами об этом поговорю, і ми перейдемо к чоловіку, к чоловіку, к чоловіку публічному выступлению.
Я посмотрював фільм «Соперники», там играет мулатка Зендея і якісь малоизвестні актёри про спортсменів, про теннисистів.
Не так, щоб я рекомендую кожному к просмотру, але є фільми, які дійсно включають,
после которых остається послевкусія і такий вау-effект від осознання.
І для мене цей фільм прежде всего про контакт.
Знаєте, коли два чоловіка общаются, і вони можуть конкурувати, соперничати, доказувати щось,
вияснювати бессознательно і сознательно, як в сім'ї, так і в будь-яких інших відношеньях.
А можуть бути в «Контакте», де дві личності зливаються в один процес.
Це щось похоже на… Це може бути і в общі, це може бути в спорту,
даже коли ви соперники, це може бути в сексі, це може бути в відношеннях довгосрочних.
Вот именно встреча личностей.
Не поверхностне общення, етикетність, деликатність, як це називати,
А вот коли сливаються дві настоящести, дві тотальні голі правди сливаються.
Мене непосредственно на це осознання вдохнував цей фільм.
Кто увлекається кинематографом, рекомендую прямо.
Але, опять же, він такий, дуже спеціфічний.
Аристократична аудиторія, я б його не посоветовував.
Юрий, якщо ти хочеш, щоб я тебе видів ярче, тобі треба піднімати руку в приложенні, а не в камері.
Ну говори.
Так, так удобнее.
Це то, що я в коментарі скинув, тому що я поїзд губив, а там, ось, ось, ось, ось, ось, ось, ось, ось?
Да, да, да.
Кайф, спасибо.
Посмотрю, сьогодні вечер.
Претендент.
І, можливо, іскусство, воно може передатися,
ніж я зараз через свої фільтри вирбалізувати буду словами.
Возможно, цей фільм вас вдохновить уйти від конкуренції,
відзащитних паттернів першого і второго рівня слушання
і прийти до настоячого контакту між личностями.
Це може бути в ваших відношеннях з аудиторією,
якщо ви ведете трансформаційні курси, тренінги, программи.
Щоб случилася там ця трансформація, контакт необхідним.
По своєму опыту скажу, що у мене однозначно це не так, щоб завжди получається.
І в більшісті це, звісно, живой формат должен бути, офлайн, жива встреча,
одне пространство, де ми близько друг к другу,
де одновременно все чувствую погоду, одновременно всіх слух,
слухають одні і ті же звуки.
Ну, як-то так. Запутався і не помню, к чому я хотів вас привести.
Хотів привести к тому, що відношення, діалог, публічне выступлення
Ми можемо розценивати як я отдельно, мир отдельно, а можемо рассматривати як ми сливаємося.
У нас случається, ну, слово «секс» дуже добре описує вайб, який я хочу передати.
Давайте на цей прекрасній ноті, коли Денис Чернощов чуть-чуть попав в яму.
Перейдемо к нашому оратору.
Давайте доведіть оргазм, до оргазма аудиторію на вашій сексуальній темі.
Дивайте пік наслажденью.
Оставлю чуть-чуть тебе.
Я хочу взяти слово і выступити, пока малышка спит.
Якщо хтось збирався бути зараз, то попрошу дати мене слово і місце.
Давай, Лера, конечно.
Класно, ще можеш почати з того стиха, що вчора, і це допомить тему Дениса.
Юра, я тебе тут немножко остановлю, дай мене слово, місто, все буде, все буде класно.
Итак, я, во-первых, рада всього всіх видеть і буду с вами максимально відкривна і хочу розказати вам одну історію.
Як вже зрозуміла Юра, вчора була інтересна історія, і вона буде якраз такі зараз розказана.
Ми казалися в комунате і должны були робити задання, но в заданні должны були бути двоє людей, які работають, а в комунате оказалися всі слухачі.
І в моменті мені чому-то захотелось прочитати своє нове стихотворення.
Я його прочитала, прочитала його отвратительно, просто ужасно.
І в моменті, де-то збивалась з мыслями, де-то у мене вообще частина забілась,
потім вона вспомнилась, потім в кінце я получила класний фідбек.
Мне поаплодировали, мне сказали, насколько це класно, насколько це здорово,
що моїм слушателям понравилось в моменті.
І я задала себе питання, а була ли це ошибка?
І сьогодні мені хочеться спросити вас.
Коли ви чуєте внутри, що яка-то точка в вашій житті, яке-то дійснє є життєю, а ошивкою ли це насправді?
Или, можливо, це опит?
Или, можливо, це новий етап?
Після того, як я задала себе запитання, я написала такі строчки, хочу вам їх зачитати.
«Силы дарить спокійствия всему живому, исцелять боль, усмірять гнев, сеять радость,
і гармонію на своєму пути можна знайти тільки внутри себе».
І я спросила себе, що я хочу робити з цієї точки далі.
І відповідь нашовся зразу.
Я себе відповідала, що я хочу читати це стихотворення ще раз, ще раз, ще, ще багато раз,
поки не почувствують внутри, що я удовлетворена.
Ні кто-то где-то мене услышав, а мені в цій точці стало добре.
І, пользуясь случаем, я буду читати це стихотворення второй раз.
Оно сырое, нове, але воно мені подобається, і, можливо, воно подобається вам.
Моє тело — карта.
Язиком ти іщеш на ньому горячі точки.
Це все.
Що ти умеєш со мною робити?
Возвращайся з задань, по формі,
ти йдеш обновляти дані срочно.
Іногда ти не знаєш, де предел.
«Здесь дві нові родинки,
«Здесь веснушки.
От тебе пахнет войной,
і у тебе свої методи.
Ісповедувати я не готова.
Послушай, де ми з тобою пропустили тот самий момент?
Із горячих точок,
вспомінає моїх горячих».
Дійствуй собрано, быстро, інтуитивно.
Убирай террористов молча.
Поджигай медленно.
Чтоб була можнасть виводити языком на спині курсив.
Я читаю сутра полоскову веру.
Це все не про веру.
Це все про боль.
Ее стихи написані, як в «Пример мене».
Мої стихи написані через секс і ще через любов.
І здесь я хочу, щоб кожен із вас задав сьогодні себе випрос.
Кака, можливо, моя ошибка була зовсім не ошибка, і де я можу повернути себе свою силу?
Всех обняла. Благодарю за внимание.
Я просто не мог быстро вступити после твоєго окончання.
Дорогі друзі, я уверен, що ми тільки що лицезріли премір
настоячого трансформаційного виступлення, настоячого контакта.
І я хочу зараз отмотати час час назад,
отмотати час назад і пройтись по всім етапам,
які Лера, у Леры случились.
Случилось з чітких границ занимання свого міста на сцені.
Якби це було зараз не онлайн, визуалізація була б така,
що є платформа, на якій де-то Денис і Юра туди запрацювати,
запрацювати з різних сторон.
Ну, не в плохому смыслі цього слова, але зараз у Юры таке настроєння.
І вона дуже чітко не агресією, а своєю силою присутствие
таке, якого-то ігре розтавило, і навіть не тільки в пределах сцены, а ще шаг вокруг сцены.
Це було дуже мощно і сильне. Беріть себе на заметочку.
Вторе. Як тільки вона почала говорити, вона в цей момент почала жити.
Вона не играє зараз роль. Вона проживає кожну строчку.
Вона знає, що буде в конці, як вона закончит річ.
Але вона не в конці. Вона зараз там, де зараз.
Це дуже чувається. Беріть себе на заміточку.
Ми сейчас розбираємо кейс идеальності, я би сказав, не так, що вам треба подражати її паузам великолепним, не так, що вам треба подражати її тону голосу, ми розбираємо идеальність її, коли чоловік
знаходит свою уникальну ідентичність, і в неї живет цей момент.
У кожного з вас буде свій тон голоса, своя естественна атмосфера від вашого присуття.
Але ми не можемо не відмітити той факт, що коли Лера виходить даже в окошко зум-онлайн-сцени,
ми чувствуємо цю силу, і вона заполняє їй ефір.
І там слітають всі маски в її присутстві, як якого-то невротичність, спешки, суети, абстрактності, поверхності, все це слітає.
І кожен може з'єднитися зі своєю, той самою тишиною, якою Алина перед цим говорила.
Ми можемо найти путь к своєму естіству, коли рідом в полі человек його зараз чувствує і проживає.
Ми через зеркальні нейрони чи інші научні факти можемо теж благодаря цим прикоснутися.
Далі.
Вона розказувала про свою історію, про насущну, а своя історія несет завжди енергию, живу енергию.
Вона говорила, що було, ввела в нас контекст.
Вона сказала, що вона чувствовала в цьому контексті і які виводи вона зробила,
після того, як вона прожила і почувствовала свою історію, свій контекст.
К чому ці виводи її привели?
І все це було таке нагрівання, нагрівання, нагрівання, підходяще кульминації,
де вона филигранно, як вишенку на тортиці, представила це стихотворення.
Тобто можна начать стихотворення, можна тільки стихотворенням виступити.
Але успех зависять навіть не від самого стихотворення, а від того, як ми його приподнесли.
і приподнесли не манипулятивно, а приподнесли настоящее присутствие своєй реалізованій сили.
Т.е. коли я говорив о фільме «Соперники» і «Контакт», я не знаю, як роботає пространство,
але так оно роботає, що Лера нам зараз показала.
Це секс, це слияние, тут і зараз, в моменті з нами.
Для мене цей фільм про це.
Возможно, це мої проєкції, і я це почував, не знаю,
але підніміть руху, кстати, сердечко,
хто ще почував зараз цей контакт?
Не в пошлому смыслі абсолютно цього слова.
Це влечет в непошлому смыслі цього слова,
а може бути і в пошлому.
Ну, це дійсно сила, ця енергія життя.
І коли ми говоримо о творчестві, о поєтах, о музикантах
или о творчестві публичних выступлень через трансформаційні практики,
ми, виходя на сцену, в даному час через стихи, я вже, по-моєму, це говорив,
ми не можемо спрятати себе.
Тобто видно всі наші внутрішні переживання,
Совершенство, несовершенство.
Вот сейчас її боли, її желання видно.
І тому, коли поєд виходить на сцену,
є тільки два варіанта.
Либо відкритися повністю по-настоящому
і бути готовим до того, що
всю цю цю галость внутрішню видят,
либо не виходити взагалі.
Тому що тут либо все, либо нічого.
І тому, коли музиканты поють песни, це дуже не як там голі дівшки в інстаграмі,
які показують нам свої голі тіла.
Це люди, які показують нещо більш глибоке, ніж тела.
Вони показують голий внутрінний мир, свої голі емоції.
І вот це касається, прям трансформирує.
Я не знаю, що ще добавити. Сохраніть, будь ласка, в своєму воспоминані цей момент, тому що ми побачили, як це. І тепер ми можемо це привнести в свою життя теж, благодаря Лере. У нас є цей опит, прож
итий.
Я не знаю, умісно ли у Леры спрашивати, как она себе чувствует.
Мне кажется, все її чувства, на этот вопрос она отвечала все своє выступление.
Вот, поэтому сейчас, мне кажется, даже неумісно, чтобы она включала микрофон,
если она очень, правда, не хочет этого.
У вас подняты руки, девочки, Алина, Настя, вы хотите им что-то сказати?
Давайте.
Ліра ну твоя поезія і ти в принципі для мене щоразу розкриваєшся взагалі не те щоб з іншої
сторони все більше і більше і тебе просто хочеться от просто хочеться бути в контакті з собою той
контакт про який говорив Деніс Да і от я прям зараз да от Деніс говорить я паралельно ж і в голові
крутиться моя рефлексія з приводу виступу і в принципі ораторської майстерності да от саме
здавалось би да наш предмет він там про про голос про там дихання навіть нехай да там про якісь
Але як лірин виступ показав, що ораторська майстерність, вона і про тіло, тому що протягом всього виступу тупо мурашило, тупо ось це таке істинне, живе, природнє, таке збудження, воно реально присутн
є, тому що від цього контакту лірі вдалося словами, голосом, тоном передати
і включити в слухачів, ось це істина живе, про яке я говорю.
Лєр, не то, що дякую, це, знаєш, просто сказати дякую, це дуже мало.
Ти неймовірна і максимально, знаєш як, тут навіть не проявляй себе,
а не жаднічай, давай себе трошечки, даруй себе, да,
Тому що ти, правда, розкриваєш самі класні частинки кожної душі, я впевнена. Дякую тобі.
Благодарю, Аліна.
Оце, те, що я говорив, рівень олімпійського чемпіона.
Не знаю, наскільки у Лєре це присвоєно,
але, можливо, благодаря нашій обратної зв'язки це присвоється ще більше.
Настя.
Якби ти описала і як ти видиш женську енергию і істинну женську силу, я б вам включила це віступлення.
У мене немає слов, вони не підбираються, це краще один раз показати.
Лер, твоє солнце светить дуже ярко. Просто його ще не всі видят.
Я вас благодарю, кожного, і мне очень-очень-очень сегодня це все входит в душу.
І для мене важливо услышати кожного, і я благодарю за вашу обратну зв'язку.
Я, якщо чесно, някій растерянність відпочиваю,
тому що після такого, як після того самого трансформаційного фільма,
хочеться уединиться, пойти і що-то робити.
Ми зараз вимагаємо продовжувати, а як будь-то був, ну, ви розумієте, о чому я.
Ірина, хочеш щось сказати?
Так, я, це слова, слова, тона літа, голосу,
ось це, що відбувалося, але ще і граціозність, як вона відповідала.
Тобто в мене от дивилася, і воно настільки все було, знаєте,
от слова, дії, емоції, стан передавання, воно давалося на 360 градусів.
Тобто якщо, наприклад, там десь відключився, зайшов в емоції,
що ти відчуваєш, поки вона говорить, і я, типу, відчувала тільки емоції,
потім дивлюся на неї, і в неї ось тебе ліра ось ця поведінка,
от як ти стала, як ти почала це вести, ну, тобто, ти всім була в присутності
і передала, ну, мені здається, що кожного з нас торкнулося,
бо на всіх рівнях, тобто, я відчула просто всі рівні
і відповідність цих рівнів, і швидкість, і тембр, і рухи, і все-все-все,
супер класно і дійсно добре що є що можна переглядати отак як сказала Настя що коли повернути
себе до цієї жіночої енергії то ти показала цей приклад Дякую тобі Дорогі друзі у нас через 15
Доджин бать перерыв в 13.15.
Зараз 13.00, я пользуюсь своїм авторитетом.
Хочу, щоб ми зараз зробили перерыв, учитывая контекст нашої енергетичної волни,
щоб ми не смазали потім це виступлення з іншою частиною.
І просто у нас третя частина сьогоднішній програмі буде чуть дільше.
До зустрічі!
Давайте до зустрічі через 15 минут, да, получается?
Я ще раз виправнув. Скажу, що це було реально охуенно. Я дуже рад, що Лера проявляє цю частину. Безгранічно рад.
Вона це знає. Особенно. Топ 10 з 10, 20 з 10, 100 з 10. І це охуенно. Браво.
До зустрічі через 15 минуточків.
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Дякую!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Дякую за перегляд!
Так, підключаємся, будь ласка. Наш перерівчик подійшов до концу. Жду вас. Отлично. Ви рядышком. Молодцы.
Так, хорошо. Як ви не устали? Насколько от нуля до десяти ви в ресурсе сейчас?
Хто ниже семерочки, можете размять ушки, мочки прямо по это вот,
либо сделать какую-то дыхательную практику, пока меня слушаете.
Включитесь в ресурс. У нас важная тема.
Мы сейчас обсудим, затронем тему ненасильственной коммуникації.
Отлично, є, рядышком видно все.
Так.
Іду, іду. Не вижу в чатикі, як ви себе чуваєте от 0 до 10.
5, 8. Ага.
Дев'яточка, Лера, клас.
Хорошо.
І так, що таке ненасильственна коммуникація? Це знаменитая техника маршалу Розенберга. У нього є целая книга, яка так і називається «Навык ненасильственного общення». Я считаю, що ми мастхеві должны
цю тему знати в своїй личній практиці психотерапії, коли я роблю з людьми, тет-тет-тет, по тему отношений.
Це прямо незаменимий інструмент. І хочете вірте, хочете нет, але многие і не пользуються, тому що просто його не знають.
Але ненасильственна коммуникація – це прекрасний метод. Ми можемо отнести це і к структурі публічних виступлень,
тому що це определенна структура, по якій ми можемо доносити свої цінності, смыслі, потребності, желані так, щоб собеседнику було максимально понятне і приводити це к цільвим действиям, які ми хочемо
з його сторони,
При цьому, щоб ми не нападали, не обвиняли, не унижали свого собеседника, а доводили до живого контакта, до ясности между нами і до конкретного рішення, що в итоге робити.
В цілому, ця практика применима абсолютно, не знаю, в 80% каких-то жизненных ситуаций в личностних отношениях, в отношениях клиент-ученик, ой, ну, учитель-ученик, в дружеских отношениях, в бизнес-п
артнерских отношениях применять можно абсолютно где угодно.
ми можемо це применять в своїй клієнтській практиці,
ну, наприклад, коли клієнт опаздує на сесію,
коли клієнт отменяє сесію,
коли клієнт займає багато пространства,
як угодно, коли клієнт не виконує домашні задання,
це навык коммунікації, який мастхів ми повинні освоїть.
Більшість з вас його знає, лишним не буде зараз быстренько пройтись по цій темі со мною.
Підніміть руки, хто знає.
Ніхто не знає, що ли? Я не вижу рух піднятих.
Ніхто не владеє техникой ненаслістоній коммунікації?
Вам повезло, це одне з лучших, що ви можете сьогодні изучити.
Напомню, що головна ціль даного методу в тому, щоб відділити факт від інтерпретування, від відчувств і обвинений.
Хорошо, я постараюсь вас більше ввести, наскільки вийде, але виделимо на це буквально 10, максимум 15 минут.
І так, де я? Я тут.
Вот як виглядеть формула ненасильственного общення,
як ми можемо упакувати для нашого собеседника свою потребність.
Ми зараз коротко изучимо цю структуру.
Я приведу ряд примерів, і потім ми повернемся к цій структури.
Тут є 5 шагів.
В класичній версії, по-моєму, 4, але в моєй версії 5 шагів.
Перший – це ми обозначаємо факт без оценки.
Наприклад, коли ти опаздуєш на нашу сесію на 15 минут, це чіткий факт.
Второй пункт – що я чуваю, настоякі емоції.
Коли ти опоздав на мою встречу на 15 минут, я чувствую спешку, суету, возмущенность.
Понимаю, що не успею донести матеріал, тому що далі у мене чоловікий клієнт.
Наші чувства. Що ми чуствуємо?
Третий пункт. Для мене важна, і тут внутрення цінності і потребності,
для мене важна успість, щоб ми не спешили, щоб ми пройшли цей матеріал,
щоб я не опоздав на следующу встречу.
Четвертий пункт.
Тому я прошу.
І тут ви в четвертому пункте даєте чітку просьбу.
Що умісно робити, які є опції, як можна в цьому разі поступити.
І п'ятий пункт – вистраєвання границ.
Якщо моя просьба, наприклад, не опаздувати чи предупреждати за полчаса,
якщо ти опоздаєш, не буде в цьому разі в цьому разі,
То я, наприклад, буду либо прекратити наше общение, либо брати с тебе предоплату, либо сниму з себе відповідальність за результат нашої роботи, тому що ми не успіли вложитися в таймінг.
Ви зарані це обозначаєте. Ту границю, яку вам комфортно виконувати.
Ми зараз к структури вернемся, але по факту у нас є два сценарія, як люди общаються, коли не знають цієї формули.
Вони либо замалчивають і подавлюють в себе вот ці потребности неудовлетворені, коли їх границі нарушають,
либо уходять в агресію, в претензію.
Тобто подавлення цей чоловік, йому що-то не подобається, він молчит, він терпит, він зглаживает, він, ну ладно, нічого страшного, вступний раз все змінюється, я не хочу конфликтовати.
І внутри копиться злость, обиди, напряження, подавленний днев – це все одно з самого худшого, що може з нами як би бути.
Тому що це все веде до вигляння, це веде до потери уваження к себе, це веде до разрушення відношень, це веде, як следствие, к внезапним сривам і разрушення відношень віднутри, коли ви замалчиваєте.
Либо наоборот, вам что-то не нравится, вы сразу как бы агрессия, нападение. Обвиняєте, критикуєте, давєте, обесцениваєте. Другой чоловік винужден захищатися, у вас возникає конфлікт, вы не понимаєте
друг друга, он смотрит на це з одной точки зрения, вы з другой точки зрения, понимання нету, возникає холод в отношіях, возникає взаємна претензія, друг к другу увеличивається.
Це веде до того, що відношення, як я вже сказав, холодеють, разрушуються, токсична атмосфера, навіть якщо вони залишаються. Возникає страх у когось щось говорити далі, щоб не було конфлікта, следово,
ми переходимо в подавлення. Короче, це не круто.
Ненасильственна коммуникація виводить людина з цих двох крайностей, з подавлення, з нападення і приходить до максимальної конструктивності между нами, теплоті, взаємності і синергії.
Тобто це третя позиція, де ми не молчим, не нападаємо, а говоримо ясно.
Давайте ще раз. Я повторю формулу, но перед тим, як я повторю формулу, я попрошу прямо вас сейчас, может быть, вспомнить,
де ви не одовлетворені в якій-то коммуникації, в робочих процесах, в відношеннях, в чому-то.
І ви не знаєте, як це сказати, або говорити дуже агресивно.
Вот, наприклад, ситуація. Чисто гипотетична. Два человека, два друга, і один друг просить второго друга з переїздом помочь выгрузити вещи, перевезти, выделити на це три часа времени, потаскати чемод
аны, шкафи, мебель.
Тот, кого просит, он знаходиться на стадії вигирання.
Он зараз не може виделити на це ресурс.
Як він може поступити?
Перше, він може замовчати.
«Да, да, конечно, давай я тебе подвезу, все хорошо».
Ну, поступити своїми границами.
Він може, «Да короче, ти мене достав, іди сам грузи свої вищі, у мене зараз куча всього».
Либо третий момент.
Факты. Какі тут можуть бути факты? Я тебе люблю, ти мене дуже ценен. Це факты. І при цьому, коли ти просиш мене знову допомогти тебе з переїздом, ми переходимо ко второму пункту. Я чувствую усталость
, внутренне сопротивлення, тому що для мене зараз важливо восстановитися.
Тому я прошу тебе, знайти кого-то другого.
Якщо це не вийде, я все одно виберу остатся вдома і восстановити силу.
Це важливо для моєго стаєння.
Я люблю тебе, ти мені дуже цінен.
Вот чітка формула, коли ми структурно, сохраняє відношення,
даємо другому чоловіку нас понять,
сохранити свої потребності, цінності, желані.
І в даному часу даємо альтернативу чоловіку, як поступити.
Наприклад, знайти когось другого.
Либо другий пример.
Коллега на роботі нагружає вас вне вашої зони ответственности.
Человек може подавити, копити в себе злость, агресію.
Человек може послати, разрушити отношения.
Либо чоловік може використовувати метод ненасильственої коммуникації.
Коли ти перекладаєш на мене задачи, які не в моєї зони.
Тобто, спокійний tone of voice — факты.
Коли ти перекладаєш на мене задачи, які не в моєї зони ответственности.
Второй пункт. Що я чуваю?
Я чуваю напряження і обиду.
Третій пункт.
Тому що для мене важна честність в розділіній об'язанності.
Я прошу тебе заняться этим самостоятельно.
Якщо цього не відбувається, я передам руководству
і вийду з процесу, тому що не можу тащитися двоих.
Чіткий, конкретний.
Анна, питання якийсь?
Тут нет, я по я, бедничаю, руководству.
Такое, мені більше я впонювала жертва якогось.
Тобто не діалогом конструктивним, а якогось жертву.
Ти тут на мене надували. По факту, без емоцій, все, ну, какое-то состояние жертв.
Ну, смотри, альтернативи, як поступити, що ти зробиш, ти можеш сама придумати.
Це зараз, условно кажучи, текст персонажа абстрактного якогось.
Но для мене тут немає ябіт. Для мене тут є чіткі границі.
Вистроені з іерархії відношіння, де є я і мій колега, і ми займаємо там рівне положення.
І чому-то на мене перегружають, допустим, відповідальність.
Як мені це розрулити?
Окей, ти перший раз можеш не говорити, передам руководству,
предложити якийсь альтернативний вариант.
Я прошу тебе зайнятися цим самостійно.
Якщо це не відпочивається, я буду повинен повторять тебе вновь і вновь це обращення.
Але я робити не буду.
Ну, допустим, так.
Якщо це не допомагає, то ти поважаєш градус.
Я тоді вже передам це руководство і прийду з процесу, тому що я не можу тащитися двох.
Тому що у мене не вистачає часу на хобби, на спорту, все время входити на роботу.
Я не можу займатися нічим другим.
От цього страдає психіка, емоційність, відношення, ще що-то.
Тобто, ну, вносиш в контекст.
Я вважаю, у вас тут багато рук, у вас ці теми видно.
Ключка, це дуже багато.
Долгий розмовір.
Ми не будемо ходити в психотерапію, изучати це.
Я вам рекомендую книгу Маршалла Розенберга «Ністерість на коммунікацію».
Але якщо є питання по структурі і подачі, звичайно, давайте обсудимо.
Так, я вибачаю, що без камери. Я дуже класно цією штукою користуюсь, я просто не знала, що воно називається.
І дівчат цьому навчаю. Дуже класна тема, якщо розібратися в неї. Тільки я трішечки по інакшому.
Тобто я одразу є ситуація, я відслідковую емоцію. І це найважче. Що там? Що там за емоція?
Чи там страх, чи там ссором, чи там образа, чи там, не знаю, гнів, злость.
А потім вже я така, окей.
І потім я вже йду до людини, і от це вот, я тебе так люблю, так люблю.
Ну, наприклад, навіть на дітях, да?
Там я розумію роздратування якесь.
Я така, чого?
Потому що мама втомлена.
Я підходжу і кажу, синулька, ти в мене найкращий, я тебе дуже сильно люблю.
Але мама так втомилася зараз.
Це не про тебе.
Мені просто потрібно відпочити.
Давай ми пограємося з тобою завтра.
або там підемо на мілче, як в суботу,
до прикладу, тобто, і це дуже
класно працює. В
стосунках, безконфліктно,
я можу отримати те, що я хочу
за 10 хвилин, наприклад,
там якась ситуація,
я, наприклад, кажу, слухай, ну,
я тебе дуже кохаю, ти мене найкращий, але
тут я відчула себе небезправді, тут мені було
незручно, або там, я відчула
типу себе якось нецінено,
і він такий, та ні, мала, я сюди, я взагалі
на це мала на увазі, і все, і не починається
якби, ну, вирішуватися. Тому це дуже класне теми, дякую.
Дякую, Маршалі. Да, в психології це називається «я-сообщення»,
але більш глибоке, це у Маршалу Розенберга, ненасильственна коммунікація.
Действительно, це то, як ми можемо дістигати своїх желаней,
сохраняя теплоту і дружбу при цьому.
Давайте рассмотрим четвертую ситуацію, третью ситуацію.
Третья ситуація – це, допустим, хронічно опаздывает
і пренебрегає договоренностями.
Як може звучати таке обращення?
Коли ти в третій раз приходиш на 40 минут позже, не предупредив,
ви просто сухо називаєте фактами.
Я чуваю раздраження і обесценность, якби моє час нічого не значить.
Для мене важливе взаємне уваження і надєжність вконтакті.
І в цілому тайм-менеджмент, учитывая мою занятость, для мене ценно время.
Поэтому я прошу тебя в следующий раз либо предупреждать заранее, либо договариваться точнее.
Якщо це не змінюється, я буду вирішен прекратити наші встречи,
тому що мене важливо общатися з людьми, з которими я чуваю уваження і честність.
Такий пример.
Давайте обсудимо головний принцип ненасильственной коммуникації.
То есть, перше, все начинається з факта.
Факт – це то, що відбувається, а не то, що ми думаємо об цьому.
То есть, є дуже простий критерий.
Якщо то, що відбувається, можна зняти на камеру, це факт.
А якщо ми зробили якийсь вивод о чоловіке, це не факт, це вже наша інтерпретация цього факта.
Тобто як не треба говорити в факте, а люди часто вивляються і обвиняють вже на першому шагі.
Ми можемо сказати неправильно, ти мене не уважаєш, ти мене ігнориєш, ти грубий і безответственный.
Це не факт, це вже оцінка, це обвинення, це наша інтерпретация.
І в цей момент чоловік автоматически буде уходити в защитну реакцію. На нього нападають зараз.
«Ты мене не уважаєш». Ну, якщо мене таке буде говорити, я буду захищатися.
Вот. Факт, он звучит як «Ты не ответил на мої сообщення два раза». Це факт.
Тут нету оцінки, тут нету обвинений, тут є просто факт «Ты не ответил на мої сообщення два раза».
Или «Сегодня на встречі ти перебил мене три рази».
Или «Ты сказав, що це глупая идея».
Или «Ми договорились на десять, а ти прийшов в десять двадцать пять».
Це сухий факт. С цього все починається.
Второй шаг – це наші емоції. Що ми чуствуємо?
І тут ключова ідея, що чуства – це про нас, як Маша говорила, а не про другого чоловіка.
Як не нужно говорити, тому що люди думають, що називають чувства, але на самом деле вони продовжують обвиняювати другого чоловіка.
Я чувствую, що ти мене не уважаєш. Це не чувство, це обвинення.
Я чувствую, що тебе все ровно, я чувствую, що ти мене використовуєш.
Це вже наша інтерпретация. Це не чувство. Чувство — це конкретне емоції. Я чувствую злость, я чувствую грусть, я чувствую обиду, я чувствую страх, разочарування, напряження.
Или я чувствую радість, благодарність і тепло.
Вот це чувство.
Не путати це з обвиненнями.
Наприклад, я чувствую роздраження,
мені стало обидно, я зараз злюсь,
я чувствую растерянність.
Вот це шаг номер два.
Повторюсь, якщо ми будемо чоловіку говорити,
ти мене не уважаєш, це атака, він буде захищатися.
Якщо ми будемо чоловіку говорити,
«Мне сейчас обидно», а це вже контакт.
І у нас є шанс, що людина нас відслушує.
Ця техніка не працює с нарциссами, аб'юзами, психопатами,
але в більшості людей це працює.
Хоча і там це теж може працювати.
Варіанів немає.
Либо ненаслістя на коммунікацію, либо дистанціювання.
Окей.
А у мене вопрос по цьому поводу.
А не чувствуется ли в этом манипуляція і серії на чувство вины продавлювання?
Вот я так себя чувствую?
Чтобы продавить на чувство вины, нужна емоція.
Ми можемо любой текст говорить агрессивно, говорить із жертви,
А, тобто тільки, як подала інформацію, а якщо сухо і холодно, тоді нет, да?
Тут важливо, як ми подаємо інформацію, але по факту у нас особо і немає альтернатив. Альтернативи – це які? Либо ми подавляємо і замалчуємо, либо ми нападаємо і агресуємо.
А це хоча б научний і самий обширно известний меру спосіб, як упакувати це без подавлення своїх границ і без нападення на чужі границі.
Тут є два аспекта. Є логика із пяти шагів і є тон голосу, який ми можемо це робити.
І, як правило, по моєму опыту, коли людина зарані готовиться к такому обращенню,
він зарані составляє цих 5 пунктів, що допомагає йому потім нейтральним голосом без манипуляцій донести.
Щоби викликати чувство вини, треба мати такий мотив.
Якщо у людина возникає чувство вини без нашого мотива у нього викликати, це вже його історія.
Ну, якби саме екологічне, що я знаю, це в четвертому пункте просто говорить, в следующий раз не пойду, пожалуюсь, да, там, грубо говоря, а щоб выровняти вот це в словах чувства, я так чувствую, я
чувствую себя использованным, там, та-та-та-та-та-та-та, і тут же в конце, і якщо ще раз так повторитися, то будеш жоско послан нахер, ну, типо раз і все, і вже чувство вину у человека нет, баланс
восстановився.
Хорошо, то есть, какая тут є ловушечка? Некоторі люди починають мягко сливатися, вони не кажуть свої чувства, які сподіваються. Внутри є злость, але вони кажуть, ну, типо, мене чуть-чуть неприємно.
Нет, треба прямо по факту сказати, донести, що я внутри чувствую злость. Не я чуть-чуть расстроїся, а мене прямо реально больно. То есть, по факту це сказати. Не сглаживати угли.
Вот. Анна, я вважаю, для тебя эта тема горячая.
Когда ты реально злишься, ты не можешь бути нейтральной позиции.
Ты все равно говоришь это с позиции злости.
Я тебя понимаю.
Ты эмоции передаєш, либо когда тебе обидно.
Ты с обидою это говоришь.
Естественно, у человека возникает чувство вины.
Ну я тебя обидел, да, но я не хотела.
Ну, к примеру, да, какую-то там дачу.
Я тебя понимаю. Смотри, давай я сейчас обозначу границы.
розбирати клінищі якісь якісь цікаві, тіфтерапію.
Ці техніка дана для того, щоб підготавливатися зарані.
І коли ми підготавливаємося зарані, обіда в нас тільки не живе.
І ми маємо можливість сказати їм як раз без обіду.
Як роботи з гневом, як роботи з цією обіду?
Пожалуйста, є личні мастера, терапевти, Денис Чернушов теж класно з цим всім роботи.
Але це все личний формат.
Це искусство.
Работати з подавленою агресією і гневом – це одне з найбільших, що може бути з точки зрення, якщо я опираюсь на учення о карме, і це найбільші емоції, з якими можна працювати, емоції гнева.
І там є цялоя наука, як з цим працювати. У мене є цей семинар многочасовий.
Зараз ми сосередоточимося просто на структурі, і я вам дам задання,
яке відповідає, Аня, на твій питання, як підготовитися до цього заблаговременно.
Понятно, що в моменті огонь горит, і все прячуться. Я розумію, тема больша.
Тема большая.
Зараз я предлагаю убрать фильтры і попытаться принять информацию
хотя бы на теоретичному уровню, а потім уже переносити на свою жизнь.
То есть на чому ми остановились?
Коли ми говоримо о своїх чувствах, ми не згадуємо угли,
ми говоримо то, що чуємо, називаємо емоцію конкретизованно.
Не просто я чуть-чуть расстроюся, а мені больно.
Не просто там «мне неприятно», а я чувствую злость і гнев.
Я же могу сказати «ты там та-та-та-та-та-та-та-та»
і весь этот гнев вылить, а могу сказати «я чувствую внутри гнев сейчас на тебе».
Ну, или «я чувствовал вчера гнев».
Иногда нам важно дистанцироваться, емоції прожить, попрактиковать, потрястись, подышать,
ходить в терапию, а потом пойти в открытый диалог, когда все хорошо.
В будь-якому чому, чим раніше ми в них підемемо, тим краще це буде. У нас зараз не урок про відношення, у нас зараз більше, як з клієнтом, можливо, вистраєть гріниці. Применимо абсолютно везде це
практика.
Як говорить Олександр Скрябин, самі величі проблеми згадуться від тих розговорів, які не згадуться. А щоб ці відкриті розговори згадуться, є прекрасна техніка, по якій структурі ці розговори згадуть.
Далі. Третий шаг.
Коли ми озвучили факти, коли ми озвучили свої чуства,
ми більш глупо зараз розбираємо, ми озвучуємо потребності.
Потрібності — це причина, з-за якого у нас якраз і визникають те чуства.
Неудовлетворювання потребності використовує гнів, наприклад, чи обиду.
Тобто це не чоловік нас разозлил, а у нас є якась наша лична потребності,
Которая не удовлетворяється, чоловік о ній не знає.
І з-за цього визникає у нас гнев і обидна.
І головна ідея, в третєм шагі, тут научиться доносити свої цінності, свої потребності до опонента.
Тому що за будь-якою емоцією стоїть какая-то потребності, в даному випадку неудовлетворенна.
Наприклад, злость і гнев – це коли нарушають наші границі, коли нас не уважають.
Обидно, коли не дають внимання, не дають признання.
Тривога визникає, коли немає ясності, коли немає безопасності.
Грусть визникає, коли немає контакта, коли немає близості.
Тобто, ще раз, якщо в мене є потребність в близості, в контакті,
і ця потребність не відовлютворена,
то тоді при замалчуванні я буду чувствувати грусть.
Якщо в мене є потребність в признанні, во вниманні,
і ця потребність не відовлютворена, я тоді буду чувствувати обиду.
Понимаєте, причина следственного зв'язку, неудовлетворена потребності, маркер, якась емоція.
Як не надо говорити. Люди вместо потребності, вони знову озвучують обвинення.
Тому що ти, дорогой, ведеш себе неправильно.
Или потому що ти должен був зробити то-то, то-то і то-то.
Тому що ти мене не цениш. Це не потребності, це продовження обвинений.
Потрібність по розділу другу – це коли ми говоримо о нашій настоящій потребності, о ніякій чоловічній цінності, не прив'язувається до конкретному чоловіку.
Например, у мене є потребності в уваженні, в ясності, у мене є потребності в безпекці, в підтримці, в честності, у мене є потребності в свободі, в віддіхі, в восстановлінні, у мене є потребності в
предсказуємісті, в определінності, а що буде далі?
Или во скільки ми відрітимемося.
Или де ми будемо жити.
Ну і так далі, і так далі.
Тобто якія формула?
«Потому що мені важна» – ви починаєте з цього.
І далі «потребність» озвучивайте.
«Потому що мені важна уваження к моєму времені.
«Потому що мені важна ясність в договірностях.
«Потому що мені важен контакт і внимание».
Це формулировка потребності.
І от ми маємо зв'язку із трьох шагів – факт, чувство і потребність.
Коли ти не відповів на мої сообщення два дня, я почував обиду і напрямку,
тому що мені важливі контакт і ясність.
Тут немає претензії, тут немає обвинення, немає манипуляції.
Ми даємо людину понять себе, при цьому дуже со внутренним стержнем.
І далі ми переходимо к четвертому шагу.
Четвертий шаг – це просьба.
Я прошу или я хочу.
Просьба – це щось, що людина має розуміти однозначно.
Він такий, що в предупрідущому услішив факт, услішив ваше чувство,
услішив вашу невдоволювальну потребність і такий, ну окей, а йому що робити?
Він не розуміє, що йому робити.
Йому треба дати альтернативу, опцію, як йому поступити.
Ви должны його попросити о чому-то.
Це не якась мораль, тобто не будь, тебе треба бути іншим, це не какая-то идея, це конкретний призыв к дійсню, що в цьому ви просите зробити.
Якщо людина не розуміє, що йому в конкреті потрібно зробити, то це не просьба.
Тобто, уважай мене – це не просьба, ввести себе нормально – це не просьба, зміни свою відношення – це не просьба, це абстрактна і абстрактна.
Не будь таким – це не просьба.
Просьба – она конкретна, понятна, осуществима і то, що можна проверити.
Наприклад, можеш не перебивати мене, пожалуй, пока я не закінчу мислю.
Или можеш відповідати мені сьогодні до 18.00.
Или я жду відповідь до 18.00.
Или «Давай договоримся, что после 20.00 пишем только по срочным вопросам».
Четко, ясно, конкретно і понятно.
Или «Можеш сейчас 5 минут просто выслушать меня без совета?»
Включайте таймер, условно говоря.
То есть, що-то конкретне, не абстрактне.
І вот у нас є зв'язка із 4 шагів.
Коли ти не відповідаєш на мої сообщення два дні, я почував обиду.
Мене важен контакт і ясність.
Можеш, будь ласка, дати мне обратну зв'язку, коли прочитаєш, або до 18.00?
І шаг номер п'ять.
Ви виставляєте границю, яку в якому-то смыслі обязуєтесь соблюсти,
якщо вас проигнорирують.
Якщо моя просьба не виконується, у мене є действие, яке я зроблю сам.
Це действие завжди конкретне, випониме, реальне, без угрозы, без манипуляцій.
Ви сами определяєте, що ви будете жалуватися чи не будете жалуватися, условно говоря.
Формула така, якщо це не вийде, тоді я, як не треба, якщо ти будеш так зробити, ти пожалеєш, це обіда, манипуляція, угроза.
Или «я тогда уйду от тебе навсегда, но вы не уйдете, не уходите»,
если мы про отношения говорим.
Или «я більше никогда не буду с тобой общаться».
Це щось неосуществиме, можливо.
Це щось про угрозу, про манипуляцію.
Альтернатива — це якась?
Можеш, будь ласка, не перебивати мене, пока я не закінчу мысль.
Якщо це буде продовжуватися, я тоді остановлю розговор
і повернуся до нього позже.
І якщо вас ігнорирують, то ви останалийте розговор і повернійтеся до нього позже.
Чітке осуществимо действие.
Тобто вам необязательно говорити чи робити, що ви встанете, уйдете.
Ви упаковуєте все це в екологічний контекст.
Или второй пример.
Якщо я не получу від тебе відповідь до 18.00, то куплю штори на свій выбір.
Того цвету, який сочту нужному,
тому що я уїжджаю з магазина.
Третий пример.
Давай після 22.00 писати тільки по срочним вопросам.
Якщо сообщення будуть приходити ночі,
я буду відповідати вже утром.
Тобто ви не ігнорируєте чоловіка,
він вам пишет там в 12 ночі.
Ви його не ігнорируєте, не морозитесь.
Ви дали ясність?
Якщо таке буде продовжуватися, відповідаючи, я буду вже в утрому.
Экологично вистроили границі, ніяких претензій.
Ну, я зараз говорю чуть на повшенних тонах,
тому що в такому стані просто.
Але ви це можете мягко, звичайно, звичайно.
Ви не требуєте, ви просто вистраєте границі.
Получається така історія, що
якщо у нас немає п'ятого шага,
то ми завісимо від від відповіда опонента.
Але якщо в нас є п'ятий шаг, то ми вистроили границі так, як ми хочемо,
ісходя з наших потребностей, целей і желаний.
Якщо в нас є п'ятий шаг, то ми свободні, ми в контакті з собою.
Тобто вся модель для мене не працює без п'ятого шага.
Давайте ще раз повторимо.
Факты.
Коли відбувається, підставляйте свій пример.
Що ви відчуєте, що для вас важливо, які потребности, просьба конкретна і альтернатива.
Якщо немає, то що тоді ви зробите?
Небільше домашнє задання.
Прямо сейчас ви можете, прямо в моменті давайте, щоб не відглазувати,
виписати 3-5 ситуацій, триггерів, які в житті вас реально задевають.
Живі ситуації. У кого-то, може, в відношеннях, у кого-то в роботі,
у кого-то там з подчиненими, де угодно.
Ну, наприклад, там, у мене недавно була така історія,
що девочка, координатор проєкта, опоздала на роздачу еды благотворительной на 10 минут.
На десять минут – це дуже багато в нашому контексті.
І, звісно, я відчував відмущення.
Я не буду на нього нападати, об'юдити, щоб в следующий раз цього не повторялося.
Я можу придумати таке письмо.
Ти во второй раз вже опаздуєш, я відчуваю відмущення.
Для мене важливо, щоб наші роздачи починалися вовремя,
Тому що від цього завіцяється расписання. Около 100 людей. Моя просьба, щоб ти був на місці за 15 минут до початку.
Якщо це ще раз повторитися, то за кожну минуту у нас буде штраф 100 гривень.
Ну, якась така альтернатива заблаговременна, екологична, а не «блин, якого хрена ти опаздуєш, що дела?»
І так далі, і так далі.
Давайте випроси Аліна і Юрій, і потім домашнє задання.
У мене не зовсім запитання, у мене жарт, якщо ви дозволите.
Він такі, знаєте, червоною ниткою по всьому занятті.
Отож, саме про це ненасильницьке спілкування і про той п'ятий пункт.
Значить, одружуються чоловік з жінкою, чоловік такий достатньо впанений в собі, і вони на березі домовляються.
Чоловік каже, я бізнесмен, я багато працюю, я заробляю гроші, ти будеш жити в шоколаді, ні в чому собі не відмовляти, але вечорами вдома мене немає.
В понеділок в мене рибалка, вівторок в мене теніс, в п'ятницю в мене баня, ну, власне, на всі дні, в нього вечір, якісь плани.
Жінка каже, так, прекрасно, я поважаю те, що ти зайнята людина і твій простір.
Але є один маленький нюанс.
В 9 вечора кожного дня у мене секс.
Є ти вдома чи тебе немає?
Чогось мені...
Це анекдот, мені здається, так.
Дякую, дякую.
Я думаю, всі сміялися, просто у всіх виключено мікрофон.
Благодарю.
Юра, будь ласка.
Я хотів би просто продовжити цю нотку. Ви подаєте, що все так просто і легко, але це випадок з вашою дівчинкою.
Щоб за кожну хвилину буде штраф 100 гривень. Я би сказав, Денис Батькович, ну ви що, ми ж всі люди робимо разом добру справу.
Вони, як 100 гривень. Маєте зрозуміти, що я ж можу запізнатися, як жива людина. Ми тут з вами добру справу робимо, а не по 100 гривень штрафу виписуємо.
Так а до мене на зарплаті?
Так ми добрі справи робимо, що ви не розумієте людських потреб. Ми ж з вами разом благодійну справу робимо добре. У вас мають тут добрі серця, а не чисто якісь фінансові мотивації.
Юра, смотри, я же не буду продолжать коммуникацию, я просто назначу штраф. Ну то есть, это такой пример. В пятом шаге должно быть то, что ты можешь реально сделать. Реально сделать. Со стороны сейчас
может казаться, что я такой деспотичный, но на самом деле нет. Я в общении с людьми очень мягкий, этичный, экологичный.
І в мене більше була стратегія не агресії, нападення, штрафів і так далі.
У мене більше була стратегія раніше в житті подавлення, замалчування.
Ти цей коментарий, ісходя з чого хотів озвучити?
Тобто ти хотів озвучити, ісходя з того, що цей метод не працює,
чи як його применити, більш практичний, чи що?
Более практично. На бумажці звучить завжди дуже класно.
Але я скільки сесій провожу, скільки я з людьми общаюсь, це ніколи не працює.
Тому що завжди, я в чаті писав, що ой, ти поробили 15 хвилин, нічого страшного.
Ти починаєш, нічого страшного, чи що це? Не роби мухи і слона.
Типа, якби все було просто так логично решати, на уровні раз, два, три проговорити,
то в мире не було б никакого інтереса.
Я ні разу не бачив, щоб ця штука просто в житті не работала.
Она звучит класно, сто процентов.
Да, я услышав тебя, я услышав.
У мене опит якой?
Це дійсно не працює, як я вже сказав,
з людьми, с которими токсична связь сильна.
Абюзери, психопати, там це тако себе не працює.
Либо с людьми, які чисто на своєй волне.
І тут є перший факт.
Якщо відкриті діалоги, вони нас не спліжають,
значить нечому було спліжатися.
І тут тоді такий вопрос.
А що мене заставляє бути з тими людьми,
які не піднімають мої потребності,
і ми не можемо с ними синергично дійсно дійсно.
Второй момент.
У мене бача клієнтська практика,
Де цей метод дуже круто працює, навіть в больших, ярких ситуациях.
І як його роблю я з клієнтами один на один.
Ми перший раз завжди заблаговременно готовимося.
І да, ми це можемо зробити навіть не в процесі розговора, щоб у чоловіка був шанс тебе перебити.
Ми пишемо на бумагі йому,
либо ми записуємо голосове сообщення.
І тоді у нього немає шанса нас перебити,
і є шанс дослухати все від початку до конца
і пройти, усовно кажучи, весь этот продаючий вебинар наших потребностей.
Якщо це не поможе, то ми повернуємося.
А що тоді нас об'єднує?
Така історія.
Ти говориш, що в мире не було б війн, війни ведуть нарцисси, психопати і так далі. Тут це не працює. Безусловно. Але 80% каких-то робочих моментів, недопониманий, ця техника може решити. Я не кажу,
що це панацея, але це дуже практичний інструмент.
І якщо вибираєть між подавлением агресії і техніко-динсерічної коммуникації, то це то, що працює.
Ось домашнє задання, яке я пропоную.
Прямо зараз вибирати три, чи одну, чи две ситуации, які вас триггерять, возмущають, цепляють.
Беріть якісь живі, ваше насущні ситуації.
Ви записали їх. Далі, вибирайте одну з цих всіх ситуацій, на якій просто потренироватися, освоити цей метод. І третий шаг – це напишіть прямо письмо, текстом, желательно от руки, але можна і на компі
.
Прямо по вотій формуле, яку я дал. Факт, коли ти. Чувство, я чувствую. Потребність, що для мене важна. Просьба і альтернатива. Як ви позаботитесь о себе саме?
І ви берете перший уровень джедая, якщо ви просто це напишете,
навіть не будете нікому його відносити, ви реально прокачаєтесь.
І, можливо, в яких-то общеннях ви вже по-другому почнете коммуніцировати.
А цель ненасильственої коммуникації – це доносити свої цінності і потребності до оппонента.
Второй уровень джедая – це ви відправите це письмо.
Либо прям романтично, в свірточці,
либо текстом в телеграмі,
либо голосом в телеграмі.
Текстом, коли ви відправляєте,
чоловік може читати абсолютно разним тоном голоса.
Він може думати, що ви кричите на нього цим текстом, нападаєте.
Але якщо ви спокійним голосом запишете голосове, пройдя по структуре, він услышит вашу емоцію, що ви не нападаєте, і услышит всі цінності.
Давайте я приведу свой другой пример, если с девочкой так зацепил. У меня был лимит на карте, и я не мог отправить деньги, вот эти, знаете, ограничения за эту студию. Я не хотел с других карт снимать
процент, я ждал первое число. Короче, мне так было выгодно, я не хотел там терять какую-то тысячу гривен, условно говоря.
І мені... А там бачі чеки зимой завжди, по студії, по отоплінню, по варенню, і мені не хазіва, а ОСББ, як це називається, спрашивають, коли деньги? Я їм кажу, що 1 числа лимит спадет і так, і я відп
равлю.
Вони що-то проигнорировали і написали мені письмо, що ми відключимо світ тоді і тоді в студії. Буквально поставили перед фактом за два дні. Я званю сначала по-человечески, з ними вияснюю відношення,
і там це не работает. Система бюрократії не работает.
І тоді я зробляю письмо таке текстове, с чатом GPT юридичне, по цій структурі ненасильственній коммуникації, що вони повинні відомити за 10 днів.
Якщо вони це не зроблять, то їх действие не санкціонувано, як це називається.
Я буду обращаться там в вышестоящі органи.
Проблема решилась за 5 минут.
Ну, типо, за 5 минут.
Альтернативи какой-то нет. Чоловік уже перед выбором стоит.
Либо він делает то, що ми предлагаємо, либо ми робимо то, що ми обещаємо зробити.
Ну, вот. Там, де важливо зробити ось ці границя.
Тут? Можна підхватить?
Не, структура дуже класна, в тому плані, а, для розуміння самого себе
і для осознання, де моя грань, щоб простроити.
Я більше про те, що коли ти на практиці просто говориш,
треба бути готовим до того, що інший людина буде давати інший фідбек.
І не завжди ти зможеш по цій структурі піти,
але в голові себе концептуально зробити – це топ, я считаю.
Дякую, Юра.
бояться потерять те, що вже є.
Чому там дівчина не може сказати парню
о своїх потребностях,
а коли ми будемо жити вместе?
Тому що бояться потерять те отношения,
які є зараз.
Якщо вона затронє цю тему,
то тоді вони взагалі можуть розтатися.
Дя, але я ж кажу,
а якщо після проясняючих розговорів
ми не зближаємся,
то тоді не було чому зближатися.
Я не вижу ніяких противоречий.
І так, давайте проговорю домашнє задання.
І підемо далі. Наталья, віжу руху.
І так, ви вибрали тему. Віделіть буквально 5-7 минут.
Не йдіть зразу в какую-то саму насущну, горячу тему с якими-то супер-близкими людьми.
Пожалуйста, без терапевта не треба.
Возьміть щось среднестатистичне, какую-то среднюю претензію к миру.
І потренируйтеся на ній.
Какі-то там прості моменти.
Я уверяю, якщо ви взємете цю практику в свою життя,
Це одне з найкращого, що відкриває перед вами нові двери, можливості відношення, результату і т.д.
І так, Наталья, питання, питання, питання, і йдемо далі під наші тери.
Місці, питання на Юрина і на цю ситуацію, на домашнє задання.
Я вказалася в такій ситуацією, що два року підряд, у мене є образовання і опит, я була інструктором по греблі на САП.
Ну, і з чоловіком, який мені предложив цю роботу, я не взаємодійувала.
Але в цьому року там міняється условія, ми почали з ним взаємодійувати, і спасибо обучению в МСММ.
Я поняла, що мені з цим чоловіком не комфортно, тому що він манипулятор.
І для нього взросле взаємодійство не підходить.
Ну, він починає як-то так прямі розговори, прямі вопросы.
І я вчора відправила йому по вашій схемі, яку ви сьогодні дали, кроме п'ятого пункта.
Насильственні. Свої умови, свої чувства.
Вот це все.
Почему я відправила?
Тому що я перед цим приняла,
що якщо мої умови не вистрають, ми прощаємося.
І ви теж класно сказали, що о тому,
що якщо ми не готові к цьому результату,
тому ми не йдемо в цю коммуникацію,
де є вигода і відстаивання своїх границ,
як мені ок і як мені не ок.
Тому прикольно.
Супер. Благодарю за обратну связь.
Це дуже ценно, і підемо далі.
Я рекомендую, звісно ж, з наставником, з терапевтом
якісь великі глобальні питання по цій техній рішати.
А з средністатистичні можна і самостійно.
Якщо ви ще не освоили цей навык.
Тому що тут же все збирається.
І наші цінності, і наші потреби, і наші желання.
І на що ми готові, на що ми не готові.
Тут прям бачу пласт роботи.
Окей, тут у мене пример, давайте ради того, що просто є цей слайд, я його зачитаю і перейдемо к дальнішому матеріалу.
Коли ми договаруємося зустрітися, і в останній момент зустрічі відменяється, я відчуваюся роздраження і розчарування,
тому що мені важливі уваження до моєму вирені і відчування надіжності в нашій договірності.
Можеш, будь ласка, передупріждати хоча б за нескільки часів, якщо плану змінюються.
Я буду считати зустрічу неактуальна, якщо ти не підтвердив її за два часа, і пойду на свою тренувку.
Така себе історія.
Я думаю, все понятне.
Хорошо, ми зараз переходимо до публичного виступлення. Поднімите руку, хто готов?
Ірина готова? Давай, перша подняла руку.
Попривітствуем Ірину, будь ласка, включайся. Я напомню, у нас 3-5 минут.
І все, як звичайно. Включай мікрофончик.
Так, я підняла першу руку, дякую, тому що якраз в мене тему я взяла конфлікт.
Тому зараз я і собі думаю.
Так.
Хто читав книги про конфлікти?
Як їх вирішувати?
Як домовлятись?
Як знаходити контролюс?
Дайте якийсь певний фідбек, лайки.
Тема гаряча, про конфлікти, багато інформації
і, звісно, неодноразово ми до них зверталися.
Але тепер інше питання.
Хто після тих книг перестав в дійсності конфліктувати і мати ситуації, які є конфліктними?
Бо нас часто вчать вирішувати.
А сьогодні я буду говорити про інше.
Про те, як не довести до того, що потрібно вирішувати.
Уявіть пожежу. Пожежники приїхали, загасили, молодці.
А тепер уявіть, якби пожежі не було взагалі.
Бо ми часто витрачаємо руки на те, щоб навчитись гасити
і продовжуємо розпалювати щодня одними словами,
одним тоном, одними реакціями.
І знаєте, що найболючіше?
Більшість тих конфліктів можна було зупинити одним словом раніше,
одним словом менше.
Мене звати Ірина Купчик, я є імміграційний медіатор,
ментор та коуч в Італії.
Я живу в іншомовному світі багато років, і я знаю зсередини, що це таке, коли ти хочеш сказати одне, а виходить інше, коли слів не вистачає, коли передаєш не той сенс, який хочеш, а той, який можеш.
І в цьому величезна вразливість, бо люди чують не те, що ти маєш на серці, а те, що ти зміг сказати.
Саме тут народжуються непорозуміння, образи, конфлікти, не зі злого умислу, а просто тому, що слово не те.
Запитайте себе зараз, скільки разів у вашому житті вас зрозуміли неправильно?
Скільки з тих разів це коштувало вам стосунків, роботи, спокою, себе?
І нас дійсно вчать, як виходити з конфлікти.
А я пропоную зовсім інше питання – як до нього не заходити?
І це не слабкість, це не боягуство, це не уникнення.
Це є вищий рівень людини, вищий рівень комунікації, вищий рівень життя.
Бо найсильніша людина в кімнаті не та, яка перемогла в суперечці,
а та, яка побачила, де починається вогонь і не піднесла сірника.
Це відгукується вам?
Оставте тоді вогник якраз в коментарях або сердечка.
І одне питання, яке зупиняє конфлікт ще до того, як він почався.
Що для мене зараз важливіше – бути правим чи зберегти людину?
Не на все потрібно реагувати, не кожне слово заслуговує відповіді, не кожна провокація варта вашого спокою.
Пауза – це не програш, пауза – це вибір сильної людини.
І ця навичка, як і будь-яка інша, тренується.
Людина, яка навчилась не доводити до конфлікту, живе інакше.
У неї інші стосунки, інша енергія вранці, інша якість кожного дня.
бо вона не витрачає себе на війни, які можна було не починати.
Слова або будують мости між людьми, або спалюють їх.
І найбільша майстерність – це говорити так, щоб мости залишались цілими.
Я працюючи з людьми, які живуть в іншомовному світі,
передають не той сенс, який хочуть, а той, який можуть.
Які роками кажуть, мова не вчиться і зупиняються ще до першого слова.
Які бояться підійти до незнайомої людини, бо а раптом не так скажу, а раптом не зрозуміють, а раптом обсудять.
Які живуть у постійному відчутті конфлікту вдома, на роботі, всередині себе.
Я сама через це пройшла. Я знаю, як це коли є що сказати, але немає слів, щоб передати це точно.
І я знаю, це можна змінити, тому що мова – це не талант, впевненість – це не характер, комунікація – це не дар обраних, це навичка і їй можна навчитись.
І якщо це про тебе, напиши в коментарі одне слово. Говорю, я побачу і я тобі відпишу. Дякую.
Дякую, Ірина.
Як себе чуствуєш зараз?
Добре. Трішки такий був густий момент.
Добре, я не розумію. Як себе чуствуєш? Кака емоція?
Емоція зараз трішки хвилювання. Емоційного хвилювання.
Тобто добре – це емоційне хвилювання, так?
Так, це емоційне хвилювання.
Добре. Якщо зжати зараз в одне словосочетання, то який головний меседж у виступлінні?
Що дар мови його потрібно навчитися правильно використовувати. Це залог успіху в комунікації між людьми.
Хорошо. Допустим, допустим.
Так, що я себе тут зафіксував?
Мені понравився, там був момент, коли ти почала говорити о себе.
Тобто у тебе було вступлення, а потім ти представилась.
І коли ти почала представляться, я почувствувала у тебе уверенність,
прям какую-то харизму, у тебе другой тон голоса,
і прям у тебе огненна така личність, такий стержень є.
Коли ти читала інший текст, то там опять включилась, як і у Алини було,
ця абстрактна театральність без персоналізації.
Я не представляю якого ти зараз конкретного чоловіка, яку ти читаєш.
І у нас відбувається цей стихотворний tone of voice.
Да, і ми це чуваємо. Я просто, я кожному готов це говорити, що, наверно, найголовніше, щоб відбувався контакт, це має бути 2-й, з кем я цей контакт делаю, кому я цей текст говорю. Персоналізація.
Второй момент. Когда ти просиш, поставте огонек, кому актуальна эта тема, ти включаєш аудиторію, щоб аудиторію включити, с нею треба завести контакт.
То есть, ну, в данном случае тут GPT сплоховало, но ты, когда будешь готовиться, вступление, там должно быть вступление какое-то, вступление, которое нас объединяет.
Вот мы встретились, и вот сейчас мы будем взаимодействовать. А вы? Ну, и, угу.
То есть, мы не можем попросить что-то сделать кого-то, до этого не сформировав хоть какие-то отношения.
Від цей момент я б тебе зафіксував.
Ну, взагалі я рекомендую, конечно, це мій косяк, то, що ви не підготовились сегодня,
але я рекомендую писати текст самим.
Писати текст самим, і я вам дам для цього багато структур.
Я себе записав, що для мене це було виступлення похоже на главу книги, як будто я слушаю книгу.
Якщо я відношусь до цього як голосовая книга, то тоді мені ок.
Якщо я відношусь до цього як виступлення, то тоді мені дуже неперсонально, не личностно.
А як як глава із книги ти читаєш, то прекрасно.
Які ти сама можеш зробити для себе вивіди з цього?
Ти молодець, ти виступила, ти підняла руку, ти піднялася, отрималася, потренировалася.
З цього можу сказати, що на даний момент навіть, я в будь-якому випадку всі свої виступи готую завжди сама.
З чатом, з допомогою, але я їх максимально потім додаю, але це в моїй діяльності.
тобто тут я розумію що це не настільки ще поки що моя тема і от коли я типу говорю там
на імміграційні теми та от там я знаю болі я знаю як їх взяти як ними керувати як їх піднести
на що дати акцент а тут ніби зараз навіть оце все навчання я знову ж таки от коли і це готували
Топ, стоп, стоп, стоп, стоп, стоп, от зараз, як ти говориш, от зараз твой тонов військ, от зараз твоя подача,
от її запомню, от ти, це от ти настояще, аутентична, от ти, от я хочу, щоб ти так спілкувалася на сцені,
от як ти зараз со мною говорила. Можеш зрозуміти це, запомнити, осознати і ось цей вайб перенести, так?
Ось воно, ось воно, ось я почуваю зараз, окей? Ось це успіш.
Дякую.
Спасибо. Благодарю тебя. Благодарю. Моя задача якась? Ми з якої точки А в якій точці Б йдемо?
Із точки А – імперсональна абстракція. Точка Б – це конкретна личності, аутентичність, простота і естественность.
Воно ти, воно. Оно є. Спасибо. Подніміть руху, хто следующий, будь ласка.
Кристина, до перерывчика.
Давайте, я попробую. Я сразу предупреждаю, буду читать, потому что только сейчас подготовилась.
Но це тема, я в нее верю, я ее розвиваю і подписываюсь під кожним словом.
Все, можна починать?
А ти по готовности, пожалуйста, начинай.
Здравствуйте, друзі! Мене звуть Рут і моя річ посвящена тем, у кого підписчиків більше,
чем друзей в реальній жизни. Поднімите, будь ласка, руки те, хто сьогодні утром
посмотрел в телефон, а не в окно і не на близького чоловіка.
Ми с вами живем в епоху идеального онлайна. У нас сотни друзей в соцсетях, 1000 лайків і іллюзії того, що ми ніколи не буваємо одиноким.
Ну давайте признаемся, смайлики никогда не заменят живой іскренній улыбки, а текстове сочувствие не сравнится с крепким рукопожатием или теплыми объятиями.
Сегодня я хочу поговорить с вами о магії оффлайн-общения. Переживаю.
Молодець, Сумичка, продовжай.
Живу общення – це не просто обмен інформацією, це обмен енергією.
Коли ми дивимося вона в глинах, ми читуємо мимику, чуваємо інтонання, улавливаємо паузи.
Іменно в ці моменти рождеся настояще довері.
Кожене нове офлайн-знакомство – це відкриття цього світа.
Встреча в кафе, случайний разговор на конференцій или на этом курсе
можуть повністю змінити траєкторію вашої життя.
Случайні люди приносять неслучайні идеи,
відкривають перед нами двери, о существовании которых ми навіть не подозривали,
і дарять можливості, які ти не знайдеш ні в одному поискові.
Інвестиції людей – це найнадежній інвестицій на протягові всей нашої життя.
Старі друзі — це наші опори, наші пам'ять і наші корні.
Нові друзі — це наш рост і свежий взгляд на цей мир.
Коли нам важко, ми не іщем ідеальний пост в ленті.
Ми іщем чоловіка.
Ми іщем того, хто виснушає без осуждення.
Люди, котрих ми впускаємо в свою реальну, а не виртуальну життя,
становяться нашим головним капіталом, нашим безопасним пространством.
Друзі, життя зміряється не количеством підписчиків,
вона зміряється глибиною наших зв'язків.
Прямо сьогодні, вийдя з цього зала, зробіть одну просту вещь.
Не пишіть сообщення, а позвоніть другу.
Познакомісь з понравившимся вам чоловіком і пригласіть його на кофі.
Давайте звернутися в реальність.
Ведь саме інтересне в цій житті происходит не на екранах смартфонів,
а прямо сейчас между нами.
Щас я вже почти все.
Давай-давай, я с тобою.
Щас я води, щас, секундочку.
Фей, Валичку.
Я нервничала.
Давай.
Реча хороша.
Прекрасно, ти вовсе огонь.
Так, на своем личному опыте я знаю,
що широкий круг общения –
це не тільки твій тыл, підтримка і безпецість,
Це ще сильніший соціальний ліфт, де, благодаря верним друзьям і знакомим,
ти не карабкаєшся по ступеням годами, а взлетаєш на нові етапи своєї життя в рази швидше.
І це не завжди про общення 24 на 7.
Іногда одній беседі буває достатньо, щоб через 5 років имати можливість друг до другоу обратитися,
помічі чи приложити нові можливості.
Ми ніколи не знаємо, де і як станемо друг другу полезним.
О, ка мені стущається зараз.
Тому я приглашаю вас в своє сообщество ГРО, в якому ви зможете заявити себе, прокачати свій навык коммуникації,
знайти нових друзей, клієнтів, создати якісь колабориції,
чи просто знайти людина, з ким можна буде піти в театр.
Буду рада кожного з вас в ньому видити.
Щас двері відкрой.
Ми поки похлопаємо, поки ти відкриваєш двері.
Умничка, молодец.
і я дождусь тебе, щоб дати обратну зв'язку.
Все, ой, я так переживала.
Хорошо, ти як себе почуваєш?
Волнительно дуже.
Волнительно.
Где це волнення в телі?
В груди і серце быстро стучит.
Хорошо, що ще почуваєш?
Радість.
Радість. От чого це радість?
Ну, от того, що спробувала.
Попробувала, тішилася.
Я на своїх нетворкингах виступаю, але перед тим, як виступати, я 20 раз репетирую і потім просто йду вже, ну, уверена. А зараз, коли у мене речі не підготовлено, мне тяжело.
А я тебе розумію абсолютно. Це не тільки тебе, це всім так тяжело, коли текст держат, коли ми не в контексте матеріала, це нормальна історія. Прекрасний голос, харизма, внешність, ну, то есть все
здорово.
Мене дуже подобається тему, яку ти вибрала.
Це добре. Попадання в аудиторію, зразу все себе знають.
Ось дуже круто.
У GPT какая-то странна сьогодні основна частина.
Ні не хватило рішення, що з цим робити конкретно.
Крім того, що к тебе підійти записатися в ком'юнити і знайти друзів, єдиномішників.
Але це питання к GPT більшим.
Смотри, тобі не треба нічого особо міняти, я би тобі просто дадав домашнє задання практичне.
Це домашнє задання – записувати себе на камеру, коли ти читаєш вслух 5 минути в день.
І задача – не читати вслух просто 5 минути в день, а потім смотреть це.
І коли ти будеш дивитися на себе со стороны, ти будеш привыкати.
Тобто, якщо я себе режисерський розбирав, то я би сказав, чим сейчас чоловік займається.
Він спешит. Він хоче побыстрі успіхати і спригнути відсюди.
А коли ти будеш вдома привыкати робити з камерою, читати, потім дивитися на себе,
то у тебе появиться привычка, ти привыкнеш к себе, к своєму голосу, к своєю внешністью,
как ты выглядеш со стороны, ты не будеш торопиться,
і у тебе возникнет вот це ощущение, я имею место быть, я могу не спешити.
Плюс це всім задання таке, ви можете 5 минут в день,
якщо у вас є амбиції розвивати свою речі, емоційний інтелект, читати вслух.
Ми можемо читати ще з карандашом в зубах, типо…
Так дикція артикуляції улучшається.
Ми можемо читати з зубами сомкнутими, губами разомкнутими,
і наоборот, з зубами разомкнутими, а губами сомкнутими.
І потім нормально, обикновеним вслух.
Але коли ми записуємо себе на камеру, ми привікаємо до себе, ми дивимося на себе зі сторони, а не зі своїх чувств, зі своїх відволнений, і це дуже терапевтично.
Тому я рекомендую тебе це делать, учитывая то, що у тебе все і так прекрасно, хорошо, я би нічого не менію. Чувається, що у тебе є свій внутренній мир, розуміння многих речей.
І я думаю, що такі базові практики, як чтення вслух на камеру і пересматривання,
чи виступлення публічного, коли ти репетіруєш,
знімати себе зі сторони, а потім цю репетицію пересматривати,
це дуже практичний і терапевтичний ефект не висок.
Класно, що ти тексти сама робиш, готовиш к своїм нетворкингам,
я уверен, що у тебе є совмєстима аудиторія, і з цим все прекрасно.
Я навіть нетворкинг создала для того, щоб тренироватися, говорити на публіку.
Тобто, виходити зі зону комфорта і репетувати все це.
Це дуже смело.
Многі люди действують наоборот, вони спочатку треніруються, а потім создають нетворкинги. А ти прямо як... Я теж вот такий, я теж вот такий.
Тому це здорово, це здорово. Це де, який міст?
Ну, зараз я живу в Тбилисі. Заборожчя, потім жила в Ізраїль, а зараз ми в Тбилисі временно.
Прекрасно. Тбилисівцям повезло, чи як їх назвати?
Хорошо, Кристина, благодарю за це виступлення. Домашнє задання зафіксируйте себе. Пожалуйста, практикуйте, записывайте.
Потому что, помните, раніше була така історія, що люди не піднімали свій голос.
Они слухають себе і кажуть, це що, мій голос? О боже!
Але це було коли? Це було 5-10 років, 20 років тому.
Почему таке происходит?
Потому что ми просто в ушах себе слухаємо по одному, а диктофон записуємо.
І ми слухаємо по-другому, і в нас злухається нікий шок.
Ми в шокі просто от цього.
Не то, що нам не подобається, ми не привыкли.
Але зараз век голосових сообщень, ми кожен день записуємо і слухаємо свій голос.
І ми привыкли.
Але на камеру багато себе не записуємо.
Не все там виставляють рівси.
А якщо виставляють рівси, вони вам постановочні.
Тому, коли ми записуємо себе на камеру в обычій житті, як ми готовимо, як ми читаємо і со сторони камера просто стоїть, як ми робимо якісь віщі, ми привікаємо к себе, к своєй обусловленості.
Це дає бачу терапевтий еффект прийнятия себе і легше проявлятися, тому що ми привікли вже к себе.
Ну, вот так вот.
Хорошо. 14.30. У нас по плану перерыв. У нас по плану тут один перерыв на 30 минут, мы его не использовали. Вам надо 15 минут или 30 минут?
Никому не надо на 30 минут, да? Тогда давайте 15 минут перерыв. Супер. 15 минут перерыв, я вас жду через 15 минут 14.45.
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
з того, що ми розуміємо, що таке проявлінність більш здорового і що таке проявлінність із травм.
І, можливо, ще хтось захочет проявитися, виступити, і далі підтожимо все наше.
Я точно виступаю, коли можна, а тільки в кінці я доделую все.
Хорошо.
Відповідь на увагу.
І я, і я хочу.
І Анна, успіем все, успіем.
Я заметив таку історію, не тільки я.
У мене недавно був конфлікт, не то щоб конфлікт, конфлікта особо і не було,
Просто ми не сшлися з однією личності.
Але ця личності достатньо проявляється уверені
в контексті обучення інших людей в тому числі.
І для мене був шок.
Я не розумію, як так можна,
що ми говоримо в мир одне,
а свої якісь моменти не залишаємо.
Це естественна історія, я такий же.
У мене куча, множество, точніше,
якісь проєкції, які я до сих пор не розумію.
Як говорить Василий Бугель,
Многі з нас з детства нехвалені, нехвалені, обіцценені і закритиковані.
Ми розвиваємся, ми з цим що-то робимо,
Але нельзя не відмітити два лагеря людей.
Перві, які проявляються із травми,
Ні з боли, ні зі цих настоячих живих чуств, як сьогодні Лера нам показала.
А именно з бісознательної, отчасти нарциссистській дыри.
Ці лагері людей і лагері людей, які займаються собою, які займаються своєю психікою, їх проявлінність в корні відлічається.
І якщо говорити коротко, то контент із травми – це завжди про доказати щось через свій контент,
розоблачити кого-то, обвинить кого-то, либо спасти, либо компенсувати.
І там є підсознательний мотив – дивіться, я прав, я лучше, я чітко знаю, як правильно і як неправильно жити.
І часто чоловік проявляється з травми, тому що не осознає цього, він не видит.
Чоловік не видит свою травму, він смотрит сквозь її призму.
Пока він це не осознає посредством множества доступних інструментів, це не зміниться.
Але ми з вами, в контексті, тут підрозуміється, що ми осознаємо свої травми, хоча б головний із них.
Тому цей матеріал я даю конкретно в подобних обученьях, не даю в відкритий доступ.
Тобто є якась внутрення боль, що я недостатньо цінен, важен, нужний, що мене не виберуть, що я должен щось доказати, що я щось значу.
І ці речі часто формируються давним-давно, ще в діттві, в яких-то відношеннях, як правило, рідницьких чи любовних, формируються через опит отвердження, через опит наказання.
І психика створить нікую компенсатию, щоб не відчувався, бою, здається стратегія противоположності, доказати свою значимость, бути лучше всіх, контролювати, учити других, обесценивати других і так
далі, і так далі. Множество в різних оттенках. Ми зараз не розуміємо психологію.
В приложені TEA у Юлії Козачкової є прекрасний марафон Дениса Чернышова «Маски любви». Рекомендую вам його изучити.
Так вот, чоловік починає діювати через компенсатию, і все рил, все виступлення, вони строяться на цьому фундаменті.
Человек думає, що він просто живет, просто говорить свою правду, розвивається, делиться чим-то.
І постепенно це ще більше укрепляється в нем, становиться його личностю.
Переходить час, чоловік вже дуже сильно отождествлен і ідентифіційован з цим образом.
Він захищає свою роль, свою маску, свій образ, строить вокруг нього контент.
І не то, щоб це плохо, не то, щоб я запрещаю так кому-то робити.
Просто, якщо ми в професії, допомагаючи коучи, психотерапевти, ми повинні осознавати один простой алгоритм, що травма порождає травму, здоровая психика може відсцелити тих, хто хоче здорову психику.
Ми можемо аналізувати свій контент спосередньо того, що це буде виходити в більш сознательний рівень.
Ми можемо наш контент оздоравливати і, соответственно, увеличити влияние оздоровлення на інших людей, як ми цим займаємося.
Тобто як ми можемо проявлятися, як може виглядеться наш контент, коли він відсотків з травми?
Много доказів, багато полярності, що мир черно-белий, ось люди правильні, ось люди токсичні.
Много обісценивання других, що ми либо скрыто, либо підтекст якийсь несем, що більшість людей спів, більшість людей чогось не розуміють, вони знаходяться в безсознанці, і так далі, і так далі.
Заряженості.
Що таке заряженості?
Це коли, знаєте, контент,
він...
Тон голоса у чоловіка,
навіть не тон голоса, а в цілому атмосфера,
чувствується, що таке напряження,
я декажу зараз.
Вот так правильно, так неправильно.
Вот...
Така агресивна защита
своєї позиції.
Агресивна защита своєї позиції.
Хто розумієте мене – пошли за мене, хто не розумієте – ви лошарі, ви недалекі, я вас уничтожу.
Вот така позиція. Абюзивний контент.
І, кстати, раніше це дуже модно було, багато аудиторій з жертви умонастроений любили такий контент внимати.
Пятий пункт – це скрытая борьба.
То есть, навіть якщо чоловік говорить за якісь великих смыслів,
внутри ощущається некий конфлікт, раздрайв.
Самий яркий маркер – це завісність від реакції окружаючих.
Тобто, якщо мені ставить плюсик – я вдохновляюся, я верю в себя, я продолжаю.
Якщо мені ставить минусик – критику, хейт, осуждення,
не дай Бог, розбори на ютуб какие-то разоблачаючі,
як знаменитих інфобізнесменів,
то відбувається демотивация,
слияние з цим критиками, хейтом,
і як следствие відбувається самобичевання, не веря в себе.
Тобто, коли наша самооценка прив'язана к мнению окружаючих.
По факту, наша самооценка, к чому може бути прив'язана?
Вона може бути прив'язана к аудиторії,
либо у мене є внутрення решима, стержень, самоценность.
Либо я отчасти можу передати це в руки своїх учителей,
які мене люблять, знають і ведуть.
І це синтез внутрення стержня з наличием авторитетів учителей, які люблять.
Це моя суб'єктивна така історія.
В нашому світі є така тенденція – я сам себе учитель, мені ніхто не потрібен, але вас я буду учить.
І тоді людина противоречить сам себе, що мені учитель не потрібен, але вам учитель потрібен, і вот є я.
Опять ж, це все йде відкуде? Із-за каких-то конфліктів, як правило, з отцом, або з мамою.
Контент здорового чоловіка, обикновеного, простого.
Як ми можемо його наблюдувати?
Ви-перше, він відбувається з личного опыту, а не з якого-то боротьби доказати.
Тобто, не «почому мир токсичний», а «вот, що я в житті зрозумію».
«Вот, що я в житті зрозумію».
Т.е. я не учу сверху, а я делюсь тими виводами, інструментами, навыками
или своими ошибками, які мені помогли.
Якщо кому-то це треба, то, будь ласка, беріть.
Возможно, це сделає вашу життя лучше.
Але я не привязан к тому, що возьмут чи не возьмут.
Т.е. формула така.
Ось що я зрозумів на собственному опыту.
Буквально недавно я проводив ефір з дуже класним психотерапевтом.
І ми обговорили таку тему, як мотивуватися, коли травматичні ціли вже не вдиховляють. Доказати, спасти, заслужити вже не вдиховляють, там немає энергії, там немає бензіна, на який можна їхати, стро
ити бізнес, достигати, завоєвати.
нової соєдненості ще немає, і вона сама проживає такий путь, що не знає відповідь на цю тему.
І вона говорить, давай ми поїздимо, не дадим готовий відповідь, а поїздимо і поділимся своїм опитом.
І це така здоровая позиція.
Також здоровий контент може бути з любопитства.
Мене інтересно узнавати мир, інтересно узнавати людей, інтересно узнавати якісь нові ідеї.
Я не позиціоную себя як гуру, абсолютну істину.
Мене інтересно узнавати, я ісследую, і я цим делюсь.
Вот такий маркер може бути.
Мене інтересно понять, як думають інші, що є ще, а як ще може бути.
Інтересно, я любопитен в хорошому смыслі цього слова.
Також, це може бути мотивація і служення.
Не дивитися, що я, Денис Чернушов, умний, а, можливо, це вам поможуть.
Не я сейчас всех научу життя, а вот если вот эти инструменты вам пригодятся, беріть їх, пожалуйста, пользуйтесь.
Це служення, оно, як правило, простекає з такого здорового сострадання, не жертвенного спасательства, а ну мне не жалко, ну вот я знаю точно, что это работает.
Вот у мене это сработало. Сработає ли у вас? Ну, скорее всего, тоже да. Ну, вот так, вот открыто.
Учитывая свободу воли і вибору чоловік.
Четвертий пункт, маркер такого здорового контекта,
он може бути із зрелости.
Іноді нам важливо дійсно зазреть.
Тобто в такому контенті із зрелости
завжди можуть бути якісь неоднозначні нюанси, сомнення, сложності.
немає чорно-белого мир.
Це не противорічит тому, що я казав раніше,
що у нас повинна бути чітка позиція, що добре, що неплохо.
Але є якісь питання більшого характеру,
там, смысл життя і так далі,
в якому є пространство для сомнений, для свободи вибору.
І там немає догму чорно-белого.
В цьому контенті завжди є пространство для того, щоб у слухателі була почва для розміщення, для рефлексії, а не готові відповіди.
«Вот це черное, вот це белое, вот це хорошо, вот це плохо, вот так вот делай, вот так вот не делай».
По факту, це як Василий сьогодні, він не відповів на питання, він задававав питання.
І здоровий контент часто базується на тому, що ми постійно задаємо питання.
І наше мастерство в тому, щоб ми задавали правильні питання,
які будуть приводити людина до більшого розуміювання себе,
цьому міру, той чи іншій темі, ниші.
Це більш зрелий контент, тому що ми, коли задаємо вопросы, ми не випячиваємо себе в центр.
Ми, коли задаємо вопросы, ми включаємо людина, і він, естественним образом, сам проходити цікування.
Пятий маркер – це контент, созданий з внутрішнього покої.
То есть, як я вже сказав, цей контент не стремиться наказати, доказати, уничтожити. Человек просто делиться своїм пониманням, тим, що считається цінним і важним. І, як правило, коли людина в здоровій
психі вже знаходиться, то він так чи інакше буде делитися чим-то цінним і важним, і не буде делитися чим-то нецінним і неважним.
Разниця просто в тому, що як і контент цього чоловіка, так і сам цей чоловік,
він пройшов цей путь і йдет його в якихось сферах життя.
Тобто через бой к пониманию, інтегрировання опыта,
яке превращається в мудрость.
Як ми на самому першому занятію з вами изучали таку структуру арка героя.
Помніте, є герой, у нього є своя точка А,
с ним случається какой-то кризис,
этот кризис несет определенные боли,
эта боль потом інтегрирується в выводы,
инсайты, озарення і дає йому мудрость.
І вот у кожного із нас є історії наших прошлых кризисів,
які ми можемо розказувати через першу схему арки героя.
І по факту це форма, в якій ми можемо упакувати мудрость на собственному примері.
Це дуже класний, завжди вовлікаюший і здоровий контент через личні історії.
І отчасти це щось близьке до того, що сьогодні було у Лери на виступлении.
Хоча там не по арку героя ця історія була.
Але арка героя ідеально підходить для цього пункту, п'ятого.
З внутрішнього спокійства, тому що коли ми вже прожили кризис, прожили болю, викристалювали мудрость, ми вже спокійно к цій темі, і ми можемо спокійно розказати цю історію.
Прошлих долгов, прошлих отношеньків, прошлих фокапів і так далі.
Не знаю, що робити вам з цим матеріалом, я не можу, і не хочу, у мене даже не такої мотиви кого-то перетащити з травматического контента в здоровий контент.
Ми просто знаємо, що це є, і ми можемо осознавати, що це неотъємлива наша внутрення робота.
Давайте це так і оставимо, без якого-то логичного завершення.
На черзі у нас Юрий, потім Анна.
Давайте сначала, Анна, я в конец, я ще доделаю. Скільки успію доделати, стільки доделаю.
Найбільше відповідно.
Найбільше відповідно Анна, потім Юрий.
Якщо можна, ще я, якщо я успею.
І Наталья, звісно.
У нас відео до 16.00,
тому за часом ми, можливо, даже 4-х успеюємо.
Ну, давайте пока так.
Хорошо, Анна, приветствую ще раз.
Приветствую.
Мені, звісно, волнительно, а не без цього.
Виступала ли я когда-то на публіке?
Да, выступала, когда играла на рояле.
Но сьогодні хочеться позвучати для вас голосом, а именно словом.
Ви часто слышите такие слова, как «состояние», «трансформация», «сознання», «ретриты»,
«саморазвитие», «мотивация», «бла-бла-бла-бла-бла».
Вопрос для чего? Чтобы что?
Наверно, ви дадите ответ один, щоб чувствувати себе счастливым.
Мене звати Анна Карель.
Я предприниматель, я стратег, я ментор-коуч, я визіонер, гедонист, я опять бла-бла-бла-бла.
Але саме головне, я люблю создавати, я люблю творити.
І коли-то я задала себе питання, як, а як можна створити себе настроєння?
І що таке настроєння?
В който момент ко мене приходить відповідь, що настроєння – це нас троє, нас троє.
Це тело, разум і душа, це мисли, чувства, дійсно, можна ще так сказати.
Представте себе ситуацію, ми просипаємся утром під будильник,
чи ти просипаєшся утром під будильник, і тело таке, о Богі, я хочу ще поспати,
ще п'ять минут, не хочу нікуди вставати.
Разум говорить, давай, у нас сегодня важні дела,
У нас проєкт, дедлайн, а вечером ще вебинар.
А душа говорить, боже, я ж когда-то була просто щастлива того,
що світило Солнце.
В кой-то момент ти вже п'єш кофе на кухні утром,
і у тебе йдет собрання цих троих людей.
Причем то собрання, на котре тебе особо ніхто не приглашав.
І що ж таке настроєння?
Іногда ми починаємо вправлять собою для того, щоб чувствувати себе краще.
Хоча все добре, діти, робота, сем'я, але що-то внутрі не то.
І каже, що настроєнне – це щось про що-то хороше.
І должно бути добре, все 2-4 на 7.
на самом деле це такий маркер некий сигнал о том, що о ком же із-за цих троих ты забуваєш
тело тебе кажется нужно расслабити ще прийти в какой-то курс по саморазвитию разум проверить
еще несколько техник или послушать советы на ютубе и о душе мы вообще часто говорим
«Хватить тряпку, соберись!»
Але насправді настроєння – це коли в гармонії все.
І душа, і разум, і тело.
Порой нашому телу просто віддіхнути і віспатися.
Нашому разуму нужна тишина і спокійство від мыслі.
От душі к морю і просто побігати босіком,
чи встретитися з друзями, поболтати в прекрасній компанії.
О тому, щоб дістигати в кожній з цих троїх Лічностей в нас гармонію,
я проведу ефір 20-го числа в середу з Настей Виноградовою,
де я більш подробно розкажу, як все-таки дістигати ці три єдинства.
Я називаю це Святой Троїцей, нас троє.
Тому що коли ми розтроєнни, ми не в балансі.
Тому приглашаю в середу на 19.30.
Настя, я вже немножко анонсирую наш с тобою ефір.
І ми це обсудимо.
Ви зможете задати вопросы і поработати.
У мене все.
Умничка, сердечки, будь ласка, в студию.
Я дуже волновалась, це реально було мое первое публичное выступление.
Да, серйозно?
Я не имею в виду, коли я играю на клавишах, там нет стеснення, а именно вот,
чтобы говорить через голос проявляться, це впервые.
Боже, я вообще не сказала, я думаю, это 101-е какое-то.
що чувствуешься зараз в телі? Такой некий триумф внутренне расширення. Прямо внутренняя
какая-то пора, самоуваження. Я дуже довго боялась, ано свершилось. Я б, наверное,
ще долгом могла говорити і ще будеш говорити у тебе щось є таке ощущение що тебе хочеться
ще говорити конечно хочеться розкри все троє що таке як тело ми можем давати їму радість
як ми можем давати радість душе як ми можем давати радість нашому разуму і як приходити в
в цю конгерентність, в цю щастя, в состояния і гармонія.
Це хороший признак, що хочеться говорити ще.
Молодець, я горжусь тобою, ти прекрасна.
У тебе все конгруентно.
І голос, і речі, і внешність, і смысл, і подача, і состояние.
У тебе є це настроєння.
Прекрасне почало, мені дуже подобається, і хук з питання, я виступав ли я публічно, ну це прекрасне почало, я прям представляю, як його на сцені можна обіграти, пауза невероятна, хороша, глибина, гли
бина, нету никакої спешки, тема не заеджена, прямо достойна.
Аня, не знаю, я думав, це 101-е виступлення, мені даже, ну, критика какая? Критика, це чому ти ще не проявляєшся, чому це ще не 101-е виступлення, а така критика.
Тут треба сказати багатарність Насті, она реально мене втащила, она просто мене потащила зараз за руку і говорит, так, ми проводимо з тобою ефір, це буде перший прямий ефір.
Ось це я розумією, я теж такий, ну, треба брати і кидати воду, і людина научиться плавати.
Окей, окей, спасибо за підтримку.
Умничка.
Щас, що-то я хотів ще важке сказати.
Ну, я заслухався, я успокоївався, прямо для мене це була какая-то така медитация.
Аня, ти готова. Дійсно. Знай, що у тебе все є.
Не так, щоб дійсно, як хочеш, так і роби.
Ну, у тебе все є.
Хтось хоче, може щось додавити, поділитися?
І именно об цьому було і речі ще коли раніше, коли вона писала полгода назад в чат «Скоро я проведу виступлення», коли я її заставив. І так і злилась з цього процесу. І, наконец-то, к ней дошло. Брав
о! Аминь.
Ну, не всегда, получается, заставить.
Нужно чеку.
Аня, що я хочу тебе сказати?
Ти прекрасна.
Я чуваю, що цей ефір буде прекрасний монолог.
Я буду слушати, внимати і знай.
Цей ефір буде ровно стільки йти, скільки ти хочеш.
Якщо він буде більше часа йти, ми його зальюємо на Ютуб.
Якщо він йти буде менше часа, ми його оставимо в ефірі.
Ми будемо робити все, що нам хочеться.
Аня, ти крута, мені так подобається, і твій бла-бла-бла, і твоя така розслаблення, і ти говорила із сили, і то, о чому ти говориш, ти этим обладаєш, грубо кажучи, як сапожник з сапогами, і ти розпол
агаєш, і к тебе по-любому на цей ефір, ну, хто услышит, все пойдут, молодец, дуже круто, благодарю.
Я прямо захотелся з тобою провести прямой ефір.
Ну, я совсем не тушить, я в цьому смыслі почти безумвязаний.
Домашне задання тебе, Аня, вот какое-то.
Сегодня купить себе что-то, чтобы отметить триумф,
как-то себя наградить.
Первое выступление, вот это тебе домашне задання на сегодня, окей?
Окей, я подумала, да.
Можете себя чем-то побаловать или запланировать что-то?
Але сьогодні запланироватися, якщо це якийсь місця, то це не сьогодні, але ти сьогодні його запланируєш.
Не знаю, я прям горжусь. І тут даже абсолютно немає ніякої, навіть, моєї заслуги. Тут є просто твоя власність,
Которая к тому вже готова і созрела.
Тому прекрасно.
Хорошо.
Якщо помните, год назад ми виділися у Юлі.
Конечно, помню.
Коли я стояла, волос дрожит, руки дрожат.
Боже, що говорити?
Куда, як спрятатися?
Да, цей год все-таки дал мне можливість
вот эту вот уверенність внутрішнюю приобрести.
Що знань було завжди багато,
а вот зараз просто спокійство прийшло.
Така внутрення опора, в якій всі мечтають.
Це дійсно достойно, щоб займати місце, пространство.
Кто у нас следующий? Наталя, по-моєму, хотіла?
Да. Тут у мене не перше виступлення,
но я заметила і проговаривала, вже прописала Рут
после її выступлення,
що мене не волнительно
выступати перед незнакомими,
мене волнительно
выступати перед своими.
Я потім пойду
со своими размышлениями в цю тему.
Чесно признаюсь, волнуюсь.
Волнуюсь, як ніколи, у мене даже сердце вилетає.
І це буде моя така победа,
больша победа.
Я хочу продолжити тему Ани.
ми всі зі собралися, люди, допомагаючі професії, і ми всі зучаємо моделі, теорії, техніки, знаємо про прив'язаності, про регуляцію, про частиць Лічності.
І кожен день ми щось читаємо про психологію, кожен по своєй тематике про кочінг.
А коли в останній раз просто так двигались і танцевали, просто, дому, тому що хотівось,
тому що почувствовали, услышали музику, яка нравится,
коли себе позволяли просто йти за телом.
І ми живем в епоху психологізації, коли все стали настільки умні,
коли всі шли в терапію, і це нормально.
Коучинг — круто, подкасты про травму, тревогу, внутрінього ребінка.
Мільйони слушателей набирає.
Але що мене не відпускає,
це чому люди годами, десятилетиями бувають в терапії,
а відчування внутріннього счастья немає.
Немає понимання, що мене робить щастливою,
що мене наслаждає в моїй житті.
Откритость, честність.
Почему к этому так тяжело прийти?
Где природность, живая свобода?
Та свобода, с которой рождается ребёнок
і которую куда-то теряет взрослая.
Понимаєте?
Я не говорю, що психологія не работает.
Она работает.
Але щось важне ми упускаємо.
І що именно?
То, що наше тело — це не просто тело.
Це архив.
Архив на мільйоні роки,
коли кожний рефлекс, кожна реакція, накопленний опит выживання, записаний не в книгах, а в клетках, в нейронних цепях, в самой структуре нервной системи.
Блуждающий нерф еволюционировав серед звуков природы.
Он буквально умеет отличать шелест-лист от шума трафика.
Только один із них говорить ему «ты в безопасности».
И догадайтесь, какой.
Але це тільки верхній слой.
Ідемо глибше, це родовая пам'ять.
Те, що передавалось не через слова, а через тело, через ритуал, через прикосновення, через совместний ритм.
Це знання не ісчезло, оно живет в нас, в тому, що нам так добре у води,
почему барабанний ритм, що-то буде внутри,
почему хочеться піти, коли больно.
Тело помнит то, що ми давно забули.
І давайте дивимося на те, що робили наші предки.
Тому що вони не просто жили біже к природі, вони вистраивали цілі системи психологічної регуляції задовго до того, як з'явилося це слово.
І колективний плащ.
В славянській традиції були плакальщиці, жінчі, які спеціально приглашалися на похорони.
Вони плакали з сем'єю, громко, телом, словами.
Не тому, що їм було так погано, а тому, що горе нельзя проживати в одиночестві.
Тому що тело має пройти через горе, а не заморозити його.
Сьогодні ми знаємо, що непрожите горе становиться депресією, прожите становиться силою.
Вони це знали без нейронауки, просто називали по-другому – хороводи.
Синхронне движення в кругу синхронизують сердечні ритми участників.
І це не метафора, це ізмерима фізіологія.
Зеркальні нейрони активуються,
Ощущення єдинственне возникає на телесному рівні.
Люди відчувалися частиною чого-то більшого,
І тревога відступала.
Не тому, що вони прорабували триггер,
А тому, що тело получило то, чого искало.
Ритуал у огня.
Созерцание огня виводит мозг в состояние альфа-волн.
То саме расслабленное, осознанное присутствие,
которое мы сейчас воспроизводим через медитацию.
Плюс тепло, близость и совместное молчание.
Групповая терапія. Без ведущего. Бесплатно и каждый вечер.
Ритуальный гнев. В разных культурах были специальные ритуалы для выхода ярости.
Битье в барабаны. Крик в лесу.
Ритуальные поединки, которые не были войной.
вони були розрядкою, злость не подавлялась,
она проживалась, принималась, выходила через тело,
тому що люди розуміли, сдержанна злость убиває знутри.
Река, земля, лес — це не було віддіхом на природі, це була регуляція.
Вода збрасує статичне напряження буквально фізично.
Босові ноги на землі снижають кортизол.
І знаєте, що було общим в цьому всім?
Менше стыда, менше закрітості і менше життя в голові.
А тепер посмотрите на нас.
Ми прячемся, ми ізолюємся.
І це не просто привычка, це защита.
Але от кого? От чого?
Где-то в процесі цивилизации нам сказали,
твої чувства — це лична проблема.
Твоя злость — це стыдно.
Твоє горе — це слабость.
Твоє тело з його порівами — це щось, що потрібно контролювати.
І ми переехали.
Ми переехали з тела в голову, там безпасніше, там можна аналізувати, объясняти, рационалізувати, там не треба чувствувати.
Ми перестали танцевати, тому що стало стыдно, перестали піти, тому що поменялись стандарти голоса, перестали плакати вместе, тому що це слабо, перестали злитися відкріто, тому що це не красиво.
І тело без своїх тисячелетних інструментів
начало кричати язком симптомів, тревогою, усталостю з утра,
слезами в машині, тому що більше негде,
хронічною улыбкою все добре, в яку ми самі не віримо.
І тоді, коли появилась психологія, масова, необхідна,
але часто працювала там же, де і сломалась,
в голові, словами і аналізом, а тело стоїть рідом і ждет.
І тому я создала ретрит не як віддіх і не як інтенсив з домашніми заданнями, а як пространство, де тело наконец получає то, чому так тосковало.
Три дня на Дністрі, 26-28 мая.
Первий день — ярость, телесные практики на выход агрессії, дыхання, которое розмораживає то, що ми годами держали.
Вторий день — река, молчання на воді, медитання на сапі.
Река забирає лишнє.
Вона робила це тисячі роки, вона умеє.
І третій день — тишина, границі, інтеграція і женський крок.
Ти уєдеш не віддохнувшій,
ти уєдеш інтегророній, з телом, яке знову твоє,
зі ощущенням, яке не треба розуміти головою,
тому що вона живет ниже.
Благодарю за ув'нення.
Наталія, благодарю.
Восхитительно. В цьому выступлі є четка позиція автора, четкі його цінності. Не абстрактна психологія, а тут є конкретна, за що я топлю, какую культуру изучаю.
І це якраз то, к чому я вас і призываю – транслировати свої ценності.
Звучить класно, що в початку був текст, коли я починав, я зразу зрозумів, для кого це.
Тобто це не для всіх людей, це для спеціалістів, для всіх, хто в професії.
Це було зрозуміло по першим строкам.
Як себе зараз чувствую?
Я відчуваюся так же саме, як іду,
що у мене сердце вилітає,
і я потім розберуся,
хто стояв со сторони кого,
і кому я боялась, що мене услышат,
тому що є чувство,
що я все-таки боялась,
що мене хтось услышит.
І, скоріше всього, це «привіт, мама чи папа».
В общем, я в наслаждений,
у мене голос дрожав,
але то, що я хотела передати, я передала.
І в самому діля, для мене ця тема важна,
і я хочу донести то,
що в ні одній психології єдиной треба жити,
тому що треба чувствувати, як і говорила Аня,
триєдинство, тело, і я горюю цей темою,
я її люблю і стараюсь доносити до жінчин.
Вот зараз ти, коли говориш, запомню этот тонну войсу,
опять же, він твій, аутентично настояще,
він чуть відчувається від того, як ти читала.
Вот твоя харизма, твоя настоящесть.
Ми на цю настоящесть можемо одевать різні архетипи,
там, разные состояния, в зависимости от времени, места, обстоятельств.
Ну, вот, у тебе є аутентичність, вона прекрасна.
Несмотря на то, що текст ти читала,
першу половину выступлений не було особо заметно,
що ти читала текст по-чувствам, я имею в виду.
А втору половину выступлений – це було даже не мило особого значення.
Ти дуже по-настоящому читаєш.
Домашне задання, тобі обязательно провести ефір на цю тему.
Тільки ефір, коли вже будеш проводити, то більш персоналізованно і підготовлено.
Це прямо достойне внимання.
Тобто, я не знаю, ти транслируєш це в блогі чи ніхто,
але вокруг цього прям цей контент-план можна підстроити.
Да, да. Це прекрасний матеріал, прекрасний.
І в підтримку тебе, я розумію, що іноді у нас ці тригери, психіка, не хуже мене це все знаєте,
піднімають пройшову бізнательну пам'ять, але це не мешає нам проявлятися.
Ми можемо, нам необязательно протерапевтируватися повністю, ми можемо проявлятися, нести цінності.
Якщо ці цінності сильніше для нас, ніж той страх, який ми сподіваємо.
Поэтому, навіть якщо ти боїшся, ну, окей. Чуть-чуть, там, де-то що-то внутри відбувається, ну, нічого страшного.
Я несу то, що мені важливо. Мені не потрібно бути ідеальною, щоб говорити про те, що мені важливо.
Тому, ти молодець.
Благодарю.
Да, Лена.
Я хотіла сказати, що, Наташ, дуже багато.
Я, якщо чесно, навіть не виділа, що Наташа читала.
Я просто на слух її розпринимала.
Я не поняла, що она читала.
І це якось вшло від душі, по-живому, по-настоящому.
Наташ, дуже круто.
І сразу природа ця представляється.
І сразу хочеться туди.
Молодець.
Так, соглашусь, я б теж на ритрит.
Я обожаю телесні практики, живой формат.
Прекрасно. Анастасія.
Наташа, спасибо тебе за те, що окунула, знаєш, так, в історію, окунула к істокам в мире, тут еволюцій, быстрого течення, забываем, хто ми і відкуди, да, з земли ми вийшли, в землю ми війдем.
І що ти включаєш тело. У мене якраз, це моя тема болезненная, тому що я с телом дуже багато. Головастик, знаєш, без тела було. І це дуже актуально, це дуже включає. І не нагружає якими-то новомодними
техниками. Не нагружає якими-то. І вот пойди ще сделай це і в спеціалі возьми 50 кг.
А обычний простой танец дома включає і возвращає тебя.
Я тебе дуже благодарю.
Приглашаюся в ефір на свою страницу з цією темою.
С удовольствием поделюсь зі своїми підписчиками.
Класно. Спасибо большое. Чесно. От душі спасибо.
Я і так понимала, чому у Леры слези шли после її выступлення.
Спасибо. У мене страх. Калатання моєго серця успокоїлося.
Спасибо большое.
Наталі, необыкновенна просто, я повторю за девочками, я полностью погрузилась в атмосферу, я видела этот огонь, лес, ощущала, то есть ты вообще полностью забрала внимание, ощущения, у меня в какой-то
момент были мурашки по ногам, потом шел холод по ногам, это круто, и это очень важная тема в нашем современном мире про ощущения и про природу, в общем, крутая, молодец.
і і касательно даже тема ниша дальше это буде только в ценності живой формат оффлайн телесной
практики это прям то что необходимо мир растет а и каждый день становиться в разы там и спешка
суетанта никому это мы хотим чистоты свободы спокойствия и вкусу жизни здесь сейчас поэтому
Та лінія, яку ти транслируєш, вона більш чем достоєна внимання.
І да, ви зараз багато чуєте цей эффект, який я і намереваюся вас розпроизвести.
Тобто практичний опыт, безпосної групової динамики,
де ми можемо потренироватися, поговорити, поощупатися, выступити,
здесь получить этот опыт.
І далі вже в своєм мірі, в соцсеті, живі формати, сцена.
Нам встановлються там гораздо проще і легше проявляться,
говорити о себе, о своїх ценностях, реализовувати свій потенціал,
говорити «да», говорити «нет».
Потому що ми тут получили этот опыт на уровні ощущений.
ми десь потренировалися, хто не пользується цією можливостю,
знайдіть таку середу, будь лікарний, оффлайн-курс, актірський, ораторський,
де ви зможете телесно і практично потренироватися,
щоб більше свободно і комфортно чувствувати себе в повседневній житті
і в ваших професіональних задачах.
Так, ми переходимо до Юрію.
— Ні, я хотіла талі коментарі вставити. — Давай, що?
— Мені аж захотілося та їжка триватися і поїти просто босиком прогулятися.
Вспомніть, як це було.
Я роки два тому був в Армінії на ретреті, і ми прям босиком гуляли.
Я всюди потім босиком гуляв цілий тиждень по Армінії.
Заходив в ресторани босиком, всі на мене так дивились.
Але в цьому є свій ранний особий вайп.
Я дякую за оце нагадування цих відчуттів.
Сьогодні теж під обосяком прогуляюся, честь цього.
Так, так, я теж на цьому акцентировав увагу.
Добре, Юрій, раз ти вже вийшов на сцену, просимо.
Що, ви готові?
Після мого виступу вам буде важко думати про щось інакше.
Так, капітан.
Добре, погнали. Ви знаєте, що я люблю вийобуватися, але тут цей спосіб буде причасний всіх до вас.
Я сьогодні зранку пішов в душ і побачив, як це має бути пробачення, прощення.
Вчора з Ланою не вийшло прощення студентів з експертом.
Я сьогодні вирішив зробити вам всім подарунок, щоб ми всі запам'ятали Дениса прекрасного.
яких було дуже багато, дуже класних, що він вас супроводжував і надалі з цим всім,
і паралельно цьому показати вам, як АІ підсилює експерта у 26 році.
У мене до вас буде одне питання, щоб ви зафіксували свої думки.
Скільки на це треба часу і грошей було рік назад або навіть зараз у вашій картинці?
А я це зробив буквально за дві години від моменту, коли сказав до моменту зараз.
Не все працює ідеально, але ми покажемо, що вийшло.
Перше.
АІшка оцифрувала всіх вас.
Оп, вже працює.
Оцифрували всі знання.
У нас було 11 годин лекцій, 361 ідея і 37 практик.
Те, що ми починаємо забувати, АІ запам'ятав за вас.
Ми прийшли разом три уроки.
Основи, голос лідерства, сила присутності.
Денис відкрив нам інтегровану дисципліну.
де тіло актора, психіка-психолога, душа-наставника
і дія спортивного психолога зливаються в одну простоту.
Приврати все, що між тобою і твоєю правдою.
У цій програмі кожен з вас і окремо програма для режисера.
22 учасники, активних тих, які АІ запам'ятав з ваших лекцій.
12 програм і один режисер.
Кожному з вас подарунок.
Це особисте АІ-партнер, куди ви пишете тему виступу, бажання,
і він вам зробить виступ, виходячи з рекомендацій Дениса Батьковича.
От, тут є карта всіх персонажів, в якій зібраний кожний відгук по кожному з вас, який давав Денис, наприкладу, відкрилася Анастасія Намбе Доградова. Ми відкриваємо.
Підприємець. 29 років не з особистого бренду, а через систему, команду і відповідальність. Що Денис побачив тобі? Ця яркість, ця суперсила, ця живість. Я реально був, у мене був 15 до твоєго виступл
іння.
Ти багатьом давала повернуту зв'язку, прямо така жива, аутентична, настояще класна.
І коли ти почала читати, це зовсім інша людина.
Де страшно, йдемо її робимо.
Категоричність буває доброю, а буває догматичною злою.
Добра категоричність, коли ми чітко розуміємо свої цінності і смисли.
Якщо ми не категоричні, скоріше за все, ми хочемо вгодити всім, а не своїй аудиторії.
Тут описані твої сильні сторони, описані твої зони росту, описані наступні кроки практики, розібрані.
І прям я зробив, щоб їжка зробила персональний від Денису якийсь офер.
Тобі пропонується один-на-один коучинг з Денисом.
І так і по-кожному.
Ваше оцифрований фідбек, виходячи з цих штук.
Це все задеплоєно, потім скину.
Далі.
Є 37 практик оцифрованих.
Тобто ви можете зайти і такий, так, сьогодні ви мені позайматися ораторським мистецтвом, а давайте ми візьмемо, не знаю, давайте в праву 13, я люблю цифру 13.
І в нас в цифрі 13 зрувий контакт із трьома людьми.
При виступі перед групою в великому залі, особливо коли прожектор не дозволяє бачити обличчя, створювати ефект персонального зв'язку з кожним через систематичне переміщення погляду по трьох точках, л
івий, центральний, правий.
І ми тут тренуємося, як зробити і так далі. Це все оцифровано. І ви це все можете знову пройти в зручному для себе форматі. Далі йдемо. І таких штук вас Денисом подарував ваш 37. Ми тільки це все гар
но випакували.
Клода виступів класу, спільна бібліотека. Учасники першого потоку, які пройшли програму в боті, можуть поділитися своїм виступом з класом.
Анонімно або зміням. Клода росте, як ми ростемо.
Тобто я тут зроблю виступи. Це Клод придумаю, навіть не знаю, що я там придумаю.
І, бо у вас є бот, давайте перевіримо, як він працює.
Хто хоче в лайф-режимі перевірити роботу бота?
Це буде тестовий формат, я не знаю, в нього вийшло чи не вийшло, але ми подивимося, хто найсміливий.
Давайте мені. Одного обожаючого.
Давайте Денис.
Давайте.
Денис, я вам скидываю ссылку на бота.
Прямо сюди в Телеграм.
Ой, сюди в чат.
Найдіть його в Телеграм.
Можете включити демонстрацію екрана тепер ви.
Я вам віддам це право.
І ви протестируєте, що він зробив.
Так, одну секундочку.
Я просто не был к этому готов и иду, иду в чатик, в чатик, Юрию, що треба зробити, його скопити, да, і як його в Телеграмі.
Візьміть, включайте демонстрацію, да, і зараз зробимо все.
Иду, иду, щас.
Так, одну секундочку.
У мене таке хвилювання було, я його переборював, але мене трохи попустило.
Я не знаю, чи це було зуміти, чи не було, у мене прямо жар піднімався.
Але трохи попустило.
Що-то чувствує, що це не те в твоїх останніх словах.
Ага, ага. Що робити?
Вставляйте просто пошук.
заходити це оформлення цей бот подарунок класу м1 поток кураторського мистецтва я допоможу
побудувати твій виступ за методологію Дениса Чернишова Тріада хто я для кого для чого 10
структур 4 тони 8 фокусів 37 прав 3 кроки отримуєш персональну структуру Let's go давайте перевіримо
як це працює.
Привіт, допоможу побудувати виступ за методологією
наськрізного дисципліна, ораторське мистецтво, курсу МСММ.
Три кроки.
Програмка виступу, презентацію.
Поїхали.
Тема виступу.
Зараз, давайте.
Поль за раннього подйому.
Наскільки часу виступ?
Десять мін.
Все.
Окей, поль за раннього подйому.
Хто у залі, що ти хочеш, щоб вони зрозуміли.
Давайте. Школьники, 9 клас. Важність дисципліни і енергії.
І одну конкретну дію. Встретили рассвет.
Вау! Тони голосу одразу – мудрець, воїн, друг, червник.
Друг.
Так, згенерувати.
Тут, в ідеалі, якщо все вийде, має бути сайт і презентація, вправи для того, щоб відбуватися до виступу.
Наскільки це вийде, я не знаю, тому що це видикло буквально пів години назад, щоб це було не просто текст того, який він мені зробив.
І я такий, а давай ти зразу будеш презентацію робити повноцінну і цілий коучинг-курс.
Якщо б було ще пару годин, як я би це допрацював, то воно би точно працювало, але тут ми дивимося.
Показати, що у мене паралельно відбувається?
Як воно працює, хочете? Можете дивіться. Він паралельно пише, бачите, що топік – польза раннього підйому, друг.
Він паралельно все генерує, тригериться на все у вас.
Це ось сьогодні ми з ним робили стільки роботи, поки я слухав.
Ого. Юра, це просто…
Я ще зробив преміум дизайн, це була ще одна презентація в такому преміум стилі.
Не просто одна, а дві.
Стан важливіше слова.
Тріада, хто, для кого, для чого, структура плюс тон, магнетизм, антидот перфекціонізму.
Тільки правда дає присутність.
По кожному з вас, з учасників цієї висновки, де ви можете...
Василь тут з цими... А, тут немає цього прикладу, я там не будемо.
О, і був дуже класний момент, коли Лєра виступала, він якраз про Лєру і робив.
От, я прямо це за скрінув і один цей внутрішній чаток поставив.
З мінусів нічого не виступив, він має там сира, зелені, салату.
Не знаю, це треба допрацьовувати, але ми маємо таку штуку.
Денис каже, я надаю людям нові знання, я нагадую людям те, що вони забули в хаосі багатозадачності.
Ваші слова?
Так.
Аішка вирішила їх цей.
Дякую. І далі ми дивстуємо далі.
Це те, що ми встигли зробити за дві годинки.
Але давайте, Денис, вам відправилося чи не відправилося, ми дізнаємося.
Смотрю, смотрю, смотрю.
Наскільки у нас працює.
Ні, ще поки чекаємо. Три-чотири години.
Ще працює?
Так, обмінно те, що показуєш, що ще працює.
Ми зараз ще поговоримо і думаю, що... Ой.
Зараз, це була моя презентація про те, що ключовий посил той, що якщо ви не почнете використовувати AI,
як ви бачите, потенціал який, ви можете або зараз дуже сильно виграти в ринку, або залишитися не стільки позаду,
що потім нас догнати буде дуже важко. Але це може стати вашою перевагою.
Тому що, як на мене, оця робота, що я пропрацював за дві години, для мене два роки назад,
коли я був у InfoBiz, на це б пішло декілька місяців, я впевнений, і ресурсові команди, ну ой-ой-ой-ой,
тільки щоб бота зробити і зібрати команду, то б пішли тисячі доларів, я впевнений.
Щоб оцифрувати експертність і так далі. І як на мене, зараз вже час, щоб продати отакі випускання,
коли викладач просто може взяти, оцифрувати кожного, зробити кожному якісь штуки, прикольні.
Тому що якщо би з Денисом просто попрацювати вечором, він би додав якісь свої ітерації, інтеграції, це би було прям вав, класно, супер.
Я думаю, і так класно вийшло прикольно, але наскільки це можна було би докрутити?
Я вважаю, що зараз контент має переходити на такий рівень і на щось нижче я не готовий розраховувати.
І це буде велика ідея, яку буду трансливати ринку і показувати перевагу всіх тих, хто буде її брати.
Так, мене щось прийшло.
Так, давайте.
Ну, ти, звісно, Юрий, приковав наше внимание.
Смотрите, скільки всього.
Так, не знаю, як це відкрити.
Бо, ти надіслав якісь формати документів, які дуже важко Денису відкрити.
Візьми, будь ласка, надійшли йому в чат HTML-формат, який він легко відкриє.
Я відправляю в лайф-режимі, будь ласка.
Я кажу, може не вийти, може вийти.
А що він за формати відкрит?
Ну, давайте сейчас, Юрий, давай так сделаем, чтобы наше время организовать.
Ми зараз прям пообщаємся.
Цель твоєго виступлення, она прекрасна, ты включила наше внимание.
Я думаю, це требує доработки.
Якщо зараз получится, я, конечно, відкриваю і всім покажу.
І це дійсно вау-вау-вау.
Я в цьому немножечко динозавр.
Але круто, що це становиться можливим і доступним.
І, в принципі, класно, що є такі експерти, які можуть це все згенерувати, необхідно саме в цьому розбиратися.
І, да, ми можемо учитувати епоху, щоб бути, так сказати, в струі.
Це, звісно, дивительно.
Я не знаю, як комментируювати такі речі. Знаю, що мене просто лох.
Розадовод, якщо зараз получится, то відкриваю і поділюсь.
Давайте, у нас осталось 15 минут з вами, 16.
І я би в цілому хотів з вами пообщатися в такому свободному форматі,
і щоб ви відповіли себе на цілищі питання.
Тобто сьогодні ми розібрали, я напомню, основніши оратори, ми практиковали, ми розібрали тему уровня слушання, ми поговорили про ненасильственну коммунікацію, ми осознали разницю проявленностей з
травмой і здорової позиції.
І зараз я хочу, щоб ми підвели итоги. В цілому, понятно, що ми не успіємо послухати кожного, але хоча б письменно чи ментально відповіте себе на цілищі питання.
Що хорошого за всі ці 4 модуля було лише для вас?
Щоб цей опыт інтегривався, в більшій степені ви можете навіть на це задання заскринити себе зараз.
Ви можете виделити 10 минут, коли ми вже закінчимо, чи вечером, чи завтра, і підвести такі итоги.
Що хорошого було лише для вас по пунктам? Мінимум 10 пунктів.
За що ви можете бути благодарни, за що ви благодарите себе в цьому обученню, за що ви благодарите групу, мир, вселенню в цьому обученню.
Я зараз більше про свої обучення, але в цьому можете і МСММ теж.
Але щоб сузити вектор сізнання, давайте про ораторське мастерство і публічне выступлення, яким ми займалися.
У вас була прекрасна група, підтримуюча.
Ви проявлялись, виступали, обритали практичний опыти.
І третій пункт не мене важний і більш практичний.
Що зараз ви планируєте зробити в ближайшому часі в контекції своєї проявленності?
Прямо два-три шага зафиксувати. У кого-то це провести ефір, у кого-то начать вести блог, у кого-то сделать запуск, у кого-то выступить на сцене большой, у кого-то упаковать свой блог. Ну, у каждого
своя история.
Давайте в живому форматі, хто хоче, визивайтесь, пожалуйста, ми пообщаємося, можна в свободному форматі, які у вас пожелання, що понравилось, що не понравилось, як себе чувствуете в цьому, пройдя так
ий базовий формат?
А можна я візьму свої 3 минути на себе і виступлю теж?
Пользуйся зіма. Буду виступати зіма.
Давай.
Просто я хотіла виступити на тему внутрініх конфліктів.
Потім я хотіла виступити на тревожність.
Давай, Настя, виступити 3 минути.
Да, і мелкою, а я вже виступаю.
І моторику рук.
А потім я виступила, що саме важливе в своїй житті сейчас,
що я йду і іщу, що я вже нашла.
І ми часто вталкиваємся з тим,
що ми заходимо в красиві кімнати,
де люди приєтні і говорять о чому-то,
але при цьому себе чуваємо дуже одинокими.
Тому що мозк в цей момент він сканірує,
завжди сканірує на свій і чужій.
І коли ми знаходимо своїх, ми віддіхаємо.
Тому що там якраз можна перестати розповідати.
Вот коли я шла на це обучення, я думала, що я йду конкретно за інструментами, за знаннями.
Да, я їх получила, але, согласитесь, можна ж їх получить і в інтернете, і в ютубі, і в будь-якому іншому доступі.
Але то, що тут я обрела, це гораздо більше.
Це гораздо більше, це і є сам процес обучення.
Я тут нашла своїх.
Микеланджело говорив, я просто беру камень, не відсекаю все лишнє.
і вот свої люди, вони роботають також, вони відсекають все лишнє, вони видять тебе то, що ти не видиш сам в себе, вони тебе завжди підтримують, с ними не треба доказувати, їм не потрібно що-то роз'яс
нювати, вони розуміють з полуслова, вони сміються з тобою всі, а вони проживають одинаковий путь, вони задають одні і тежі питання.
І що я знаєте, саме головне я заметила, що сильні усиливають сильні.
Вони не конкуренту друг другу.
І рідом з своїми людьми ти обретаєш себе більше, чітче і ясніє.
Тому, дорогі мої, любі мої, родні люди, що я хочу вам сказати?
Проявляйтесь. Проявляйтесь, говорите, що думаєте, чувствуйте громко, багато.
Среди своїх.
Ваши всегда вас підтримують.
Іменно вони, ваше проявлене,
і притягають своїх, а чужих відсечуть.
Чужі вони нам і не потрібні.
Не теряйте друг друга.
Давайте продовжувати цей путь вместе.
Я думаю, що ми точно друг другу будемо полезни.
Просто так.
Просто тільки на тому, що ми є друг у друга.
Я вас искренне благодарю.
Весь цей год ми пройшли більшій путь.
Лично я пройшла путь от з вами, от восстановлення операций, болезней, диагнозів,
до человека, який ведет інстаграм і приглашає в прямі ефири на дуже важні теми.
Ви все бриллианты. Я вас всіх обнимаю і люблю.
Хто не підписаний, підписуйтесь, у нас прямі ефіри впереди.
Люблю кожного, обняла кожного.
Ви всі безцінні для мене.
Настя, благодарю тебе, знаєш, я помню твое выступлення второго і помню сейчас.
Вообще, це небо і земля настільки стала настояще, аутентична.
Зараз чувствується персоналізація, як комусь говориш,
ну, це дуже тепло, дуже искренне, дуже по-настоящому.
Я лично вижу величай прогрес, і тут, наверное, слово даже хочеться передати всім, хто тебе слушав.
Тебе можна говорити? Или Аня по очереди?
Дякую, я здерживала слізы.
Я не понимаю, що чуть-чуть у мене завісло.
Дякую.
Я поняла, що підкатываються слізы.
Тому що це дуже трогательно.
Це дійсно.
І ми приобріли здесь настояких,
своїх людей.
Це дуже важливо.
В епоху онлайна,
в епоху І.
Нас не заменит нічого.
Я имею в виду чистое человеческое отношение.
Тільки люди можуть чуствувати, і тільки ми можемо це друг другу передавати.
Тому це дуже цікаво.
А якщо повністюватися до курсу,
Наверно, найголовніше, що мене зацепило,
то, що я вонесла, це про своїх людей нейтральних і «Ану-ка, удиви мене».
І помню, я задала питання, що потрібно зробити для того,
щоб ту третю категорию перевести в своїх поклінників.
І відповідь, звісно, мене поразив.
як раз взагалі забудь об цьому, щоб тебе...
Тому що подобається цій третій категорії – це ти вже все, провалився.
Тобто це якраз відсутствие доказати і відсутствие
«Полюби мене, посмотри, який я класний»
і змістити свій фокус на тих людей, які приходять тобі
за твоєю підтримку, за твоєю словом, за твою уверенністью, за твоєю внутренням миром.
І для мене це стало дуже важним, коли ти сфокусувався на своїх людях.
Так ще так отрималося лаконичне перетекання Настіних слов к своїм людям.
І я завершу зараз, що наші люди — це наші сили. Сильним усіливає сильним.
Денис, дякую вас за цей прекрасний курс, за ту атмосферу,
яка м'яка, м'яка, обалакиваюча, я не знаю, я в восторге, мені було дуже приємно з вами общуватися, благодарю.
Передаю слово.
Я тож вернусь к Насті, начну с Насті. Настя, це була, знаєш, я тут така мисль, що як випускна річ, як річ на випускному, це було ідеально, і тож, як і у Ані, так даже підступили слези.
Тому що від обучення все одно встали вже.
Момент того, що зними нашлися свої,
і тут я взагалі вперше стыкнулася з людьми,
які не обесценивають,
де можна бути без масок,
де можна бути самою собою,
можна місце расти,
і все за тебе радуються.
І це дуже ценно.
На кожному модулю бралося щось своє.
На транзактному збирали Лічність,
А для себя здесь, на ораторському искусстві, я заметила две точки,
коли я соприкоснулася именно к своєй силі,
і після чого я почала розуміти, як мені треба проявляться.
Тому що до цього я ходила в масках, натягивала на себе якісь костюмчики не свої.
А ораторське искусство мені помогло почувствувати себе більш глибше.
І інструменты, які в Денис давали, я буду ще пересматривати, записувати,
Точно знаю, що вони ще більше усилят,
відкроють серце, тому що у мене теж ціль
проявлений істинності, честності, іскрінності.
І огромна благодарність.
Соглашуся з тим, що в самому діля
тут така атмосфера, пространство,
де мягко, безпосно і тепло.
Це було дуже ценно.
Благодарю.
Я благодарю вас. Я благодарю вас. Восхитительний, волшебний, удивительний. Я вас точно запомнил. Для мене тоже большая удача соприкоснуться с вами. Если я нужен, пишите, звоните, я на связи. Я вот
вижу, у меня Юрий уже пишет, там что-то пришло.
Ми, звісно, зараз відвідуємо, переглядемо.
Але давайте, Естафіату, якщо хтось хоче продовжити, то продовжимо.
У нас ще є п'ять минуточків.
Я хочу сказати спасибо. Я жалею так з течення обстоятельств, що я сьогодні...
Що самого основного полезноцяного ви для себе винесли? Що більше всього вам понравилось?
Ну, во-первых, я вспомнила, що я SMM, через чувства, через свої говорити з чоловіком.
Ну, і об'язательно пересмотрю, звісно, записи і возьму себе ще більше.
Більше.
Добро.
Я теж хочу сказати, що, наверное, більше всього, що я взяла з цього курсу,
Увереність в себе і уміння управлять своїм волосом,
знаходити свої сильні сторони і виходити і виходити і виходити.
Кожен раз, коли ми розмовляємо, ми виходити.
Не бояться виходити так і виходити.
Дякую вам багато.
Дякую, Юля, дякую.
А я тебе напишу, спрошу ще за ту структуру.
Мені дуже подобається.
І дякую за ті усі інструменти, якими ми будемо користуватися, зростати і обов'язково будемо передавати далі у світ от все, що ви дали нам. Дякую вам.
Благодарю, Олена. Благодарю.
Ну що, поставте сердечки, хто хоче бачити, як він у нас там сконвертировався.
Я запишу демонстрацію, і Юра там старався це все прямо.
Це все Клод пишет, це не я, це не мій аккаунт, це аккаунт нейронки от моєго імени.
Це не я писав, це я дискав, і справляй все.
Він пішов справлять. Не знаю, що там написано.
В общем, прийшли ли ви такі штуки, ми відкриваємо їх.
І тут польза раннього підйома.
Вона не відкрила, в вас демонстрація тільки телеграма ще стоїть.
Ні, а у мене прям...
Демонстрація в зумі стоїть тільки телеграмі того.
Ага, ну давайте вот так.
Є?
Да.
О, ну вот, польза раннього підйома.
Для кого?
Хто я?
Для чого?
Живе коло?
Друг, сьогодні я тренеру.
Ну в общем таке у нас є, якщо відкрити другу посилку
Ви якось оцініть з точки зору, наскільки це передає ті сенси, які ми вам давали
наскільки це може реально допомагати, чи це булшіт, ми облажалися з тим, що робили
Дайте якусь реальну оцінку
Мені в них, я ж не можу так швидко, мені здається, що там, якщо вникнути, там дуже здорово і круто
Ні разу не сказав, що промти пишуть. Чоловік, Юр. Другий сядет за агентом, і він напишет, що попало.
Давай правді в глаза дивитися. Юр, ти просто його класно обучаєш. Ти крутой. Все, точка.
Тут не я крутой, тут все так можуть. У мене є на обученні ж дівчини відсюди.
вони зробили те ж саме. Натали вон зробила себе сайт для реціта. Юлі страницю зайдіть,
посмотрите, просто перфекту. Кристина руку підняла, я їй теж показав інструмент,
она теж сказала, що до було. Типа, боже, це невероятно, це все. Спустя два часа діалога було,
Це стыдно сьогодні такої не діляти.
Разниця, не присвавити це мене, ви теж можете, хочу кожному показати, що ви це можете діляти, ви це должны діляти,
ну, це должно переворачивати ринок, должны двигати вперед, а не застрівати.
Хочу, щоб Денис сказав, як воно на справді, що б'ється, що не б'ється, що б'ється, що булшіт,
Ні, технологія херня, це джібітішні тексти, напиши пост, реально викликає його афект, живий фідбек справжній хочеться, а не типу...
Я думаю, що це однозначно дуже крута історія, крутой інструмент, треба в цьому розібратися, мені треба вникнути, я не можу так за одну минутку ще погрузитися, чуть-чуть інтернет ще скачет, і могу
чуть позже дати обратну зв'язку, і я думаю, що це буде дуже інтересно.
Дорогі друзі, я не буду задержувати вас. У нас 16.01. Я вас благодарю.
Ви дуже круті. Проявляйтесь, будь ласка.
Якщо у вас будуть возникати якісь трудної, сьогодні, я на связі, пишіть.
Я щедр на обратну связь, якщо буду потрібен як-то.
В інстаграмі ми є.
Саме цінне, що ми можемо зробити для цього міра – це бути реалізованими.
У кожного із вас є своя уникальна формула і талантов, і психотравм,
які сформували вот таку уникальність.
І тільки ви, має цей бриллянтик своєї уникальності,
можете дати миру то, що можете дати тільки ви, простите за тавтологію.
Поэтому здорово, що ми тут всі є, здорово, що ми йдемо путь самопознання.
Це дійсно то, чим достойно займатися в чоловічному телі, в чоловічій формі життя.
Я вас обнимаю, желаю всім удачі і желаю вам робити цей мир чище, осознанні, здоровіше через свою проявленість.
Будь то блог, будь то ваші проєкти, будь то жива сцена.
В общем, куди б ви не шли, що б ви не делали,
ви очищаєте цей мир і робите його радостніше, інтересніше, наповненні і здоровіше.
Дякую вам за вас.
І до нових зустріч.
Обязательно, якщо вживую мене відбуваєте, приходите.
Все, бістрій коментарі.
Бот работает сьогодні-завтра, на всякий случай.
Тому що на роботи через підписку має бути мак включений.
Якщо він не відповідає вам,
значить я виключив мак.
Якщо що, пишіть.
Хочу, щоб кожен з вас зробив своє вступлення.
Попробував. Як воно? Поповжувався технологією.
А у динозавров, які, взагалі, минус 5, може?
Попробуйте.
Попробуйте, напишіть мені, скажіть, що тут не вийшло.
Я зроблю, щоб у всіх вийшло.
Спасибо, Юра, ти лучше.
Я це знала завжди.
Все, друзі, до нових зустріч, спасибо, пока-пока.
Всего доброго, спасибо большое.
Пока-пока.